ORDER- MY NAME IS CHAIR STUDENT
ON MONDAYS EGGMAN LV CHAIRING
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. WELL I HAVE I
AM BRAND NEW SENATOR I HAVE
SERVED IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I
HAVE CERTAIN NEEDS HERE IS MANY
POLICY COMMITTEES BUT NEVER
BUDGET SO. AS WE- AS WE ARE
EMBARKING ON THIS NEW JOURNEY-
WITH MASKS AND DISTANCE AND YOU
ALSO HAVE A NEW CHAIR BUT WE
WILL BE PATIENT WITH EACH
OTHER. I'M SURE WE'RE ALL GOING
TO GET THROUGH IT- WE ALSO HAVE
ON THE COMMITTEE DR PAN AS WELL
AS AS A SENATOR MELENDEZ
DARKNESS UNDER PAN IS NOT ON
THE LINE RIGHT NOW CENTER
SENATOR BELINDA'S IS I'LL ASK
HER TO MAKE SOME OPENING
COMMENTS IN A FEW MINUTES. BUT
FIRST I'D LIKE TO SAY- THAT
DURING THIS TIME WILL BE DUE TO
THE COVERED WE ARE OFF ALL OF
MANY OF US ARE OPERATING
REMOTELY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. TO
NOT INSTANCE OF IN IN CENTRAL
GATHERINGS BUT EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM MUST WEAR A FACE MASK
AT ALL TIMES. AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING- THE HAS. TO
US SO WE CAN BE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THAT. WE'RE HERE HOLDING
THIS COMMITTEE HERE BUT PEOPLE
ARE AGAIN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY- ALL THIS TESTIMONY
WILL BE. REMOTELY TODAY FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR- COMPUTERS. THIS
WILL AID US AND FEEDBACK GOING
BACK AND FORTH- I GUESS EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO RECOGNIZE THAT
YOUR RATE YOU USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND PROMPT. ON EACH TIME
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN
MUTE PLEASE SELECT AND MEET
BEFORE SPEAKING. AND R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU ARE DONE WANT
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO.
PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. BUILDING
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID TO
STICK FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
YOUR DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN THIS. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING ROOM. OR
HAVE THE CONNECTIONS NEEDED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS. IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LIKE TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE JUST
IN FOR THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGY. AND I
WOULD ALSO SAY WE USUALLY AFTER
EVERY. ITEM ASK FOR- IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR THE L.
A. O. HAS COMMENTS. IT IS IN
ORDER SAVE TIME WE WON'T ASK
THEM EVERY SINGLE TIME I WILL
ASK THEM IF THEY DO HAVE
SOMETHING. TO RAISE THEIR HAND
AND THEN I WILL CALL ON THEM.
ALL RIGHT. AT THIS TIME. AND
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE I
SHOULD SAY WILL GO OVER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR.
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY. THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND
COVERED CALIFORNIA. I WOULD ASK
SENATOR MELENDEZ IF SHE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS AS THE VICE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SENATOR EGGMAN- I WILL BE VERY
BRIEF WITH A LOT OF INFORMATION
GROUP ARE JUST ONE STATE
FRAZIER TO BE HERE- WILL
REMOTELY WITH EVERYONE I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL THE
RESEARCH I HAVE A LOT OF VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUES. ON THERE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THIS YEAR- AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH EVERYONE TO
SOLVE THOSE PROBLEMS I THINK
CENTER AND MANY APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY. NOW
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
PRESENTATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. FOR CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY. HEY
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME
GOOD MORNING YES PLEASE- OF
WELCOME. HI SENATOR DR MAN THIS
IS MARCO ME CHIME THAT DEPUTY
SECRETARY AT THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. AND WILL
BE DOING A QUICK OVERVIEW AND
THEN WILL TURN INTO THE ITEMS.
ARE WE BEGAN I JUST ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF US AT HHS AND ALL
TWELVE DEPARTMENTS AND FIVE
OFFICES. I WE JUST WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
CHAIRMANSHIP AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS BUDGET
WE ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH CENTER AND- AS OUR
MELENDEZ OUT AS PART OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE SO WE'RE REALLY
EAGER TO GET TO WORK WITH YOU
ALL AND- AND ARE GRATEFUL TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER
WITH. THANK YOU START BY JUST
GIVING YOU A QUICK. OVERVIEW OF
OUR AGENCY. IN OUR PRICE. OVER
THE COURSE OF THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS AT AND EVEN TODAY. YOU
WILL HEAR FROM A NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES WITHIN
OUR AGENCY. AROUND THIS YEAR IS
A PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT WE
DELIVER. OUR IN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. AB WE
ARE FIRST AND FOREMOST FOCUSED
ON OUR RESPONSE TO THE
CORPORATE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
WHICH NOW HAS BEEN. OVER A YEAR
WITH REGARDS TO THIS RESPONSE.
WE'RE EQUALLY FOCUSED AS PART
OF THE PROJECT AND WHAT YOU
WILL SEE WITH REGARDS TO THAT.
AREA'S PIECES THAT WE HAVE ON
THE AGENDA TODAY AND IN THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS. IN BUILDING A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. NOT REALLY
BLACK CONTINUING TO HELP OUR
FIVE. AT THE VARIOUS EFFORTS
THAT HAVE.BEEN IN PLACE FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE.
ACCESS TO COVERAGE ACCESS TO
CARE. WE'RE EQUALLY- FOCUSED ON
INTEGRATING HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. HI THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF OUR
WORK. AND IT CENTERS ON THE
NOTION THAT. THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT WE ARE SERVING- WHO HAVE.
BOTH HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NEEDS. AND IT'S PARAMOUNT THAT
WE LOOK AT THAT TURNED OT OF
THEIR NEEDS- AND NOT. AT THE
BUREAUCRATIC STRUCTURES OF
GOVERNMENT WHAT I MEAN BY THAT
IS. REALLY LOOKING AT WAYS IN
WHICH WE WRAP OURSELVES AROUND.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD ASKING FOR SERVICES FOR
PROGRAMS. AND THINKING ABOUT
THEIR NEEDS T AND THEN
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE WRAP
OURSELVES AROUND THEM. AND SO
THE INTEGRATION OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. THERE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- YOU. GIVE
SOMEONE HEALTH INSURER COVERAGE
BUT IF THEY HAVE ACCESS TO FOOD
IF THEY KNOW HAVE ACCESS TO
HOUSING IF THEY DON'T ACCESS
TRANSPORTATION. THOSE ARE ALL
PARAMOUNT. TRUSTING THOSE
SOCIAL. OF HEALTH AND
ALTERNATELY REALIZING SOME
POSITIVE OUTCOMES ON THE HEALTH
SIDE. ANSWER COLLECTIVELY THAT
CONTINUES TO BE A PRIORITY RUN
INTEGRATION. FINALLY IT'S
REALLY ABOUT IMPROVING. THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE AMONG STATUS
I'M DYING CLUNES. INDIVIDUALS
WERE GETTING SERVICES FROM OUR
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELESS SERVICES
IT'S OUR FOSTER CHILDREN WHICH
ARE OUR CHILDREN AND THEY
AREN'T ALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
AND IS A PARAMOUNT THAT WE WORK
TO ENSURE. HEALTH AND WELL
BEING IT'S IT ALSO IS AN
IMPORTANT THAT WE WERE I THINK
ABOUT. THOSE INDIVIDUALS WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BOTH
INTELLECTUAL AND PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES CT IN WAYS IN
WHICH WE PROVIDE SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS FOR THEM AS WELL AND
SO. IN TOTAL THOSE FOUR OUT FOR
PRIORITIES REALLY INCOME PRESS
ARE WORKING AND IT'S HOW WE
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE BULK OF.
THE VARIOUS PROJECT COMPONENTS
ARE THERE ARE JUST NOT ONLY
HERE WITH REGARDS TO THAT HHS
SESSION TO YOUR HEARING AS PART
OF THIS VERY BEGINNING. ALL
TWELVE DEPARTMENTS AND FIVE
OFFICES WITHIN OUR ORGANIZATION
WE WANT TO BE PERSON CENTRED WE
WANT TO BE DATA DRIVEN WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. AS PEOPLE
ARE GETTING SERVICES. FROM US
THAT THEY'RE GETTING. HIGH
QUALITY SERVICES THAT WE HAVE.
UP WITH OUR LOW. ARE AND ALLOW
PIECE HERE IS A- OUR LOCAL. AND
TELLS WHICH IS OUT WHICH IS
SOMETHING VERY OF THIS HELPING
YOU SERVICES. DELIVER BY AT THE
STATE. AND THEY'RE NOT
CENTRALIZE ACTUALLY. IN THE
DELIVER CAL. AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND THAT IS REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE- IT
EACH PROGRAM AND THEN HAS THE
ABILITY TO REALLY LOOK AT THAT
THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THAT
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY AND IT IS
PARAMOUNT THAT WE CONTINUE THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
COUNTY PARTNERS. SO ABDUCTOR A
MINUTE I WILL START THERE AND
WITH REGARDS TO THE OVERVIEW
WHICH WAS ISSUE ONE. FIVE AND
WE WOULD BE HAPPY UNLESS YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR CENTER
MELENDEZ HAS ANY QUESTIONS. WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO GO. INTO
ISSUE TOO ON YOUR AGENDA. I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THIS
TIME. MELISSA NOTHING FOR ME
OKAY ALL RIGHT MY COLLEAGUES TO
GET TALKER WITH THE OFFICE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION IS GOING TO
TAKE LEAD AND PRESENTING TO YOU
AND ANSWERING HER QUESTIONS
WITH REGARDS TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO SENT YET. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
TUCKER WITH OFFICE SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION AND I'M HERE TO
DISCUSS THE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION PROJECT PHASE TWO
OF OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REQUEST CONTINUES THE EXISTING
TWENTY LONGER TERM RESOURCES
FOR THE COMPLETION OF PLANNING
EFFORTS AND ADDITIONAL
CONTRACTOR RESOURCES TO BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO- FOR THE FIRE. DEPARTMENTS
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WITH THIS
PROJECT THESE CONTINUE
RESOURCES ARE SPECIALLY NEEDED
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER OF
SYSTEMS AND PROGRAMS THAT WILL
BE IMPACTED BY THIS PROJECT AS
WELL AS A VERY AGGRESSIVE
SCHEDULE IN ORDER TO AVOID
FURTHER FEDERAL PENALTIES. OUR
SOLUTION THAT WE'RE BRINGING
FORWARD- WILL NEED TO INTERFACE
WITH MULTIPLE OTHER SYSTEMS
INCLUDING- SOME DH YES SYSTEMS
LIKE FEVER SERVICE MEDICARE.
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE- THE MEDI
CAL DATA WAREHOUSE AND LSO
WITH THE S. SYSTEMS FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTERS. IN OUR
PLANNING PROCESS WE DETERMINE
THAT THE STATE WILL USE AN OPEN
TENDER MODEL- FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF EDV SIMILAR
TO THE APPROACH BEING TAKEN
OTHER STATES. AND THIS IS GOING
TO GIVE FLEXIBILITY TO OUR
PROVIDERS AND WILL ACCOMMODATE
BOTH ARE AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULE AS
WELL AS THE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
AND DEPARTMENTS THAT THIS
PROJECT WILL SERVE. I'M
CURRENTLY WE HAVE SUBMITTED OUR
PAL STAGE THREE SOLUTION
DEVELOPMENT- PACKAGE CHIU CDG
IT WAS. SUBMITTED ON FEBRUARY
FIRST. AND WORKING VERY
CLEVERLY WAS CDG THE PROJECT
WAS ABLE TO RELEASE THE PRIME
VENDOR RFP- ON DECEMBER TWENTY
THIRD OF TWENTY TWENTY- IN
ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE
SOLICITATION PROCESS AND
SUPPORT THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
MINIMIZE FEDERAL PENALTIES. THE
ADDITIONAL CONTRACTOR RESOURCES
MOSTLY FOR THE UNITY SOLUTION
VENDOR AND SUPPORT CONTRACT
COSTS. ARE NEEDED FOR THE
SUCCESSFUL DESIGN DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION PHASE OF THE
PROJECT- THE ACTIVITIES THIS
PHASE INCLUDES SOLUTION
DEVELOPMENT CHANGES TO. THE
SYSTEM THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER
INTERFACES WITH NONSTATE
ENTITIES AND CHANGES TO SYSTEMS
JUST. ABOUT THE NEW DATA TO OUR
FEDERAL PARTNER. I BELIEVE WE
CAN GO INTO THAT SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS. PARDON ME I'M.
FINDING THE QUESTION. OKAY SO
THAT WAS ABOUT HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW I DIDN'T KNOW IF THERE
WERE ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT.
OTHERWISE GOING INTO QUESTION
TO WHAT IS THE CURRENT EXPECTED
TIMELINE FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION. SO THIS IS FOR
BOTH PERSONAL CARE SERVICES AND
HOME HEALTHCARE SERVICES. FOR
PERSONAL CARE SERVICES PCS
IMPLEMENTATION IS TARGETING BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. OF FOR HOME HEALTH
CARE SERVICES THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS TARGETED FOR
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. IN REGARDS TO
EXPECTED TOTAL OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING PENALTIES FOR EDIE FACE
TO PERSONAL CARE SERVICES IN
THIS CALENDAR YEAR FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE HAVE FEDERAL
PENALTIES EXPECTED OF ELEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND. AND WITH EACH YEAR THE
FEDERAL PENALTIES INCREASED BY
POINT TWO FIVE PERCENTAGE
POINTS- GOING UP 21% ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS WITH REGARDS TO.
THIS ITEM CAN I IF I IF I MAY
ASK- SO IT IN TAKING ON THIS
NEW BIG PROGRAM THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE US MORE EFFICIENT- WE'VE
HAD A HISTORY MOST RECENTLY
IT'S BEEN VERY APPARENT WHEN WE
WHEN WE PUT NEW SYSTEMS A
SPECIALIZED TRAINING SYSTEMS
INTO PLACE. WHAT KIND OF CHECKS
TO WE HAVE INTO PLACE TO MAKE
SURE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE HAD HISTORICALLY. WITH
NEW ELECTRONIC PROGRAMS. WERE
NOT CONNECT EXPERIENCE WITH
THIS AND- AND CONTINUE TO
ACCRUE A CREW. FEDERAL
PENALTIES. I THINK ONE IS THE
DEPARTMENTS AND ALWAYS SAW I
HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
COLLABORATIVE LEADS TO DO SOME
DETAILED ANALYSIS IDENTIFYING
YOU KNOW THE SYSTEMS THAT ARE
AFFECTED XCERRA- AND LOOKING AT
HOW WE CAN INTERFACE. WE ARE
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF TESTING
EFFORTS WERE GETTING UP. THAT'S
WHAT THEY CALL A SOFTWARE IS A
SOLUTION WE'RE NOT DOING CUSTOM
DEVELOPMENT- FROM THE
BEGINNING- WE'RE TRYING TO
LEVERAGE EXISTING WORKERS ARE
NET THAT'S OUT IN THE MARKET
PLACE TO LEVERAGE- WHICH
ALREADY DOES THIS WORK FOR
OTHER STATES. SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING TO MITIGATE RISK. OKAY
THURMOND AS ANYTHING. YES YOU
CAN NOT AND SHOULD I JUST WANT
TO DUMP HIM ON WHAT YOU WERE
ASKING BECAUSE I'M YOU KNOW YOU
GOT SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE-
ABILITY TO ROLL THIS OUT IN A
WAY THAT'S EFFECTIVE I'M GIVEN
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND I JUST WANTED
COULD YOU JUST PLEASE- IT
EXPAND ON BLIND THERE ARE
FEDERAL. FEDERAL PENALTIES. IN
IT IS ONLY. QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE IT'S IS I
MEAN YOU CAN YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT. WE JUST WE DON'T
WANT TO CREATE ANOTHER- LAST
WEEK WE'RE EXPERIENCING WITH
EDT YOU COULD PROVIDE TO THAT
THAT BE GREAT. SO WITH REGARDS
TO THAT FEDERAL PENALTIES-
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
IS A REQUIREMENT UNDER THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY CURES ACT.
SO WHICH IS THE REASON WE'RE
YOU KNOW WE'RE MOVING FORWARD
WITH EBV IS TO MINIMIZE
COUNTIES BECAUSE OF COURSE THEY
GO UP. EACH YEAR- WITH REGARDS
TO. YOUR COMMENT OR YOUR
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO. OTHER
DEPARTMENTS HAVING ISSUES I
THINK ONE FIRST AND FOREMOST IS
A CURRENT- HOW DO YOU CALL THIS
THE SOFTWARE AS A SERVICE WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE UTILIZING ITS
CURRENT TECHNOLOGY IT'S
CURRENTLY WORKING- WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THINGS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY WORING OUT IN THE
MARKETPLACE OTHER STATES ARE
USING SO WE'RE NOT STARTING
FROM SCRATCH OR NOT- LOOKING TO
LEVERAGE SOME OF THE- EXISTING
OUR OLDER SYSTEMS RIGHT. WILL
BE INTERACTING WITH THEM FOR
DATA. OKAY IN WE ARE BEING
RELEASED ONE. OKAY SO THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT IS IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE IMPLEMENTED
ORIGINALLY BY DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY. I DON'T SEE WE GOT A
GOOD FAITH EXTENSION THROUGH
THE END. I'M SORRY YOUR BY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY WE
GOT A GOOD FAITH EXTENSION OF
BROADEST THROUGH DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY-
AND NOW UNTIL WE GET THIS
IMPLEMENTED TO MEET FEDERAL
REGULATION THERE ARE PENALTIES
AND THEY'LL CONTINUE TO BE
UNTIL IT'S IMPLEMENTED. IN SO-
NOT TO GET TOO MUCH INTO THE
WEEDS YEAH. NEW WINE WE ARE NOW.
EIGHTY NINE. I'M I CAN'T HEAR
YOU. WHAT'S THE REASON THAT WE
ARE ON TIME ENGINEER I THINK IT
IS RIGHT- I THINK IT REALLY IS
THE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS- THERE
WAS A LOT OF ANALYSIS
INDIVIDUAL KERR- AND WE'VE BEEN
C. T. AND THE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO EXPEDITE THIS. TO MINIMIZE
THE PENALTIES. I CAN ELABORATE
A LITTLE BIT MORE HERE THIS IS
MARCO MEETS WITH THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. SO THERE
WAS A SIGNIFICANT DELAYS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
PROVIDING US GUIDANCE AROUND
HOW TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THIS
REQUIREMENT. AS A PART OF THAT
WAS BAD THE SECOND PART REALLY
WAS THE PANDEMIC AND REALLY
BEING DELAYED IN TERMS OF-
DELIVERY. OUT OF THE WAY WE
THINK ABOUT THIS REALLY IS THAT
IT'S A IT'S A PHASED IN
APPROACH TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MITIGATE THEIR RISKS SO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH OUR- COUNTY
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO
REALLY BUILD THIS OUT IN A WAY
THAT ROLLS IT OUT. IN PHASES
THAT WE BUILD OFF OF THE PHASES
SO THAT WE LEARN FROM THE PRIOR
PHASES BEFORE WE SCALE ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE. THE PENALTIES
THAT WERE PUT IN PLACE OUR
PENALTIES FROM THE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PURSUANT TO
THE STATUTES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS VERY DELAYED IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING SPEEDS I
DIDN'T SPROUT. HOW IT WOULD
ULTIMATELY ALLOW US TO
IMPLEMENT THIS. PARTICULAR
PROVISION OF THE LAW. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO IF THE FOR THIS
AND EVERYTHING AND SO CENTER
MELINDA'S WILL HAVE TIME TO GET
BACK TO THIS AT ANOTHER POINT
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THIS
ITEM OPEN. CORRECT WE MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE. OKAY
THANK YOU DR AMEN I FOR ISSUE
THREE WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
AFFORDABLE DRUG MANUFACTURING
ACTING LIKE MEDITATION OR OR SB
EIGHT FIVE TWO I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE FOR SHOPPERS JOHNNY
ON THE PHONE OR UNDERSTAND MY
APOLOGIES AT INTEREST ALL WHO'S
AN ASSISTANT SECRETARY AT THE
AGENCY WILL TAKE. INCREASING
YOU ON THIS RIGHT. A GOOD
AFTERNOON SO JUST TO GIVE
EVERYONE AN OVERVIEW OF. THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL WE HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PORTABLE DRUG
MANUFACTURING ACT OF THE
RESOURCES IN THE DCP. FACULTY
IF I COULD THAT STOP YOU ONE
MINUTE- CAN I SUPPOSE IT BUDGET
CHAIR AND I'M GETTING NOTES
THAT I'M SUPPOSED TO ASK THE L.
A. O. OUR DEPARTMENT FINANCE IF
THEY'D LIKE TO RAISE THEIR HAND
TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS OR IF THEY
LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS.
SENATOR EIGHT MINUTES- THIS IS
TONY PIC FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND- THANK YOU
SO MUCH I JUST HAD A- VERY
BRIEF COMMENTS ABOUT- THE FIRST
ITEM- CONCERNING- ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION- WOULD IT BE
OKAY TO GO. TO GO BACK TO THAT
ISSUE AND JUST MAKE. MAKE A
BRIEF COMMENT PLEASE. OKAY SO
OUR OFFICE DALY- HAS REVIEWED
THE PROPOSAL FOR EDV PHASE TO
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
DOLLARS AND WE DO NOT HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED BUT WE WANTED TO RAISE
ONE POSSIBLE ISSUE- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WISH TO ASK
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT. SO
DREAMS IF THE PHASE ONE PART
OF- DEVELOPING ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION THE ISSUE OF
CAPTURING A SERVICE PROVIDERS
LOCATION BY ELECTRONIC MEANS AT
THE START AND END OF A SHIFTER
THE WORKDAY. ENDED UP CAUSING A
DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION IN THE
RECENT WISE- ORIGINALLY- THIS
FIRST PHASE CONCERNED IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WORKERS AND
THEY HAD EXPRESSED SOME PRIVACY
CONCERNS WITH. EEVEE V.
ELECTRONICALLY CAPTURING THEIR
LOCATION. AND CALIFORNIA HAD
INITIALLY PLANNED TO DEVELOP A
SYSTEM THAT DID NOT. CAPTURED
ELECTRONICALLY THE LOCATION.
I'M NEVER THE LESS- AND
RECEIVED- WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS
APPROVAL FROM THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES
TO DO THAT. NEVERTHELESS THERE
WAS- NATIONWIDE GUIDANCE THAT
WAS ISSUED BY THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES
THAT WAS SORT OF IN CONFLICT
WITH HIS INITIAL PLAN. SO THE
REASON I'M- AND SO CALIFORNIA
HAS A RECONFIGURE THE SYSTEM-
WHICH CAUSED A SLIGHT DELAY AND
SO THE REASON I'M RAISING THIS
ISSUE IN RESPECT TO PHASE TWO.
IS JUST TO AT WORK WERE
WONDERING IF THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS ACCOUNTED FOR THIS.
SLIGHTLY SENSITIVE ISSUE-
REGARDING ELECTRONIC- BETTER
CAPTURING OF A SERVICE.
PROVIDER'S LOCATIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CAN UP PLEASE. HI
ANASTASIA DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES- YES SO WE HAVE
HAD IN A NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDER
MEETING ON BEHALF OF THE
FUNDING DEPARTMENT AT THE STATE
TO INCLUDING DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES FOR ME
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND OTHERS
AND WE HAVE DISCUSSED THIS WITH
THE COLORS WE KNOW THAT WOULD
BE TO WE ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS ON. A
LEFT TRYING TO GRIEVE VERIFYING.
THE LOCATION AT THE START TIME
AND END TIME OF SERVICES NOT
THINKING TRACKING BUT FIFTH CAN
AND FIND. SO WE HAVE MADE THAT
ASSUMPTION IN OUR SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT IN THAT OUR XP. AND
SO WE WILL BE IN COMPLIANCE AND
AGAIN WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND I BELIEVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES. SEVEN OTHER
STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSION. COMING
UP SHORTLY. CHRIS THANK YOU
SEND YOUR QUESTIONS ARE. AND
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE. OKAY
WE'LL CONTINUE. I BELIEVE THAT
ITEM OF. OKAY ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE GROUNDHOG DAY YESTERDAY
BUT HERE WE GO. SURE SO I JUST
TO KIND OF GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE PROPOSAL FOR US SENATE
BILL. FIVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
PORTABLE DRUG MANUFACTURING
OCT- THE P. C. P. THAT WE PUT
FORTH WHICH GIVES RISE FUTURE
TO US THE RESOURCES TO. JANGAN
SERVICES AND ONE OF TEACHERS
THAT WOULD SERVE IN A PROJECT
MANAGEMENT CAPACITY. THE BILL
ITSELF. SB TWO CALLS FOR THE
AGENCY TO ENTER INTO
PARTNERSHIPS TO INCREASE
GENERIC MANUFACTURING- IN THIS
LEGISLATION ALIGNED WITH AN
EARLIER PROPOSAL. ENDS AT THE
SCHOOL YEARTWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TWENTY ONE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE STATE
TO INCREASE GENERIC
MANUFACTURING. AND WHAT THE
RESOURCES WILL ALLOW US TO DO
AND SOME. ADDRESS VARIOUS
RESEARCH AND ANALYTICAL TASKS
ASSOCIATED WITH- IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE BILL YOU CAN DO IT
PROCEED ALONG THREE
INTERRELATED TRACKS- THE FIRST
TRACK IS FOCUSED ON IDENTIFYING
TOP DRUGS. THIS WOULD BE A DATA
DRIVEN ANALYSIS WHICH LAYERS
ON. OTHER FACTORS SUCH AS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND ECONOMIC.
FOR EXAMPLE PUBLIC HEALTH AFTER
WOULD BE DRUGS THAT ADDRESS OUR
HIGH RISK OR HIGH MORTALITY
CONDITIONS ECONOMIC FACTORS
LOOK AT COST- AND THEN THE
SECOND TRACK- FOR THE RESOURCES
THAT IN THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
FOCUS ON LEGAL MARKET POLICY
AND REGULATORY FACTORS. SO THIS
IS MORE FOCUSED ON THE
FEASIBILITY OF WHICH DRUGS TO
MANUFACTURE- AND THEN LASTLY
THAT THE THIRD TRACK IS FOCUSED
ON STRATEGIC AND OPERATIONAL
ISSUES. THIS IS MORE ABOUT THE
HOW OF GETTING DRUGS INTO THE
HANDS OF CONSUMERS. SO FOR
EXAMPLE UNDER CONTRACT WE LOOK
AT DISTRIBUTION MODELS. SUCH AS
RETAIL PHARMACIES OR MAIL ORDER
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. SERVICES.
AND I JUST WANTED POLICY
HEARING CASE- THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS AND IS IT IS THE ARE
WE PROPOSING- DOES DID THE BILL
PROPOSED THAT THE STATE
ACTUALLY ENGAGED IN THE
MANUFACTURING OR TO CONTRACT
WITH THE MANUFACTURER. SO THE
WAY THAT THE BILL'S STRUCTURED
IS- THERE'S TERM. DEFINED AS
PARTNERSHIPS. AND PARTNERSHIPS
IS DEFINED BROADLY THIS COULD
MEAN- AND GENERIC PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS BY WAY OF CONTRACTS WERE
PURCHASED THANK THROUGH. YOUR
REPAIRS OR OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES- AND THEN THERE'S A-
LEGISLATIVE REPORT THAT'S DUE
AND- SHIP IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THAT'S MORE
FOCUSED ON THE STATE ITSELF-
DIRECTLY MANUFACTURING DRUGS
AND THAT ONCE HE'S ABILITY
STUDY. EXAMINING YOUR THAT THE
TRADE OFFS OF. AT THE STATE
GOING DOWN THAT PATH. SO THAT
WOULD BE DETERMINED BASED ON
THE CONSULTANTS AND WHAT THEY
COME UP WITH AFTER LOOKING AT
THE- AT THE ISSUE THE CORRECT
YES CORRECT. OKAY ALL RIGHT AND
IT DOES IT ALSO CONTEMPLATE THE
MANUFACTURING TAKING PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA DESPITE IF WE ARE
EITHER. CONTRACTING WITH OR
DOING IT OURSELVES. THE BILL
DOESN'T. HIDE SPEAKS
SPECIFICALLY TO MANUFACTURING
CALIFORNIA- BUT WE ARE TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AS WERE
KIND OF LOOKING AT THE
LANDSCAPE OF POTENTIAL
PARTNERSHIPS. OKAY THANK YOU.
AND THEN THE NEXT ITEM- THE
NEXT QUESTION PLEASE. YES SIR.
TODAY WE DON'T HAVE A CONCRETE
TIMELINE FOR WHEN THE FIRST
CONTRACTS WOULD BE ENTERED INTO
THE BILL RECENTLY CAME INTO
EFFECT ON JANUARY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR. CURRENTLY WE'RE JUST
USING INTERNAL RESOURCES TO DO
INITIAL PLANNING AND STRATEGY.
BUT THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
WILL BE ON. SHOULD IDENTIFY THE
TOP DRUGS WHICH THE RESOURCES
IN THE PCP WILL ENABLE AGENCY
TO DO. AND ONCE WE GET THAT
DATA ON THE TOP DRUGS THAT'S
REALLY GOOD AND I DON'T APPLY
IT OUR- POTENTIAL PARTNERS TO
THIS PROJECT. DOUBLE DOUBLE THE
STATE ON THE PATH- SHOULD
SELLING THE REQUIREMENTS
INVESTIGATE I TO MANUFACTURE.
CARE HI GENERIC DRUGS. OKAY
MADAM CHAIR WHEN THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
MMHM THE PROPOSAL OKAY DO YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU'VE ANSWERED AS
RESPOND TO THE THIRD QUESTION
AND YOUR RESPONSE TO ME. FOR
THE THIRD QUESTION- RESOURCES-
IN. IN THE PCP WOULD COMFORT
THE THIRD MAN DAY FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE REPORT ON A
FEASIBILITY OF DRUG
MANUFACTURING. OKAY THANK YOU
ORIGINAL MELINDA'S. I'M SURE I
JUST WANT TO GO BACK TO COST
JUST BE SEATED WITH. YOU'RE
PUTTING A DISTRIBUTION
PARTNERSHIP PLAN TOGETHER
THERE'S COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT AND I'M CURIOUS. WHERE THE
MONEY'S GOING TO COME FROM TO
FUND THAT- AND THEN I DO HAVE
TO GO BACK TO THIS QUESTION- I
GUESS I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING-
YOUR Y. GERMANIC MEANS ARCH
WOULD WANT TO GO INTO A
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE. I
THINK IT'S- MAKE A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF MONEY. YOU KNOW AND
PRIVATE MARKETPLACE RENDON
CARTON WITH THE STATE MUST
YEARS. THIS HOSTAGE GREEN I'M
NOT AWARE OF INSTRUCTIONS SHE.
SO ON. THERE ARE SOME
INCENTIVES FOR YOU KNOW
DRAMATIC ACTRESS TO WORK WITH
THE STATE BECAUSE OF THE LARGE
VOLUME THAT'S A CITY CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS- YOU KNOW THERE'S
CALPERS DH CS- ARE COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND THEN THERE'S
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES SOME
STATES ARE COUNTER COSTS BUT
ALSO KIND OF DEPENDING ON WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE AVAILABLE
THERE CAN AND THE VOLUME THAT
IT REPRESENTS OUR COULD BE
OPPORTUNITIES US FROM A STATE
PURCHASER PERSPECTIVES. AND
THEN- ANY ON THE KIND OF THE
DEALS AT THE STATE CAPS. THIS
COULD ALSO BE AVAILABLE. ON AS
OTHER ENTITIES KIND OF BEING.
GATHERED ON TO THAT THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY YEAH.
AND THEN- REGARDING YOUR
EARLIER QUESTION ABOUT ON. THE
COSTS FOR DISTRIBUTION
NETWORKS- WE ARE LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW THE EXISTING MODEL WHERE.
THERE IS- PHARMACIES RETAIL
PHARMACIES SO- WE ARE TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT ACOSTA TACTIC MASS
AND BEING ABLE TO. THANK THREE
VAST AND- ALSO KIND OF ALSO
THINKING OF OTHER CHANNELS SUCH
AS MAIL ORDER PHARMACIES THAT
ARE MORE DIRECT TO CONSUMER.
THAT OUT INCREASING UTILIZATION
SINCE THE PANDEMIC SO- WE WILL.
BE WHAT I WANTED TO RAISE COSTS
BY MANUFACTURER TRUCK WE WOULD.
TAKE A KIND OF AN ON APPROACH
ON- BENEFACTOR OF THE DRUG AND
ALSO GETTING INTO THE HANDS OF
THE CONSUMER. I TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THOSE TYPES OF FACTORS.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE THEM
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE ACTUAL
DISTRIBUTION THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE ALSO LOOK THROUGH AN
EQUITY LENS A LOT OF OUR SMART
SMALLER PHARMACIES IN OUR IN
OUR- COMMUNITIES ARE ARE THOSE
THAT ARE REALLY ON THE GROUND
WITH OUR- COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
MOST AT RISK. WHO MAY NOT
AVAILABLE SELVES TO A MAILING.
SO LET'S JUST MAKE SURE WE KEEP
THAT IN MIND AS A PROGRAM
DEVELOPED. THANK YOU SENATOR
ANY ANY COMMERCIAL DEPARTMENT
FINANCE OR THE ELIA. OKAY WELL
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ITEM OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
FOR DR AMEN SO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR IS THE CENTER FOR DATA
INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION MY
COLLEAGUE JOHN ARMENIAN IT'S
GONNA TAKE LEAD IN BRIEFING ON
THAT PARTICULAR ITEM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON I HAD
THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ESTABLISHES THE CENTER
FOR DATA INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATION WITHIN THIS- CGHS.
THE BILL INTEGRATES THE
FOLLOWING ENTITIES THE OFFICE
OF THE HEALTH INFORMATION AND
INTEGRITY. THE OFFICE OF THE
PATIENT ADVOCATE THE OFFICE OF
INNOVATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE FOR THE PROTECTION OF
HUMAN SUBJECTS THE LANGUAGE
AUTHORIZES THE CENTER TO KEEP
CERTAIN FUNCTIONS FROM THESE
ENTITIES SUCH AS THE ANNUAL
REPORT CARD ON QUALITY CARE AND
PATIENT EXPERIENCE. LIKE HEALTH
COVERAGE PROGRAMS AND GUIDANCE
ON HEALTH DATA SHARING AND
COMPLIANCE WITH HEALTH
INFORMATION PRIVACY LAWS AND
REVIEW THESE RESEARCH PROPOSALS
USING STATE DATA ASSETS. IN
ADDITION THE LANGUAGE
AUTHORIZES THE CENTER TO
DEVELOP AND ADMINISTER- A
RESEARCH DATA HUB- ADMINISTERED
THE C. H. H. AS OPEN DATA
PORTAL ENGAGE AND COORDINATE
WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH COVERAGE
PROGRAMS. TO HELP ADDRESS
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
EXPAND HEALTH DATA SHARING AND
HEALTH INFORMATION PRIVACY
COMPLIANCE GUIDANCE AMONG STATE
ENTITIES. AND DEFINITELY WORK
ON THE IMPROVEMENT OF.
IMPROVING DATA SHARING- AND
DATA PROCESSES AND KNOWLEDGE
MANAGEMENT WITHIN THE CGHS
DEPARTMENTS. I'LL STOP THERE
AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS. I'M AT THIS TIME.
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT QUESTION
PLEASE. I THINK HE LAST PIECE
THAT THERE WERE THREE QUESTIONS
SUBMITTED- THE LANGUAGE ALSO
PERMITS FOR THE CENTER TO
COLLECT FEES FROM STATE
DEPARTMENTS FOR SERVICES
PROVIDED TO SEE COSTS FROM
RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS- FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PROTECTION OF
HUMAN SUBJECTS. THE LANGUAGE
ALLOWS STATE ASSETS TO BE
DISCLOSED TO ALL EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND NONPROFIT
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS FOR RESEARCH
PURPOSES WHICH WILL BENEFIT THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS THE
LANGUAGE AUTHORIZES THE CENTER
TO ADOPT REGULATIONS IN SUPPORT
OF THESE FUNCTIONS. ALL RIGHT.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR L. A.
O. OR DEPARTMENT FINANCE. ANY
OF THE SENATORS. ALL RIGHT WELL
WE WILL LEAVE THIS ITEM OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE. OKAY.
HI DOCTOR AYMAN THIS IS MARCO
BEACH AGAIN AND I WILL PRESENT
ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
THE EQUITY CENTER PROGRAMS
PROPOSAL AT THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL JUST TO GIVE YOU A
QUICK OVERVIEW IS CONSISTED OF
FORTY DIFFERENT COMPONENTS AND
I'LL BRIEFLY WALK YOU THROUGH
EACH ONE OF THOSE COMPONENTS
AND THEN CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN QUESTIONS FROM ONE OF
OUR ONE IS REALLY FOCUSED ON-
COLDER CLOSE PROBABLY NINETEEN
EQUITY ANALYSIS. AT THIS IS ALL
CENTERED AROUND THE NOTION THAT
FOR MANY YEARS THAT'S AS MANY
OF US WORKING TO HELP YOU WITH
YOUR SEATS AS OUT WE ARE
ACUTELY AWARE OF THE INEQUITIES
ARE THE DISPARITIES AS WE SEE
AND- IN IN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THOSE INEQUITIES AND
DISPARITIES POOREST
SIGNIFICANTLY EXACERBATED BY
THE COLD THE NINETEENTH AND I
MIGHT ANSWER THE PREMISE BEHIND
THIS PARTICULAR ANALYSIS IS
REALLY WORKING WITH RESEARCH
PARTNERS CAN BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW DEEP THOSE
INEQUITIES AS A RESULT OF THE
COOKING NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
WE'RE REALLY WORKING WITH OUR
STATE COLLEAGUES LEGISLATIVE
COLLEAGUES THAT BETTER THINK
ABOUT HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD IN
TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT AS
PART OF OUR RECOVERY AND WE'RE
DISRUPTING THOSE INEQUITIES.
AND BUILDING BACK BETTER. THE
SECOND COMPOUND OF THIS. IS A
LINE ACCESS POLICY FRAMEWORK.
AND THE PROMISED REALLY IS TO
ON OF WHERE THAT HAS DONE BY
THE LARGEST. AND MINISTER AND
THE SERIES PROGRAMS ACROSS OR
AGENCY AROUND LANGUAGE ACCESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES THAT WE'RE
DELIVERING HAVE. A SET STANDARD
IN TERMS OF WHAT LANGUAGES.
WE'D TRANSLATE MATERIAL IN THAT
THE INFORMATION HAS MOST OF ALL.
PART THREE OF THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL IS BUILDING AT EQUITY
DASHBOARD ACROSS OUR MAJOR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS. AND THE IDEA HERE
REALLY IS TO. REALLY ROLL UP
OUR SLEEVES AND BEGIN TO LOOK
AT THE DATA. AROUND EQUIT WITH-REGARDS TO THE PROGRAMS IN SOME
INSTANCES WE MAY HAVE THE DATA
IN OTHER INSTANCES WE MAY NOT
HAVE THE DATA. AND SO PART OF
THE PREMISE IS REALLY THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE ENGAGE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE COULD BEGIN
COLLECTING DATA. CERTAINLY IT
ALLOWS US TO REALLY WORK WITH
THE PUBLIC OR STAKEHOLDERS
COMMUNITY PARTNERS ARE
COUNTIES. AS WELL AS YOU THE
LEGISLATURE AROUND. AREAS WHERE
WE DO HAVE INEQUITIES IN HOW WE
TO CLOSE IN EQUITIES ARE. AND
ALL FINALLY CLOSE WITH THE
FOURTH PIECE OF THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL WHICH IS TO EXPAND.
WORK FORCE TRAINING FOR STATE
EMPLOYEES AROUND RACE. IN ORDER
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE'RE BUILDING
COLLECTIVELY PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. AT THAT THEY ARE
ROOTED IN RACIAL JUSTICE AND-
YEAH IMMEDIATE ANY INDIVIDUAL I.
ALSO DOCTOR EGGMAN I WILL PAUSE
HERE TO SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTION AND I'M HAPPY TO GO
THROUGH THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE IN YOUR GENDER IF THAT
WORKS FOR YOU OKAY OF JUST TWO
QUESTIONS I HAD WITH THE EQUITY
DASHBOARD SO. WELL WE'VE BEEN
OUT OF SESSION LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE I GO TO THE STATE
DASHBOARD THE PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT DASHBOARD MY COUNTY
DASHBOARD WILL THIS NEW EQUITY
DASHBOARD BE JUST OFF ON ONE OF
OUR ALREADY EXISTING DASHBOARDS
WILL BE A NEW DASHBOARD AND
WHAT INFORMATION WILL BE PUT
INTO THE DASHBOARD AND WEBER.
WHERE DO WE GET THAT
INFORMATION FROM. GREAT
QUESTION SENATOR SIR RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE WHAT WE CALL AN OPEN
DATA PORTAL ON OUR WEBSITE AT
C. HHS DOT CA DOT COM. AS PART
OF THE OPEN DATA PORTAL WE
ACTUALLY CURRENTLY HAVE A
PROGRAM'S DASHBOARD AND YOU CAN
ACTUALLY GO ON THE PROGRAM'S
DASHBOARD AND BY. I BELIEVE
DISTRICT FOR SENATE DISTRICT I
COUNTY LOOK AT. UTILIZATION OF
SERVICES ACROSS OUR MAJOR
PROGRAMS AT THE MOMENT. AND SO
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE REALLY IS
TO BUILD OFF OF A CONCEPT LIKE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO GET DIG DEEPER INTO THAT.
MEASURES ARE REALLY FOCUSED
AROUND EQUITY- I THINK RIGHT
NOW I DON'T HAVE. THAT ANSWER
FOR YOU AND IN TERMS OF WHAT
THOSE MEASURES EXACTLY WHAT HE-
PROMISED YOUR WOULD BE THAT WE
WOULD CONVENE SIR INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS TO REALLY
HELP US UNDERSTAND. AND DIG
DEEP INTO THE DATA THAT WE HAVE
TO IN ORDER FOR US TO FOCUS
MEASURES THAT. PROMOTE THAT
PASSPORT. IT SO WHO'S THE
AUDIENCE FOR THE DASHBOARD IS A
PROVIDERS OR IS IT. CONSUMERS
OF SERVICES. I DON'T THINK THAT
THIS ON THIS PARTICULAR ONE
IT'S REALLY CONSUMER DRIVEN- I
THINK IT THIS IS REALLY FOR US
COLLECTIVELY AFRO GRAHAM. WELL
FOLKS PROGRAM LEVEL AT. RISK
LIKE YOURSELF YOU'RE REALLY BE
ABLE TO SHINE A LIGHT ON WHERE
DO WE SEE THE INEQUITIES AND
THEN WORK WITH OUR POLICYMAKERS
TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THE GAPS.
ADMINISTRATOR OR LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTIONS IN ORDER FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO BUY DOWN THOSE GAPS
INTENT REALLY IS NOT THE
AVERAGE INDIVIDUAL THAT'S
GETTING SERVICES INTENT REALLY
IS US COLLECTIVELY AS A
COMMUNITY. AND THAT COULD BE
DIFFERENT LEVELS IT COULD BE AN
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM LIKE AN MSSP
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE OR AND I
JUST THIS PROGRAM BACK ON THE
LEVEL. IT CERTAINLY CAN BE- A
STATE DEPARTMENT LOOKING AT ITS
IT'S- PROGRAM AND THEN YOU AS
THE LEGISLATURE AS YOU
CONTEMPLATE WORKING ON A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT POLICY
PIECES. AND OUT WHERE THE GAPS.
ARE WITH REGARDS TO EQUITIES.
AND ON WORKFORCE AS YOU WILL
ALLUDED THE MOST THE- ARE
DELIVERED BY COUNTY STAND OR
ARE A NONPROFIT PARTNERS WHO
WHO IS WHO GETS THIS TRAINING
MONEY ISN'T THROUGH A GRANT
FOR. LOCALS OR IS IT FOR STATE
TRAINING. EXCELLENT QUESTION
DOCTOR A MAN SO WE'VE BEEN
DOING A LOT OF VARIOUS
TRAININGS FOR OUR- BUCKETS OF
TRAINING DOLLARS FOR- OUR AND
OUR COUNTY. THE PROGRAM THE
TYPE OF THIS PURPOSE PROPOSES
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE STATE
WORKFORCE AND HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT THE STATE WORKFORCE OUR
ACCESS TO TRAININGS ARE FOCUSED
REALLY ON THIS PARTICULAR TOPIC
THIS IS HARD HONES IN
SPECIFICALLY ON THE STATE
WORKFORCE. OKAY THANK YOU ANY
ANY QUESTIONS CENTER MELINDA'S
BEFORE WE HAVEN'T RESPONDED TO
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
PROVIDED. DO YOU THINK YOU-
OKAY SO. HEALTH CARE INEQUITIES
CERTAINLY ARE REAL ENOUGH
QUESTION ABOUT IT BUT- I'M I'M
NOT UNDERSTANDING HOW THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM IS GOING TO
HELP- THE HEALTH INEQUITIES
THAT EXIST IN MY DISTRICT IN
THE EASTERN PART OF MY DISTRICT
CERTAINLY- HAS SOME ISSUES AND-
WHAT I NOTICED GOES ON OFTEN
TIMES IS THAT THE MORE URBAN
AND- COASTAL COMMUNITIES SEEM
TO GET MORE ATTENTION ONE
RESOURCES ASSISTANCE TO. PLACES
INLAND TYPES OF CITIES OR THE
NORTHEASTERN PART OF MY
DISTRICT SO WHAT I'M HEARING
YOU SAY IS THAT THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL IS NOT NECESSARILY FOR
THE CONSUMERS AS IT IS MORE OR
THE- GOVERNMENTAL SIDE AND I
WOULD JUST. EVEN THAT POSITION
YOU KNOW WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS ARE BEING REQUESTED
AN ADDITIONAL MONEY I'M- CAN
YOU HELP ME UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
IS GOING TO BENEFIT. PEOPLE IN
MY DISTRICT. ABSOLUTELY CENTER
I THINK IT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION. THERE'S TWO RESPONSES
TO THAT QUESTION THE FIRST
RESPONSE REALLY IS AROUND
CHANGING SYSTEMS AT THE POLICY
LEVEL. OUT WE CAN DO A LOT BACK
TO DISRUPT INEQUITIES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WITHIN PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT ARE DELIVERED.
BUT THE PREMISE BEHIND THIS
PROPOSAL REALLY IS LOOKING AT
THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE ACROSS
THE AGENCY FIVE AND A TWELVE
DEPARTMENTS AND FIVE OFFICES.
AWAITING THE DATA AND
DEVELOPING POLICIES IN ORDER
FOR US TO ADDRESS THE
INEQUITIES AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL
I. THINK THAT ONCE WE BEGIN TO
pCOMPONENTS. ALTERNATELY HAS
PROFOUND IMPACTS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL BECAUSE IF WE CAN CHANGE
THE SYSTEM. I ANY AND WHAT IN
WAYS IN WHICH WE ADMINISTER
PROGRAMS THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT WE PUT
FORWARD. THOSE ALL WILL HAVE A
DIRECT IMPACT ON EITHER THE
CONSUMER. WHO HE OR SHE MIGHT
BE GETTING SERVICES DIRECTLY OR
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
DELIVERED WITHIN YOUR COMMUNITY
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT IT TOO FULL IT'S
ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT
INEQUITIES IN WHAT WE CAN DO AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. BUT IT'S
EQUALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
LOOK AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL AND
HOW WE. ADDRESS THAT AT THE-
LOCAL. OKAY THANK YOU. YOU CAN
START RESPONDING TO THE
QUESTIONS. DR EGGMAN'S ALSO
WITH QUESTION NUMBER TWO AROUND
WITH THE- EQUITY ANALYSIS ALSO
INCLUDE RECOMMENDATIONS. WITH
REGARDS TO ACTIONS THAT COULD
BE TAKEN I THINK OUR INTENTION
HERE REALLY IS TO WORK FIRST
OUT WITH THEIR RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION TO HELP US DEVELOP
THE ANALYSIS. AND THEN
COLLECTIVELY TAKE THAT ANALYSIS
OF WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL AS OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS
TO THINK THROUGH WHAT ARE THE
PRACTICAL RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE COLLECTIVELY AND I'LL GO
INTO SO WHAT I WILL SAY HERE IS
THAT THAT THAT BE ANALYSIS
ITSELF FOR THE ENTITY THAT
WOULD BE DOING THE LICENSE
WOULD NOT BE MAKING THAT
RECOMMENDATION. THE INTENT IS
THAT WE TAKE THAT AND THEN WORK
WITH A BROADER STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
RECOMMENDATION. PRESCOTT ON.
THE THIRD QUESTION. YOU HAVE IN
YOUR A GENUINE IS RELATED TO
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS POLICY
FRAMEWORK- AND- ITS ABILITY TO
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS OR HEALTH
INFORMATION. THE INTENT REALLY
BEHIND THE LANGUAGE ACCESS IS
THAT STATE RUN PROGRAMS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE BOTH ON THE HOUSE SIDE AND
THE HUMAN SERVICES SIDE. HOW
ABOUT BASED STANDARD OUT SOME
OF OUR PROGRAMS HAVE MUCH
HIGHER STANDARDS IN TERMS
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES- AND
REQUIREMENTS BOTH FROM
LEGISLATION AND REGULATIONS.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO HERE
IS REALLY CREATE A SPOT THAT
UNIFORM STANDARD ACROSS OUR ALL
OF OUR PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
IN ORDER FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER. IN A NATURAL IT COULD
POTENTIALLY TRANSLATE INTO A
BETTER INFORMATION AT THE
PROVIDER LEVEL. BUT THE INTENT
REALLY ISN'T THIS BE HIGHER
LEVEL WITH REGARDS TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE MISTER WITHIN.
ARE THERE THE AGENCY IN TERMS
OF NEXT STEPS HERE WHICH IS THE
SECOND PART OF YOUR QUESTION.
WE HAVE ALREADY FORMULATED A
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS ACROSS OR
AGENCY WHO ARE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS ACROSS. A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAM AREAS. OUT
THAT STANDARD LOOK LIKE IN THE
WAY I THINK ABOUT THIS IS THE
KNOW WHAT YOU OF OUR DATA.
BEIJING GUIDELINES SO WE HAVE
ARE WE HAVE BASIC STANDARDS THE
AGENTS. AND THEN DEPARTMENTS
CHOOSE GO ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT
I SHOULD THEY WANT. BE INTENT
HERE IS TO ENSURE POLICY ALL
THE PART IN EACH YEAH I IS OUR
EACH UP BY. AND THEN THEY START
CAN GO BONTA TO PERSON ORDER ME
BUT WE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S BASIC AT LEVEL ACROSS.
AGENCY. FOREST ARE. QUESTION
YOU HAVE IS RELATED TO THE
EQUITY GAS SPORTS IN THE
CURRENT GAPS IN THE COLLECTION
OF CERTAIN DEMOCRATS FOR A
QUIRKY INFORMATION AND HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS THAT PREVENT.
IDENTIFICATION OF INEQUITIES
AND THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION AND I THINK IS THE
PROMISE OF WHY WE WANT TO DO
THIS. SO IT'S NOT ONLY TO BE
ABLE TO SAY WHAT DID I DO WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THAT HELPS US
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
INEQUITIES. IT'S ALSO A TO SAY
WHAT DATA DON'T WE HAVE BUT WE
WANT TO HAVE IN ORDER FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. AND SO PART
OF THE THAT THE EXERCISE HERE
IS DIGGING DEEPER IN TERMS OF
THE ABILITY FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE PACKAGE THE
DATA THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE TO
HELP AND- OUR WORK. AND THEN
MORE IMPORTANTLY LOOKING AT
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN FURTHER
BUILD ON THAT BY ADDING DATA
ELEMENTS INTO OUR WORK MOVING
FORWARD. IN ORDER FOR US TO
HAVE SOME VISIBILITY THAT IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT HERE THAT ARE
WEEK IMPROVES AT THE DATA
COLLECTION PROCESS SEES AND
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
AND PROVIDER GROUPS. I TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEING COLLECTED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. HAS I LOVE OF
QUALITY BECAUSE- AS MANY OF
KNOW. THE PALMER OF THAT IS AS
GOOD AS IT'S PART SO. WORK WITH
LOCAL. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
COLLECT. THE SECOND PART OF
THIS IS RELATED TO OUR THE
MINISTRY PLAN IF YOU WOULD JUST
ROLL OUR WORK AROUND TO MAKE
CARE AT THE MINUTE CARE PRICE
ESTIMATE HEALTHCARE. PROJECTS I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS IS NOT JUST HEALTH RELATED%
IS HUMAN SERVICES RELATED WE
GOTTA THINK ABOUT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. AND THE
PROPOSAL DOESN'T PER SE RIGHT
NOW SUGGEST ANY CHANGES TO ANY
ONE OF THOSE PROGRAMS BUT THAT
CERTAINLY COULD BE SOMETHING
THAT WE COME FORWARD. ON ONCE
WE IDENTIFY OR OR REALLY DIG
DEEP INTO IT OUT WHAT DATA WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AND SO WHEN I
WAS VERY TO THAT QUESTION IS
THAT THE PREMISE HERE REALLY IS
THAT. WE ARE NOT FUNDING WITH
THESE DOLLARS SYSTEM. RIGHT NOW
BUT WE ARE FUNDING REALLY IS
BARBARA JEAN- EXISTING DATA TO
BUILD THE PAST. AND THEN REALLY
WORKING WITH YOU ASK FOR FUTURE
OF MEDICATIONS AROUND SISTER
JEAN JUST MIGHT BE NEEDED
RELATED SCREW I'VE DIVISIONAL
DATA THAT WE. MIGHT NEED TO
PROCURE. QUESTION NUMBER FIVE
IS A SURPRISE THE CORRECT. OF
THE WORK FORCE TRAIN OR- AND
REYES EQUITY OUT AND- THERE ARE
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
EXIST. LIKE YOUR PROGRAM ITS
THAT SB APART USE. I WHAT WE
CAN. HAPPENING IS US WORKING
WITH ALL TO ALL DEPARTMENTS AND
FIND OFFICES. UNDERSTAND THE
PROS AND CONS OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY EXIST AND
THEN THINK ABOUT THEIR
CURRICULAR DAD IS GOING TO FIT.
THE NEEDS OF OUR DEPARTMENTS
COLLECTIVELY I JUST WILL
EMPHASIZE HERE THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO THINK
ABOUT THE AUDIENCE. WHO WERE
TRYING TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
THIS TRAINING IS AVAILABLE FOR
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT MY LOCAL STAFF
ACROSS OUR DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES. HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS TRAINING IN ORDER. TO BE
ABLE TO. I DON'T UNDERSTAND. A
RATIO AYE ACT WHICH- INDIVIDUAL
BIAS THAT'S- I PROMISE YOU'RE
WITH TO. OUT WE DON'T A
PARTICULAR. AT IT DOWN RIGHT
NOW I DON'T REALLY LOOK WEBER
WITH. AS WELL AS- OUR INTERNAL.
THINK ABOUT WHICH PROGRAM MIGHT
BE. IT NEEDS IS BOND. THE WAY
THAT WERE TO ACCOMPLISH IF
FINALLY I YOUR LAST QUESTION
HOW DOES THE- PLAN TO. EFFORTS
BUT POP EQUITY NATIONAL
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED BY THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION. WE
CERTAINLY ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE PINE HARRISON DISTRIBUTION.
AND THE WORK THAT HAPPENED IN
THE TRANSITION PARTICULARLY
AROUND KOBE AND THE STROKE
EMPHASIS ON EQUITY OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO US
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
BECOME CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION ON A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT TOPICS
RELATED TO COMPANY NINETEEN.
AND THIS CERTAINLY WILL BE ONE
OF THOSE PIECES I DON'T HAVE A
CONCRETE ANSWER FOR YOU IN
TERMS OF WHAT SPECIFICS WHAT WE
DO HERE TOGETHER I THINK THAT
THERE IS A COMMITMENT ON BOTH
ENDS TO REALLY WORK TOGETHER TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
LEVERAGE EACH OTHER'S WORK. AND
ACCELERATE SOME OF IT MOVING
FORWARD. OUR DOCTOR EGGMAN I
WILL HERE IN SEE IF YOU ARE OR
CENTER. MELENDEZ HAVE ANY FUN
UP QUESTIONS TO ASK OF THOSE
ANSWERS. I DO NOT. OKAY ANY
COMMON OR QUESTIONS FROM THE OF
FINE CERTAINLY. OKAY THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
GREAT DR AMEN I'M JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUE STEPHANIE IS WELL
SPOKEN BECAUSE HE WILL TAKE
LEAD AND AB RESPONDING TO THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM TO BRIEF YOU
ON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME STEPHANIE. IS WELSH
THANK YOUNG THANK YOU DOCTOR
EGGMAN AND DATA CENTER EVELYN
DOES IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
THIS AFTERNOON TO TALK ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL. AND I DID THE
SECRETARY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
I'M REALLY EXCITED THAT I GET
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP WITH
THIS BECAUSE- OF THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART AND AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
AROUND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. SO
I'LL BE TALKING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SETTING UP OUR OFFICE IN
HOUSTON COMMUNITY RESTORATION
AND THE POSITIONS THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING AS WELL AS ONGOING
BUDGET COST. SO SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR
SIGNS REPEAL PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD HAVE CREATED THE
DEPARTMENT AT HOUSTON COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. AND THE PROVISIONS
THAT WOULD HAVE TRANSFERRED THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF. DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE. ALBANY
ALBANY SERVICES AGING. STASHED
ALSO A ESTABLISHED THE OFFICE
OF YOU THINK REST. WITHIN OUR
AGENCY AFFECTED JULY ONE TWENTY
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THAT IS
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION AND THE
PURPOSE OF THE OFFICES IS TO
SUPPORT THE TRANSITIONAL
JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH TO BE
SERVED IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
CONSISTENT WITH OVER A DECADE
OF REFORMS TO THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. ESTABLISHED IN THE
OFFICE AT THE AGENCY FEDERAL
LINES WITH RESEARCH AND BEST
PRACTICES THAT FOCUS ON
REHABILITATION AND SUPPORT THE
DELIVERY OF TRAUMA INFORMED AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SERVICES YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
RESEARCH SUPPORTS THAT KIDS
BEING CLOSER TO HOME IS MORE
LIKELY TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
FOR THESE REASONS HOUSING THE
OFFICE WITHIN AGENCY WILL BE A
FACTOR THE SCOPE OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS LIKE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
IN OFFICE JUST LIKE THE OFFICE
OF THE SURGEON GENERAL CAN
SUPPORT THE NEW OFFICE IN ITS
EFFORTS TO IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES TO SUPPORT
CONNECTIONS. TO LOCAL
IMPLEMENTERS WHO ARE GOING TO
SERVE THESE UNITS IN ADDITION
TO PROBATION INCLUDING
BEHAVIORAL. HEALTH AND SOCIAL
WELFARE DEPARTMENT. TO FURTHER
SUPPORT THE TREND. THE
LEGISLATION. THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SUBCOMMITTEE AT THE
CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL TO ADVISE
AND PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE OFFICE RELATED TO THE
POLICIES -GRAMS
APPROACHES THAT. IMPROVE YOU
THE OUTCOMES REDUCE YOUTH
DETENTION AND OF COURSE REDUCE
RECIDIVISM- THE- OFFICE WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR STAFFING THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE. THE STATUTE
CLEARLY OUTLINES THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE OFFICE
THESE INCLUDED PROMOTING TRAUMA
RESPONSIVE CULTURALLY INFORMED
SERVICES. IDENTIFYING AND
DISSEMINATING BEST PRACTICES.
ASSESSING THE AFFECT THE
EFFICACY OF LOCAL PROGRAMS.
REVIEWING LOCAL JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT GRANTS TO
ENSURE THEY CONTAINS ALL
NECESSARY ELEMENTS AND IT'S NOT
THE OFFICE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO SUPPORT PLAN IMPROVEMENTS.
AND TO DEVELOP POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES AND INTEGRATE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES TO SUPPORT WHAT
YOU. THE OFFICE ALSO- WILL
STAND OUT AND I SERVICE AN
OMBUDSPERSON SERVICE THAT WILL
BE MANNED BY SEVERAL STAFF. IN
ORDER TO. RECEIVE REVIEW AND
ASSESS- ISSUES AND COMPLAINTS.
THAT COME FROM THE COMMUNITY-
THAT IS A BROAD OVERVIEW ALL
VERY SEE IF THEY ARE ANY.
QUESTIONS BEFORE I AM. FANS OF
THE QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE BY THE
CAN. ARE YOU EXCITED TO GET
THIS GOING. I AM. I AM I THAT I
KNOW THAT YOU AND I HAVE A
BRIEF OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS IT
AND- I COULDN'T THINK OF A
BETTER PLACE AT THE HOUSE THIS
AND TO REALLY LEVERAGE THE
EXPERTISE OF OUR VARIOUS
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS- TO FIND
CREATIVE AND EFFECTIVE WAYS TO
SERVE EASIEST LOCALLY- I THINK
YEAH IT'S- A VERY EXCITED. OKAY
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
THURMOND IS IT. ON THE OVERVIEW
BEFORE SHE GETS IN THE
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS- I WILL
ASK THE QUESTION UNLESS YOU'RE
PLANNING ON A DIRECTION- AND
DRESSING QUESTION. REPRINTING
OR INTERESTING- WHICH I THINK.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO ADDRESS
THE QUESTIONS THAT WE SKED
AFTER THE OVER YOU JUST WONDER
IF THERE WAS ANY QUESTIONS.
BASED ON THE OVERVIEW. YOU'RE
IN SPECIFICALLY INTERESTED IN
QUESTIONS NO I WILL GO TO. OKAY
WELL LET'S LAUNCH INTO THE
QUESTIONS THEN SO THE FIRST
QUESTION- TALKS ABOUT WHAT
DUTIES ARE STAFF WILL BE.
PROVIDING BUT OVER THE COURSE
OF TIME AND I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS ARE REALLY KIND OF WANT
TO WALK THROUGH THE STATUTE HAS
THREE DIFFERENT TO- POTS OF
RESOURCES. AND IT'S IT IS A
LITTLE BIT CONFUSING- BUT THE
OFFICE ITSELF REALLY HAS. TO
RESPONSIBILITIES IT STARTS WITH
THE FIRST ROUND OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT GRANT
PLANTS AND THAT'S ACTUALLY HAVE
TO BE FILED WITH THIS OFFICE BY
JANUARY ONE. TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
AND SO THEREFORE THAT OUR UNIT
ACCOUNTING LIAISONS AND IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR POLICY
UNIT WILL BE BUSY REVIEWING
THESE PLAN ELEMENTS. AND IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THEY MAY HAVE TO
RETURN THOSE PLAN ELEMENTS FOR
COUNTY REVISIONS OFFER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ACCEPT
RESTED THIS THIS WORK WILL ALL
HAPPEN. WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF
THE OFFICE STANDING UP- AND
THIS IS AN ONGOING
RESPONSIBILITY- THE UNIT STAFF
THAT ARE ASSIGNED TO AS COUNTY
LIAISONS WILL BE WORKING ON
WITH THE COUNTY IMPLEMENTATION
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THIS TIME.
IDENTIFYING TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NEEDS IN
PARTICULAR- AND OFFERING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- THEN
THERE IS ALSO ANOTHER ELEMENT
THAT I THINK THE QUESTION IS
WHO ARE TALKING ABOUT AND- IT
IS TRUE. THAT THE STATUTE AS
WRITTEN PROVIDES THAT BY
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
MODEL JUVENILE JUSTICE GRANT
ADMINISTRATION THAT CURRENTLY.
ARE IS BEING- OVERSEE AT THE
BOY OF STATE COMMITTEE. WILL TO
THE TWO OFFICE. AND IT'S A BILL
THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND AT THAT
TIME- DO YOU KIND OF HAVE A
LIST OF THE FIRST BIG PLAN THAT
WILL COME IN UNDER THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT GRANT
PROGRAM. WILL HAVE BEEN
REVIEWED AND COUNTIES WILL BE
PROVIDING ANNUAL UPDATES THEY
MAY PROVIDE A MUCH LARGER
UPDATE ON ITS THREE YEAR CYCLE
BUT- THE LONG THE SHORT OF IT
IS THAT BAD STAFF WILL NOT HAVE
TO DO SO MUCH WORK TO REALLY-
REVIEW. JUVENILE JUSTICE PLANS
BUT THEY WILL BE PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CERTAINLY HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO DO BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS OF THAT TIME BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND THEN.
ALSO THERE IS A GRANT THAT'S
REALLY ACTUALLY UNDER WAY
ALREADY B. I. C. C. IS DOING
SOME OF THIS WORK NOW AND
THAT'S A ONE TIME GRANT AND
THAT'S REALLY SOME RESOURCES
FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. TO
DEVELOP INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS SO THAT
THEY CAN BE PREPARED TO ANSWER
THESE FOLKS LOCALLY- AND SO THE
SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION IS
HOW DO WE DETERMINE OUR
STAFFING LEVELS- AND- I THINK-
WE FELT IT WAS REALLY AFFECTED
TO DIVIDE THE OFFICE INTO TWO
UNITS THAT WERE LED BY. AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COUNTY COORDINATION UNIT WHICH
I KIND OF SPOKEN ABOUT QUITE A
BIT WHICH- I SIX LIAISONS THAT
CAN WORK WITH THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES TO REVIEW THEIR-
REALIGNMENT BROUGHT BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAMS. AND THEY ALSO THE
KIND OF PRIMARY POINT OF
CONTACT FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THEN WE HAVE A
POLICY RESEARCH OPERATIONS UNIT
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE. THE
OFFICE HAS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO
BEST PRACTICES- AND ALSO-
SUBMITTING REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN ANALYZING THE
ADVOCACY PROGRAMS. AND SO THIS
IS REALLY WHAT THIS YOUNG UNIT
WOULD. BE FOCUSED ON- AND THAT
IS ALL THE AREA OF OUR OFFICE
THAT WOULD. INCLUDE AND JUST
BILL- DUTIES- AND THEN LAST-WHICH THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AS WINX SOME. CON FUNDS BECAUSE
WE FELT LIKE WE WOULD NEED TO
ACQUIRE SOME NECESSARY SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE IN THE AREA OF
TRAINING OR JUST FEET. EVOLVING
SCIENCE SCIENCE OF ADOLESCENT
DEVELOPMENT THINGS THAT WE MAY
NOT HAVE- YOU KNOW CLOSELY AT
HAND AND IT GIVES US SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO BE NIMBLE AND
ADDRESS COUNTY ISSUES- SO. THE
NEXT QUESTION- DOES AGENTS
EXPECT TO COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE FTURE AND
FUTURE BUDGET YEARS TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES- WE DO NOT
AT ALL AND WHEN WE DID OUR
STAFFING ANALYSIS WE KNEW THAT
IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THERE WAS
THE POSSIBILITY OF POTENTIALLY
SOME ADDITIONAL.
RESPONSIBILITIES AND FULLY FEEL
THAT WE HAVE THE CAPACITY
WITHIN OUR EXISTING I REQUEST
HERE AND TO MEET THOSE
PARTICULAR. RESPONSIBILITIES.
AB I THINK THIS IS THE SECOND
TO LAST ONE PLEASE PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL ON THE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE OFFICE
IN REGARDS TO JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT BLOCK GRANTS. IS
THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE COUNTY
PLAN TIED TO FUNDING- THE
STATUTE IS VERY CLEAR ON THIS-
BEGINNING IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. I COUNTIES MUST
FILE A PLAN WITH THE OFFICE-
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL
COMPONENTS TO THAT PLAN THEY
RANGE FROM ALL OF THE SPECIFICS
AROUND THE TARGET POPULATION
THE FACILITIES THAT WILL BE
USED THE PROGRAMS THAT WILL BE
IS AND THE PROVIDERS THAT WILL
BE. DELIVERING SERVICES- THEY
ALSO MOST DOCUMENTS HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO IMPLEMENT EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES. IN EVERY AREA
FOR MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO RE
ENTRY SERVICES. AND FAMILY
REUNIFICATION. I AM- AND THE
PLAN ALSO NEED OUTLINE WHAT
DATE THEY WILL BE. ON YOU
SERVED HOW THOSE KIND WILL BE
MEASURED TO DETERMINE THE
RESULTS OF PROGRAM'S
INTERVENTIONS SUPPORTED BY THE
BLOCK GRANTS. SO WE WILLBE
ASSESSING ALL OF THOSE ELEMENTS
AND COMPONENTS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE. IN THE PLAINS- WE
ALSO REALLY RECOGNIZED THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS TO GET THESE
RESOURCES OUT TO COMMUNITIES
AND TO SUPPORT OURLOCAL
IMPLEMENTERS TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN SERVING NEEDS YOU. AND SO
IT'S REALLY PARAMOUNT THAT WE
WORK TO GET THESE PLANS
APPROVED AND AT THAT SUPPORT
THE COUNTIES TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED- HE
WILL THAT SERVE THESE THESE YOU.
AND THEN LAST. TO WHAT YOU WANT.
AND YOUR TEAM WILL BE PERSON
BURKE COMPLY- IN THE YOU KNOW-
AS ORGAN OR CHART WHICH I THINK
YOU HAVE IN YOUR AGENDA WE HAVE
BROAD AND- SEVEN X. INTO OUR
OFFICE TO HELP ASSIST ARE-
PERSON. I DON'T IF YOU SAME
PERSON BUT IT'S SEVERAL PEOPLE
WHO WILL BE WORKING ON THIS-
THEY WILL RECEIVE RUBIO AND
RESOLVED AND REFER COMPLAINTS-
FROM YOUTH FAMILY STAFF AND
OTHERS ABOUT- ANY KIND OF
CONDITIONS VIBRATIONS. OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE
PRESENTING AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION AND THE OFFICE MAY
DETERMINE THAT IT CAN RESULT
THE COMPLAINTS- DIRECTLY I
THINK WE'RE REALLY HOPING THAT
THAT IS- THAT'S THE NORM WE
HAVE. STAFF ON HAND THEY CAN
DETECT SINCE. AND WE CAN WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE FACILITY
ADMINISTRATORS TO TRY TO
RESOLVE ANY ISSUES I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR TA AGENDA
TO USE THE INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE GETTING FROM THOSE
COMPLAINTS TO DELIVER BETTER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE TO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE STEP THERE
CERTAINLY MAY BE CIRCUMSTANCES
IN WHICH COMPLAINTS NEED TO BE
REFERRED WE HAVE AN ATTORNEY-
WITHIN THE OFFICE THAT CAN HELP
ASSIST. WITH GUIDING US ON WHAT
WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE
REFERRAL- I THINK THAT IT'S
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
BASED ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES SO-
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO DEAL WITH IN
THE OFFICE AND TO GET BACK
ITEMS- THE OTHER THING I WOULD
SAY ABOUT THIS JUST REAL
QUICKLY IS THAT THE OFFICE IS
REQUIRED. TO PROVIDE REGULAR
REPORTS TO THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT A VARIETY OF THINGS BUT
IN PARTICULAR ABOUT THE
COMPLAINTS THAT WE RECEIVED AND.
THE FINDINGS AND ACTIONS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN. SO WITH THAT I
BELIEVE I AM ALL THE QUESTIONS
AND- WANT TO OPEN UP AND MAKE
SURE THAT THERE AREN'T ANY MORE
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT IN THAT
AND WE WANT TO WELCOME A DOCTOR
PANELIST WHO'S JOINED US LIVE
IN THE HEARING ROOM- AND WHEN
HE WAS COMING AND I MAY HAVE
MISSED IT BUT I KNOW SOMETIMES
WE SET UP. OVERSIGHTSIT AND AS
WE KNOW ALL COUNTIES ARE NOT.
CREATED EQUAL OR HAVE THE SAME
AMOUNTOF RESOURCES OR ABILITY.
THE PLAN TO WHILE WE'RE
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND THEN BRINGING IN DATA. WITH
THE REALIGNMENT. WILL WE
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO IF COUNTIES
ARE NOT PERFORMING WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE PERFORMING TO
WITHHOLD FUNDING OR OR- WELL
THIS WILL IS ACTUALLY HAVE
TEETH. WELL I BELIEVE THAT- WE
WILL HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
INVESTIGATE- ISSUES CERTAINLY
IF THERE ARE EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS VIOLATIONS OF LAW
AND THAT WE HAVE PLACES THAT WE
CAN GO THERE OBVIOUSLY ARE
ENTITIES THAT REGULATE THESE
FACILITIES- AND SO I BELIEVE
YOU KNOW WE WILL BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT- THIS IS. THESE
ARE SERVICES THAT NEED TO BE
PROVIDED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL I
THINK THE ONE THING I WOULD SAY
IS THAT WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
SUPPORT THE COUNTIES TO BE AS
SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE IN THIS
AND THAT REQUIRES THE
RESOURCES- AND DAD. THAT'S MY
ANSWER TO THAT. OKAY SO NOT
QUITE WE DON'T QUITE HAVE HAVE
TEETH BUT BUT WE HOPE THE
COUNTIES WILL PROVIDE THE
SERVICES SO OUR YOUTH AND
FAMILIES. CAN BE THEIR MOST
SUCCESSFUL AND WILL CONTINUE TO
LOOK TO LOOK FOR WAYS. TO HELP
COUNTIES AND CONSTITUENTS BE
SUCCESSFUL BUT WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. YES AND OF COURSE
WE WILL BE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE I
THINK THREE DIFFERENT REPORTS
THAT WE HAVE TO PROVIDE- AND-
AGAIN IF THERE ARE VIOLATIONS
OF LAW- CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
PRESENTED AN EMERGENCY OF
COURSE. OUR OFFICE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE RESPONSIVE TO
THAT. OKAY BECAUSE WE ARE WE'RE
NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT THE- USE
IN RESIDENTIAL KIND OF SERVICES
CORRECT IT'S A BROAD SPECTRUM.
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION HAS
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF NEEDS
AND THEY ALSO WORK FOR THE MOST
PART HAVE COMMITTED MORE
SERIOUS FELONIES. AND SO THESE
ARE LIKELY PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
HOUSED IN FACILITIES- FOR AT
LEAST PORTIONS OF THE OF THAT
TIME IN WHICH THEY ARE
REHABILITATING. AND SO AS I I'M
NOT EXACTLY SURE THE SCOPE OF
ALL THE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
FACILITIES CERTAINLY MANY OF
THEM WILL BE OBVIOUSLY.
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS IN THE
COMMUNITY. A QUESTION AND I AM
I AM I HOPE WOULD JUST BE THAT.
AGAIN BEST PRACTICES WOULD SAY
THAT WHATEVER FACILITY UP TO
YOU THIS IN. THE END THE
INTEGRATION BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY HAS TO START SOONER
THAN LATER AND THAT'S BEEN ONE
OF I THINK OUR STUMBLES ON
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE STOOD UP
THAT PEOPLE COME OUT AND THEN
THEY ARE JUST KIND OF. SWEPT
AWAY WITHOUT ANYTHING OR THE
MORE WE TRY TO CONNECT THEM TO
SERVICES AFTER THEY'RE OUT AND
OFTENTIMES FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS. THERE'S A LACK OF
FOLLOW THROUGH SO DO WE HAVE
THE MEANS TO BE ABLE TO. I'M
SAY MANDATE BUT BUT REALLY
ENCOURAGED THAT THOSE
CONNECTIONS ARE MADE SOONER
THAN LATER. ACTUALLY THE PLANTS
REQUIRE THEM TO FOCUS ON RE
ENTRY SO I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
RE ENTRY IT SHOULD BEGIN WITH
YOUR ENTRY INTO THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM- I THINK THAT'S THE BEST
PRACTICE THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
MOVING TOWARDS AND THAT THE
THAT THE REHABILITATION AND THE
WORK THAT WE DO- WHILE SOME OF
THIS IS IT WITHIN OUR CUSTODY
OR OVER SUPERVISION- EVERYTHING
SHOULD BE GEARED TOWARDS
FOCUSING ON SUCCESSFUL RE
ENTRY- AND THAT IS PART OF THE-
THAT IS PART OF THE PLAN THAT
THE COUNTY MUST ADMIT. THAT WE
WILL BE REVIEWING AND AGAIN
FORGIVE ME IF I MISSED IT THAT
THE INTERACTION BETWEEN THE- A
NEW CAR NEW I WANTED TROUT
DIDN'T GIVEN JUSTICE YOUTH OF.
ARE MEETING RESTORATION AND
THEY'RE GOING TO INNER
INTERFACE WITH THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AS MANY OF THESE
YOUTH ARE DULY- INVOLVED IN TWO
TO SYSTEMS. ABSOLUTELY I MEAN
AS I MENTIONED THAT I'M A
DEPUTY SECRETARY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BUT I REALLY SEE THIS
OFFICE BEING WITHIN OUR AGENCY
AS A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY
INTERACT VERY DIRECTLY WITH THE
DIRECTORS OF OUR VARIOUS
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. I'M ALSO VERY
SPECIFICALLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAT THIS STATUTE DICTATES THAT
THERE MUST BE A LOCAL COMMITTEE
THAT PUTS TOGETHER THIS PLAN
AND THOSE KINDS OF PARTNERS
LIKE CHILD WELFARE WE PART OF
THAT COMMITTEE. THANK YOU BUT
CENTER MELINDA'S- CENTER PAN.
TERAPIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE AN
OUNCE OF FRIENDLY BUT- OR
THERE'S A REAL ISSUE STAFF THE
COUNTIES COMING UP PLANS ARE
THERE STATEWIDE METRICS THAT
APPLY ACROSS ALL COUNTIES TO
ENSURE THAT- THE- THAT WE HAVE-
THE WAY TO MEASURE THE OVERALL
SUCCESS AS WELL AS HOW EACH
COUNTIES DOING RELATIVE TO
OTHER COUNTIES. YEAH GREAT
QUESTION- I CAN GIVE YOU A FEW
MORE DETAILS BUT THERE IS
ANOTHER PART OF THE STATUTE
THAT- DOES EXPLORE AT UPDATING
A SYSTEM THAT I WORKS ARE AT
THE TOP OF MY NAME I CAN'T
RECALL THE NAME- BUT IT IS IT
FOR THE PURPOSES OF REALLY
LOOKING AT WHAT TO THE METRICS
NEED TO BE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
POPULATION- I BELIEVE THAT
THAT- TRANSITION OR OR THAT
RECOMMENDATION EXCUSE ME THAT
WOULD COME FROM. THAT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ON HOW TO
IMPROVE THAT COMES TO OUR
OFFICE WITHIN THE FIRST FEW
YEARS- BUT IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY FRANKLY TO
DEVELOP THAT AND TO WORK WITH
THE COUNTIES THAT SUBMIT AS
DATA TO DEVELOP DATA REPORTS
FOR ALL OF YOU AND SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE DID IT AND
ATION OF THAT. WAS TO HOUSE A
RESEARCH SPECIALIST RESEARCH
DATA SPECIALIST WITHIN OUR
UNIT- AS WELL AS AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE I REALLY ENVISIONED AS
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY YOU SOME
BAR CONTRACT PLANS- TO HELP
DEVELOP GUIDANCE AROUND WHAT
KINDS OF DATA WE SHOULD BE
COLLECTING AND WHAT KINDS OF
DATA WE WANT TO WORK FOR ALL OF
YOU AND HAVING THE CAPACITY TO
DO THAT LEVEL OF ANALYSIS-
LEAKAGE EXCEPT. AND THEN
THERE'S ALSO RELEASE DATACORE
OF THE ASKED FOR JUST. WITH OUR
VARIOUS DEPART. OBVIOUSLY SIR
THESE KIDS IN CHILD WELFARE.
BEHAVIORAL PROGRAM EXCEPT. OKAY
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF IS
THAT. AND I GUESS THE ONE
CAUTION I WOULD HAVE THE
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY GAUGES AND
RESEARCH IS THAT WE DON'T WANT
OVER DATING FOR DATA BURDEN
PEOPLE ETHER SO. BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT INTERESTING YOU
SPEAK TO IS THE TIMELINE FOR
DEVELOPING THESE METRICS
BECAUSE IT'S HARD YOU CAN'T BUT
YOU KNOW THE METRICS YOU CAN'T
DO A DATA COLLECTION METHOD
WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO COLLECT SO. YOU SPEAK
TO THE TIMELINE WHICH
ANTICIPATE WITH THE STATEWIDE
METRICS WOULD BE DEVELOPED SO
THAT FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE WITH
A FOLLOW UP ON THAT. YEAH I
THINK IT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION I'M NOT SURE I KNOW
THE SPECIFICS ON THE TIMELINE I
APOLOGIZE I HAVE TO. GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT. IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT JUST US BECAUSE WE DO IT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THAT. D. O. J.
AND SO. IF YOU- IF THAT WOULD
BE A CAMPAIGN TO GET BACK TO I
DON'T WANT TO BE INCORRECT. I'M
PUTTING TOGETHER A TIME LINE
FOR YOU OKAY NO THANK YOU- THAT
WOULD BE VERY IMPORTANT TO GET
A TIME LINE I THINK WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR OUR DELIBERATIONS
BEFORE WE FINALIZE BUDGET TO
HAVE THAT TIME LINE AND BE SURE
THAT THE TIMELINE IS SUCH THAT
WE WILL. KNOW WE WILL HAVE
TIMELY- ACCESS TO. DATA TO
EVALUATE THIS PROGRAM SO I
APPRECIATE THAT IF YOU GET BACK
TO THE STAFF OF THE TIMELINE.
OF BEFORE WE REVISIT THIS
ISSUE- AT. NAY REVISED THAT
WOULD BE EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
YES CENTER. IN THE SEVENTIES
FROM THE HOSPITAL. THINGS WE
WANT TO HELP. PROGRAM WHICH HAS
BEEN OVERFUNDED OR IF YOU ARE A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND YOU
CONSEQUENCES THAT IS WE HAVE A
NUMBER MANY MANY AB ONE
THOUSAND NOW. ONE WAS. LIVING
ON THE SOME ISSUES THAT YOU CAN
YOUR NOT. I THINK WE- OF THE
AND THE REQUESTED- COUNTIES
WERE NOT FROM TO BRING TO
ADEQUATELY. ADDRESS THEM OF THE
ON NOW WE HAVE THE YOUTH
SUFFICIENT POINTED OUT SOME OF
THE MOST- THE BEER RESPONSES
HAVE BEEN COMMITTED. AND BEGAN
OPPORTUNITY QUESTIONS DOWN TO
THE COUNTY LEVEL WHERE
RESOURCES MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE
I'M JUST WOULD LIKE TO HEAR YOU
TALK ABOUT WHY YOU THINK THAT
THIS TIME- YOU THINK IT WILL BE
A SUCCESSFUL EFFORT TO DO WHAT
WHAT EXPERIENCE. IT WAS A
LITTLE BIT HARD TO HEAR YOU BUT
I THINK I GOT THE MOST OF IT
WHICH WAS TALKING ABOUT YOUR
CONCERNS THAT THERE MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH RESOURCES LOCALLY TO
SEVERITIES KIDS ADEQUATELY- I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
WOULD ALSO- WHAT I WOULD ALSO
SAY IS THAT WE KNOW THAT IT'S A
MUCH BETTER USE OF FUNDS TO
SERVE THESE. CHILDREN OR YOUNG
PEOPLE- LOCALLY AT IT
ULTIMATELY IS GOING TO. SAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF DOLLARS
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THESE
INDIVIDUALS GRADUATING INTO THE
ADULT CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
WHETHER THAT BE THROUGH LOCAL
JAILS- AND OR BUT UNFORTUNATELY
MAYBE EVEN ENDING UP IN ANY OF
OUR STATE FACILITIES- AND SO. I
THINK THAT- THIS IS AN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO WHAT RESEARCH
WOULD SAY IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND
THAT ULTIMATELY. IS GOING TO
SAVE THAT THE LOCAL. COUNTY
MONEY BUT ALSO BE. IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE YOUTH AND THE
FAMILIES AND I THINK
GENERATIONS OF FAMILIES- AND SO
I THINK WE FEEL PRETTY I THINK
WE FEEL REALLY CONFIDENT WILL
ALSO OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE
REALLY LOOKING AT THE
EXPENDITURES THAT IS DEFINITELY
PART OF THE PLAN REVIEW PROCESS.
IT NIGHT YOU PROBABLY A BIT
WITH DIFFICULT TO HEAR ME. I'M
JUST. IS TO SUMMARIZE BECAUSE I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU THAT
IDEALLY. WE WOULD. GET THIS
PRINTED UP THE PROBLEM RIGHT
RATHER THAN DEAL WITH IT. BACK
IN THE OFFICE I DON'T DISAGREE.
IN MY- I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE
WITH YOU THAT THEIR RE ENTRY
PROCESS SHOULD START REALLY
ONCE THEY- ENTER THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THAT'S BETTER FOR
EVERYONE BUT MY CONCERN. IS-
YOU KNOW HAVE TRIED THIS BEFORE
IN THE STATE WITH WHEN WE CLOSE
DOWN THE STATE HOSPITALS AND
CREATED A COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH. SERVICES AND THAT HAS
NOT WORKED AS AS EVIDENCED BY
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS PEOPLE
WE SEE IN THE STREETS OF MENTAL
ILLNESS ISSUES AND WE'VE SEEN
THIS WHEN YOU DON'T ALLEN'S
WORK CHRISTIANITY COUNTY LEVEL.
THE COUNTIES WERE GIVEN THE
MONEY AND THE RESOURCES.
PROVIDE THE SERVICES AND THINGS
THAT THEY NEEDED IN THE- IN I
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT AGAIN
WITH THIS JUVENILE POPULATION
SOMETHINGTHAT REALLY WAS
THERE. THE COURT MY QUESTION
WAS. YOU KNOW CAN YOU TELL ME.
WHY YOU HAVE SO MUCH CONFIDENCE
THAT THIS TIME. IT'S GOING TO
BE EFFECTIVE AND IT'S GOING TO
WORK. I THINK THE THING THAT I
WOULD SAY IT IS. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE WE HAVE SOME INTERESTING
AND EXCITING NEW THINGS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO TO EXPAND
AND MAKE A VERY FOCUSED EFFORTS
ON INVESTING IN OUR COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SYSTEM- WELL
NOT ALL OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
CERTAINLY MANY OF THEM. I HAVE
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIOR HEALTH
ISSUES AND I THINK WE'RE
REALLY. WE'RE TRYING I
RECOGNIZE WITH WHAT THE U.
SAYING CLEARLY YOU KNOW MY
BACKGROUND SO- I'M I'M FAMILIAR
WITH THE FACT THAT WE WANT TO
INVEST MORE IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SYSTEM IMPACT. I KNOW.
CONSIDERING THAT THE
PERSPECTIVES OF THE TWO OTHER
SENATORS WHO ARE HERE.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO DO THAT AND
SO I THINK WE REALLY MADE AN
EFFORT AS THE ADMINISTRATION IN
THIS PARTICULAR YEAR YOU REALLY
LOOK AT THAT BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONTINUUM. AND AGAIN. THESE
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
SERVED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES CAN
REALLY LEVERAGE THOSE PROGRAMS.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
INVESTING IN- THE ONLY PART OF
THE SEATING AS ADDITIONAL
SERVICES SO- I RESPECT YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING- BUT A VERY- I FEEL
REALLY CONFIDENT THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THESE CHEAP THAT
THESE CAMPS AND ALSO THAT THE.
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THEIR- THE NEW
YORK QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
DEPARTMENT FINANCE REALLY- OKAY
THEN WE WILL LEAVE THIS OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN. HEY MAN THIS IS MARK ON
EACH WITH HOUSING HUMAN
SERVICES THE LAST ITEM IN THIS
MARKET IS THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION
REAPPROPRIATION. AND AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUE FOR SELF DRIVING IS
GOING TO TAKE THE LEAD IN
CREATING A GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
HI. THIS IS A RESPONSE TO THE
COMMITTEE'S FIRST QUESTION- TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW HOW DOES
THIS PROPOSAL IS REQUESTING TO
RE APPROPRIATE THE FUNDS THAT-
THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL WORK- GIVEN
THE PRIORITIES TO COATED IN THE
VACCINE ROLLOUT. THE CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL COMMISSION WAS PUT ON
HOLD. BACK IN FALL TWENTY
TWENTY AND THIRTY MINISTRATION
WAY WORKING ON PLANS TO RESUME
PUBLIC MEETINGS. THIS SPRING.
THE OPERATED FUNDS WOULD ALLOW
US TO COMPLETE THE SECOND
REPORT THAT'S DUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON DESIGN
CONSIDERATIONS FOR UNIFIED
FINANCING OF HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW LAST SUMMER WE
ALL THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
FIRST REPORT WHICH WAS FOCUS ON
ENVIRONMENTAL WHICH WAS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS THIS
STORE- CURRENT STATE OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
AND JUST TO GO ON TO YOUR
SECOND QUESTION- REGARDING THE
RELEASE OF THE SECOND REPORT.
WORSE STILL WORKIN ON THE PLAN
TO RESUME THE PUBLIC MEETINGS
FOR THE COMMISSION WHAT WE
EXPECT FROM THE WORK ON THE
SECOND REPORT TO CONTINUE THIS
SPRING AND INTO THE FALL. AND
WE DON'T EXPECT THE SECOND
REPORT TO BE FINALIZED TOM ANY
SOONER THAN EARLY. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS HERE BUT CENTER
GRANTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AS
I GUESS ONE THE X. OFFICIALS ON
THE COMMISSION- APPRECIATE THE
WORK I LOOK FORWARD TO- THE
COMMISSION CONTINUING ITS WORK-
YEAH THAT- HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
A LITTLE BETTER ENGAGEMENT WITH
COMMISSIONERS FOR THE SECOND
REPORT THEN WE DID THE FIRST
ONE. BUT OVERALL I CAN
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE- THAT WE
CONTINUE THIS- VERY IMPORTANT
EFFORTS SPECIALLY WITH THE NEW
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION. WITH
THE INTELLIGENCE OF THE CHAIR
MAY JUST GO BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE VERY BRIEFLY- THE-
SO ON EQUITY CENTER PROGRAMS I
DO WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
MINISTRATION FOR PUTTING
FORWARD RESOURCES FOR STAFF FOR
LOOKING AT EQUITY YEAH I'M
OFFERING A BILL ON. RACISM AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS I HAVE
WOULD JUST SERVE ASKED THAT WE
CONSIDER- AND GUESTS ONLY
KNOWING CONSTRAINTS WE HAVE THE
BUDGET. THAT WHILE WE'RE PRETTY
DETECTIVE PLEDGING FOR STATE
STAFF- EXACTLY WHAT RESOURCES
WE WILL ALSO BE PROVIDING FOR-
YOU KNOW COUNTIES AND OTHER
LOCAL ENTITIES BECAUSE-
CERTAINLY HEROES WE KNOW AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. NOTE
THAT COUNTIES ARE ACTUALLY THE
OPERATIONAL HARM SO- WAS WE
TALK ABOUT EVERY YOU KNOW AS WE
GO THROUGH ALL THE VARIOUS
THINGS THAT- WEEK WE TALK
ABOUT. AND SO I THINK THAT IT'S
IN ORDER FOR US TO FULLY BE
ABLE TO TAKE IN EQUITY LAND
CERTAINLY HAVINGTHAT STATE
LEADERSHIP AND HAVING STATE
STUFF'S REALLY IMPORTANT BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO ENSURE THAT. OUR
COUNTIES WHO ARE ACTUALLY
CARRYING OUT MANY OF OUR- BOTH
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICE
PROGRAMS ALSO HAVE SOME
RESOURCES TO DO THAT AND THAT
THERE BE SOME DISCUSSION WITH
OUR- LOCAL ENTITIES AND THAT
PARTICULAR COUNTIES AND HOW
THAT WOULD HAPPEN SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE THAT COMMENT THOSE
WERE LOOKING FOR TO- FINALIZING.
THE BUDGET AFTER ME REVISED
THANK YOU. HELLO PART OF A CALM.
WITH COME FROM WE NUMBER THAT
ITEM SO. WE AGAIN OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
EMPLOYERS POLITICIANS HERE AT
THE. OKAY CONTINUE. WE WERE
MOVING ONTO OKAY- WERE THERE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
LA- OR DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON
THAT LAST ITEM. BECAUSE NOW
WILL WE WILL THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR THEIR TIME AND
MOVE ONTO THE EMS AUTHORITY. HI
THERE AND GOOD AFTERNOON- I'M
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR ALL MY
DAYS EGGMAN. CLUB CENTER
MELINDA'S SAND CENTER DOCTOR
PAN NICE TO SEE YOU ALL. I'M
DAVE DUNCAN I'M AN EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE EMERGENCY EDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY R. M. STOP- I WILL
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENTS AND OUR BUDGET IF I
MAY TO STARTS. IN. OKAY WITH
EVERYBODY YES PLEASE OKAY
PERFECT. THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
SYSTEM WAS CREATED BACK IN
EIGHTY ONE BY HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE DIVISION TWO POINT FIVE
WITH THE INTENT OF CREATING A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM. WITH EMSA
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
COORDINATION AND INTEGRATION OF
ALL STATE ACTIVITIES CONCERNING
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES. TO
ENSURE A PROVISION OF EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CARE. I AM SAYS A SMALL
DEPARTMENT WITH SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITIES THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES FALL PRIMARILY
INTO THREE CATEGORIES OR
DIVISIONS. SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST PREHOSPITAL EMERGENCY
SERVICES- THAT'S ONE PIECE OF
EMERGENCY CARE NETWORK THAT'S
INTEGRATED WITH HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER
SERVICES. IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND CERTIFIED
EMTS. TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
LICENSEDPARAMEDICS THAT
RESPOND TO ABOUT FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION NINE ONE ONE
CALLS. I CAN ONLY. IN THEIR
OVERALL FORTY TWO HUNDRED
GROUND AMBULANCES AND A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SEVEN AIR AMBULANCES
WITHIN THAT SYSTEM SO THESE
FOLKS RESPOND TO THE ILL OR
INJURED. AND LET ME THEM TO ONE
OF THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS OF IT MAY ALSO BE
DESIGNATED SPECIALTY CENTERS.
FOR TIME SENSITIVE EMERGENCIES
LIKE TRAUMA STROKE SCAMMY-
SPECIFICALLY ANSWER IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR LICENSING
PARAMEDICS IN DISCIPLINING
THOSE LICENSES WHEN NECESSARY
PROVIDING SCOPE OF PRACTICE
TRAINING STANDARDS REGULATIONS
FOR ALL EMS LEVELS. INCLUDE
INCLUDING PUBLIC SAFETY FIRST
DAY- THERE'S BEEN CONSIDERABLE
INTEREST IN THE LEGISLATURE
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
CONCERNING MEDICAL
INTERVENTIONS ALIGNED FOR THE
PUBLIC AND FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL ASKING MS ALSO WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION- IN
ADMINISTRATION OF THOSE PIECES
SOME OF THOSE INCLUDE. TACTICAL
MEDICAL CARE FOR ALL LEVELS OF
RESPOND OR STE. INCLUDING A
EDIE'S AUTOMATED EXTERNAL
DEFIBRILLATORS IN PUBLIC
PLACES. THE AVAILABILITY OF
TRAINING IN THE USE OF HAPPY
FOR ALLERGIC SORRY EPINEPHRINE.
AUTO INJECTORS. NALOXONE OR NOR
CAN AS IT'S FREQUENTLY KNOWN
FOR NARCOTIC OVERDOSE SPIKE EMS
AND PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL. IN
A INCLUDING THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
EMS HELPS TRAIN THE PUBLIC IN
CPR AND NOW STOP THE BLEED
CAMPAIGNS. WE ALSO HAVE A
LITTLE KNOWN ROLE TO SET
TRAINING STANDARDS AND
CERTIFIED TRAINING FOR
LICENSED. CHILD CARE PROVIDERS-
AN IMPORTANT INITIATIVE FROM M.
SO REGARDING THE ROLE OF
PARAMEDICS IS AN IMPROVED
HEALTH WORK FORCE PILOT PROJECT
THROUGH THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. THE TEST AND
EVALUATE THE USE OF PARAMEDICS
AND EXPANDED MOBILE HEALTH CARE
ROLES THAT FILL IDENTIFIED GAPS
IN LOCAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO CARE IN
INTEGRATION OF CARE. THE
EVALUATION FOR THE PILOT
PROJECTS ARE CONDUCTED BY THE
UC SAN FRANCISCO CENTER FOR
HEALTH POLICY AND WORKFORCE.
THE RESULTS OF THESE PILOTS
DEMONSTRATE THAT PARAMEDICS CAN
EFFECTIVELY IN SAFETY WORK
SAFELY WORK. WITH PATIENTS TO
REDUCE REPEAT HOSPITALIZATIONS
DECREASED NINE ONE ONE CALLS.
REFORM OUTRAGE FOR HARD TO
REACH PATIENTS AND IDENTIFY
PATIENTS SECOND BETTER BE
TREATED IN SETTINGS. OTHER THAN
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. ALL
WITHOUT DISPLACING ANY OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. SECONDS
CATEGORY OF RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RAMPS- THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM IS
A TWO TIERED SYSTEM OF EMS
RESPONSE SO WE HAVE A TYPICAL
TEACHER RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES EPSRC
DEVELOPS GUIDELINES AND
APPROVES PLANS FOR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SYSTEMS THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTED AND OPERATED BY
LOCAL EMS AGENCIES OFTEN KNOWN
AS LAMB SAYS. SO THERE ARE
THIRTY THREE LAMB SAYS THAT
INCLUDE TWENTY SIX SINGLE
COUNTY LANCERS ENDS IN MULTI
COUNTY LEADS US OF THE MULTI
COUNTIES TYPICALLY SERVE LARGE
RURAL REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA-
THESE LOCAL LAMB SAYS DIRECT
NINE ONE ONE AMBULANCE SERVICE.
AND PROVIDE MEDICAL DIRECTION
AND OVERSIGHT AT THAT LEVEL-
IT'S ALSO DEVELOPS THE
REGULATIONS IN THE DESIGN AND
QUALITY OF SPECIALTY CARE
SYSTEMS IMPLEMENTED WITHIN
MULLIN SAYS INCLUDING THE
TRAUMA SYSTEM WHERE WE HAVE
SEVENTY NINE DESIGNATED
CENTRES. HE AFTER EMERGENCY
CARE CENTERS INCLUDING
PEDIATRIC TRAUMA CENTERS. THIS
STROKES SYSTEM WITH A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY DESIGNATED STROKE
CENTERS. RT ACT DAMMY THE
CENTERS AS THEY'RE KNOWN OF
WHICH THERE ARE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN AND WE ALSO
ADMINISTER VIA POISON CONTROL
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. ONE OF
OUR PRIORITY INITIATIVES IS TO
ASSESS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
EMS SYSTEM. USING IMPROVE LOCAL
AND REGIONAL DATA SO WITH THE
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
NINE WHICH WAS CHAPTER IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE HAVE
CONVERTED ALL PROVIDERS TO
ELECTRONIC DOCUMENTATION OF
PATIENT CARE THAT CAN BE
AGGREGATED ANALYZED. USED FOR
SYSTEM EVALUATION AND
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT. WE
HELP LOCAL EMS SYSTEMS. IN
PROVIDERS EXCHANGE CLINICAL
DATA WITH HOSPITAL SO THAT
PARAMEDICS CAN OUT PATIENT
INFORMATION IN THE FIELD AND
HOSPITALS CAN RECEIVE
INFORMATION FROM YOUR MOUSE OF
THIS INITIATIVE ALSO IMPROVES
CARE DURING A DISASTER BY
MAKING CRITICAL PATIENT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE. WHEN
PATIENTS ARE TREATED IN
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS. ON THE THIRD
A MAJOR AREA OF RESPONSIBILITY
THAT SFA. ADMINISTERS IS THE
MEDICAL RESPONSE TO DISASTERS
WE'VE BEEN SO. FIND IN OVER THE
LAST YEAR I AM SO PARTNERS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH UNDER WHAT'S
CALLED THE ESFA ESFA GUIDELINES
TO BUILD A PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MEDICAL RESPONSE EMERGENCY
SYSTEM. IN COMBINATION WITH OUR
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS INTO PLANNED FOR
THE MEDICAL IMPACT OF ANY TYPE
OF DISASTER OR HEALTHCARE
EMERGENCY AS WE SEE CURRENTLY.
AS PART OF OUR PLANNING EFFORTS
AND STUFF DEVELOPS AND
MAINTAINS THE HOSPITAL INCIDENT
COMMAND SYSTEM ALSO KNOWN AS
HICKS. WHICH IS BECOMING
NATIONAL STANDARDS IN AN
INTERNATIONAL MODEL- IF SAY HAS
DEVELOPED RESOURCES FOR IT YOUR
RESPONSE TO DISASTERS TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
RESPONSES IN THE FIELD. THE
FIRST YEAR CURRENTLY CONSISTS
OF FORTY TWO DISASTER MEDICAL
SUPPORT UNITS WHICH SERVE AS A
LEAD VEHICLE FOR AMBULANCE
STRIKE TEAMS. OF THE UNITS ARE
HOUSED IN LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND CAN BE USED TO SUPPORT
PATIENT MOVEMENTS FIELD TRIAGE
TREATMENTS AND STAGING FOR
MULTI CASUALTY INCIDENTS AND
THAT CAN USUALLY BE ALIGNED
WITHIN THE FIRST COUPLE OF
HOURS IN RESPONSE TO A DISASTER.
OF THESE UNITS ALONG WITH
AMBULANCE STRIKE TEAMS ARE
ROUTINELY USED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SECOND MULTI
CASUALTY EVENTS OR HOSPITAL
EVACUATION. OF THE STRIKE TEAMS
WERE RECENTLY USED TO EVACUATE
OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
PATIENTS DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTY WILDFIRES. INTO TRAIL
SCORED TO APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY PATIENTS OUT OF
IMPERIAL COUNTY TO RECEIVE
HOSPITALS RECEIVING HOSPITALS
AND- THE LINE CARE FOR THOSE
FOLKSTHAT DURING THE COLD
NINETEEN SURGE PROMINENTLY HOW
BACK IN MAY AND JUNE. THIS
SECOND TIER CONSISTS ALSO OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
TEAMS YOU'LL HEAR CALMATTERS
FREQUENTLY REFERRED TO. THAT
CAN DEPLOY WITHIN TWELVE HOURS
OF ACTIVATION AND SUPPORT ANY
LOCATION IN CALIFORNIA. THESE
ARE ONE OF THE MOST FLEXIBLE
DIRECT PATIENT CARE ASSETS THAT
WE COVER A BECAUSE THEY CAN BE
DEPLOYED AS A FIVE TO FIFTY
MEMBER HEALTHCARE TEAM. ARE
THEY CAN TAKE ON HEALTH CARE
MISSIONS RANGING FROM ACUTE
EMERGENCY CARE TO THE
MANAGEMENT OF EVACUATED LONG
TERM CARE PATIENTS WE'VE EVEN
HAD COME OUT TEAMS IN HOSPITALS
OVER THE LAST A- RESPONSE FOR
COVERAGE. IN ADDITION PERSONNEL
CAN BE PULLED FROM OUR DISASTER
HEALTH CARE VOLUNTEER REGISTRY.
THAT CURRENTLY CONTAINS NEARLY
A HUNDRED THOUSAND LICENSE
PERSONAL ALL TYPES. INCLUDING
THE LOCALLY ORGANIZED MEDICAL
RESERVE CORPS THAT SAID THE
COUNTY'S COVER. PROXIMAL
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DISASTER
HEALTHCARE VOLUNTEERS AND
MEDICAL RESERVE CORPS MEMBERS
HAVE SUPPORTED VARIOUS MEDICAL
MISSIONS DURING THE MID
NINETEEN RESPONSE- WITHOUT I'M
GONNA TRANSITION SUMMARY OF THE-
MS OUR PROPOSED BUDGET WILL
CONTINUE OUR CHIEF OF
ADMINISTRATION RECORD TRUSSELL
IF I MAY ALL RIGHT THEN I'LL
TICKETS TO. ISSUE NUMBER TWO
THE- ACTUALLY I WAS INCLUDING
THIS JUST IN THE OVER ARCHING-
OKAY SUMMARY FOR ABSOLUTE FAN-
FULL ON THAT IF YOU LIKE I CAN
GO TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE THEN
FOR WHERE ARE WE GONNA GO TO
FOR- WHEN I WAS COVERING I
CONSIDERED TO BE ISSUE NUMBER
ONE SHOW WE GO TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO YES. OKAY THANK YOU FLAT
OUT. ADULT METAL DEFINITELY
KEEP ME MORE ORGANIZED IF I MAY
OKAY- THANK YOU FOR THAT ISSUE
NUMBER TWO I'M I'M ALSO GOING
TO HAND TO OURCHIEF OF
ADMINISTRATION FOR TRUST. THANK
YOU RIGHT. IN AND I WILL SAY TO
A TO RECKON THINKING DR DUNCAN
ALL THE REST OF PROVIDERS WHO
HAS TO BE SOMEONE BRIEF WE WANT
TO BE COGNISANT OF ALL OF US
HERE IN THE SAME ROOM FOR
EXTENDED HOURS AND- ALL AND WE
DO HAVE. MOST OF THE OVERVIEW
WRITTEN UP SO- IF FUTURE PEOPLE
COULD BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
BRIEF TO KEEP BUSINESSES THINK
THIS. IS WE CAN'T. AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AT THE DEARTH
AND BREATH OF THE SON OF THIS
ORGANIZATION. OKAY THANK YOU.
YOU ARE MUTED MY FRIEND. NO I'M
I'M ACTUALLY NOT MUTED CAN
EVERYBODY HEAR ME YES WE CAN
WE'VE GOT CHEN AND- SO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO IS WELL ONE OF THREE
BUDGET PROPOSALS WE HAVE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RELEASED IN
JANUARY. IT'S IT REQUEST TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON GOING
INTO PERMANENT POSITIONS TO
MEET INCREASED WORKLOAD WITHIN
THE OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
REGULATORY AND EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS. AND WITHIN THE LEGAL
OFFICE. ASSOCIATE WITH MANDATED
REPORTING CAST EIGHTY FOUR
THREE FOUR COMPLIANCE AND
CREATION OF CONTENT AND ONGOING
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MS INTRANET-
THE FIRST POSITION AND THAT L.
EA YOU IT IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS
INCREASED WORKLOAD WITHIN THE
OFFICE. OF L. EA TO COORDINATE
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT RELATED TO EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND DISASTER
ESPONSE AND MITIGATION MANNER
GOVERNMENTAL COMMUNICATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF MS AS LEAD ROLE. IN
OUR CALIFORNIA'S EMERGENCY
SUPPORT FUNCTION EIGHT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND MEDICAL THE SECOND
POSITION BEING REQUESTED IS
NEEDED TO ADDRESS INCREASED
WORKLOAD WITHIN THE LEGAL
OFFICE. ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MANDATED REPORTING TASKS SB
FOUR THREE FOUR COMPLIANCE
ISSUES AND THE ONGOING CREATION
OF CONTENT AND WORK- ONGOING
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTATION. OF MS AS
INTRANET. THAT COULD MY BRIEF
OVERVIEW IF THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS I CAN MOVE ON THE
ISSUE TO. I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AKTIF PLEASE. THE
SECOND PROPOSAL CONCERNS THE
REGIONALS ASTRONOMICAL HEALTH
RESPONSE PROGRAM WE'RE
REQUESTING THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO IMPROVE RESULTS
ASTRONOMICAL HEALTH
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE RECOVERY
AND MITIGATION BY FINDING THREE
ADDITIONAL REGIONAL DISASTER
MEDICAL HEALTH SPECIALISTS TO
SERVICE SHARED RESOURCES WITHIN
THE SIX CALIFORNIA- YES MUTUAL
AID TO REGIONS. THESE POSITIONS
ALL ALL ARE ALL LOCALLY BASED
THROUGH FUNDING TO LOCAL LENDS
US ROCK CALIFORNIA THE ARGUMENT
JUST PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED
USES THE STATE REGIONS AND
COUNTIES IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
MUTUAL ASSISTANCE AGREEMENTS
STANDARDIZED PLANNING AND
MITIGATION EFFORTS REGIONAL
MEDICAL HEALTH RESPONSE PLANS
IN REGIONAL RECOVERY PLANS. IN
ADDITION ARGUMENT JUST
PERSONALITY TASKED WITH WORKING
WITH THE LOCALS AND REGIONAL
TRAINING AND EXERCISING IN
PREPARATION FOR DISASTERS.
FURTHER THE ARGUMENT JUST AS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TIMELY
REGIONAL COORDINATION OF
MEDICAL HEALTH RESOURCES DURING.
pRECENT STAFF AT THE LOW LEVEL
WILL ALLOW FOR AROUND THE CLOCK
EMERGENCY DISASTER SUPPORT
ENHANCED BACKUP BEFORE DURING
AND AFTER A DISASTER RESPONSES
IN APPROVED DEVELOPMENT OF THE
REGIONALLY COUNTY MEDICAL
HEALTH DISASTER RESPONSE
SYSTEM. REGIONAL DISASTER
MEDICAL HELPS ARE CRITICAL TO
BOTH DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE WITHIN CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS I CAN
PROCEED IF THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS I CAN PROCEED ISSUE
NUMBER SORRY HAVEN'T GOT.
QUESTIONS SO THE FUNDING IS
THIS TO THE THIS DOESN'T LOK
LIKE IT'S FOR STATE STAFF IS
JUST TO PAY FOR A LOCAL STAFF
AT THE REGION'S I JUST. LIKE
LOW CLARITY ABOUT WHAT THE
MONEY IS CORRECT IT'S A REQUEST
FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE FUNDING
OKAY SO WE WILL GRANT IT TO A
LOCAL ENTITY WITHIN HIRE THE
PERSON. OUR PAY FOR HER PART OF
THE PERSON. OKAY YES SIR OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY THE THURMOND IS.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
COMMUNITY PARAMEDIC OR TRIAGE-
YEAH THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS TO
POSITIONS IN GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF- AT
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IN GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
OF FORTY OF SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND AND TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. TO IMPLEMENT
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICINE PROJECTS
FOR LOCAL EMS AGENCIES PURSUANT
TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR STATUES OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AB FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR CREATES THE COMMUNITY
PARAMEDICINE ARE TRIAGED
ALTERNATE DESTINATION AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY. WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE A LOCAL EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AGENCY OR
LAMBS ARE TO DEVELOP AND SEEK
APPROVAL FOR A PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES VARIOUS THE VARIOUS
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICS IN TRIAGE
PARAMEDIC SERVICES. COMMUNITY
PARAMEDICINE IS A NEW ANY
EVOLVING METHOD OF COMMUNITY
BASED HEALTH CARE IN WHICH
PARAMEDICS FUNCTION OUTSIDE OF
THEIR CUSTOMARY EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND TRANSPORT ROLES.
HERMETIC PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED
TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC LOCAL
PROBLEMS AND TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF LOCALLY DEVELOPED
COLLABORATIONS BETWEEN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES AND
OTHER HEALTH CARE AND SOCIAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS. CALIFORNIA
THROUGH MS- IN THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT HAS PILOTED
COMMUNITY PARAMEDIC PROGRAM FOR
SIX YEARS INDEPENDENT
EVALUATORS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO I
FOUND THE PILOTS TO BE A SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE MEANS OF
UTILIZING PARAMEDICS. TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE PUBLIC ALLOWING EXPANDED
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AND CASE MANAGEMENT. SB FIFTEEN
FORTY FOUR REQUIRES ENDS OF THE
PROVIDE ONGOING SERVICES IN
OVERSIGHT TWO LENSES REGARDING
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICINE PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS PROMULGATE AN UPDATE
MULTIPLE CHAPTERS OF
REGULATIONS. AND IT SAYS HERE
THAT. THE PROJECTS ARE TESTING
SEVEN DIFFERENT CONCEPTS FOR
THE PRACTICE THE WHICH ARE
LISTED BUT WE ALSO SEE FOURTEEN
PROJECTS ARE STILL IN ROLLING
AND SOME HAVE ALREADY CEASED TO
EXIST FROM THE- FROM TO HELP
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. WHAT WERE
THE OUTCOMES FOR THOSE DO WE
KNOW AND WHAT KIND OF METRICS
ARE WE MEASURING JUST ALL THE
METRICS. THAT ARE LISTED IN
FORTY PEOPLE APPLIED TO DO ONE
OF THE SEVEN OR ALL OF THE
SEVEN FOUR IS THAT A
COMBINATION. WHEN COMMUNITIES
APPLY FOR THAT. THAT IS A GREAT
QUESTION I'M GOING TO DEFER TO
OUR CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR LOUIS
BROWN KEY TO PROVIDE AN ANSWER
ON THAT. GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR
TELEMATICS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. IN THE OVERSIGHT FOR
THOSE OR THE- FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS WAS PROVIDED- THE
SYSTEM EVALUATION WAS PROVIDED.
BY THE UNIVERSITY OF. SAN
FRANCISCO WHO MONITOR THE
PROGRAM AND- IN COLLABORATION
WITH EMSA AND ARSHAD I
DEVELOPED A- EVALUATION
CRITERIA FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND THE IN THE OUTCOME THE
ANSWER IS- WHAT IS CURRENTLY
APPEARING THE- REPORT OR-
PUBLICATION. WE'RE SO PREPARING
THE REPORT WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE
OF THE OUTCOME IS YET THE
OUTCOMES WERE ALL FAVORABLE AND
THEY CONTRIBUTED TO THE- TO
THE- THAT. LEGISLATION AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR. THAT WILL
IT WHAT BEGAN. IN ON JANUARY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. MAY I ALSO
ADD ONE QUICK COMMENT LOS UPON
ME- DURING THESE PILOT PROGRAMS
WE'VE ALSO HAD EXTENSIVE AND
DETAILED QUARTERLY REPORTS
ALIGNED ON ALL THE PILOT
PROGRAMS LOOKING AT SPECIFIC
METRICS AND OUTCOMES ALONG THE
WAY FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
THEN WE GET A MORE DETAILED
ANNUAL REPORTS SO WE'RE WE'RE
CAREFULLY MONITORING METRICS
OUTCOMES WITH RESPECT TO ALL.
SEVEN OF THE PILOT PROGRAM-
CATEGORIES OF THE OTHER ANSWER
THE OTHER QUESTION YOU HAD WAS
A PICK ONE OR A COMBINATION ARE
THEY CAN'T PICK A COMBINATION
SOME COUNTIES ARE INTERTWINED
IN. HIS MANY AS TWO OR THREE OF
THESE CATEGORIES BUT MANY OF
JUST TAKEN ONE CATEGORY ON.
OKAY BUT IS THERE IS THERE ONE
THAT PEOPLE TAKEON MORE THAN
THE OTHERS ONE THAT'S USED MORE.
ALL TAKE THAT AS WELL- AND I
WILL ALSO REMEMBER ONE OTHER
QUESTION YOU ANSWERED WERE YOU
ASKED WHICH WAS- YOU KNOW HELLO
FOLKS DROPPED OUT OR OR HOW
MANY AND WHAT'S TENDED TO
HAPPEN IS- SOME OF THE FUNDING
FOR THIS OVER THE COURSE OF
FIVE YEARS HAS HAS DRIED UP IN
A COUPLE OF PROGRAMS HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO CONTINUE PRIMARILY
BASED ON FUNDING ISSUES. I
THINK THE MOST COMMON OF THIS
SEVEN- IS THE SOBERING CENTER
IN THAT WE HAVE I THINK THREE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES THAT HAVE
TAKEN OUT ON. BUT MANY MANY
HAVE TAKEN ON TWO OF THESE SO
IT'S FAIRLY UBIQUITOUS
UBIQUITOUS ACROSS THE- THE LIST
OF SEVEN. HOSPICE WOULD BE THE
LEAST. A DOCTORED PROGRAM- IN
PLACE CURRENTLY- THAT INDIRECT
DIRECTLY OBSERVED THERAPY FOR
TUBERCULOSIS THOSE TO HAVE BEEN
SORT OF A MINIMALLY ADOPTED BUT
CLEARLY STUDY. THANK YOU OKAY I
THINK YOU KNOW JUST TO ADD
DENTAL TO TOUCH A COP DR DUNCAN
SCOTT COMMENTS ON THE- PRO
PROGRAMS HAVE ENROLLED- FIVE
THOUSAND AND NOW THREE MIDDLE
AND IN THE MENTAL HEALTH.
PROGRAM HE END UP IN THE
ALTERNATE DOES DESTINATION
SOBERING CENTER PROJECTS IN
ROME IT WAS TWO THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE. BUT I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND DIE I
DID HAVE A CHEAT YOU KNOW THAT
THIS BILL WENT THROUGH THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE AND- I KNOW
THAT- WE LOOK AT SOME OF THE
FOLLOWING DATA I BELIEVE THAT-
MANY OF THEM DID SHOW GOOD
RESULTS- THE POST DISCHARGE
SHORT TERM FOLLOW UP I THINK
THAT RESULTS OF SOMEONE NEXT-
AND- AND I THINK THERE WERE
SOME CONCERNS THEN. ABOUT-
HOUSE ALSO THAT WAS SO I THINK
WE MAINLY IN THE BILL EXPANDED
THE OTHER ONES AND SAID WILL
SORT OF. BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU IS I
SEE THAT NOW THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL OF COURSE IS ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF. THE
ANALYSIS DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY
MENTION THIS BUT IF IT DOES
REFER TO. FUNDING GOING TO THE
M. S. INFORMATION SYSTEM AND OF
COURSE WE'RE HAVING. IT
TECHNOLOGIST ETCETERA. THE IS
THERE GOING TO BE ON GOING
EVALUATIONS OF THE PREVIOUS
PILOTS WERE OF- THERE'S A
CONTRACT I THINK WAS UCSF THE
DID THE EVALUATION ARE THEY
STILL GOING TO CONTINUE TO. DO
AN EVALUATION OR IS THAT GOING
TO BE BROUGHT IN IN STATE
THAT'S ALL WE CAN CONTINUE THE
VALUATION IS GOING TO BE DOING
THAT AS WE'RE EXPANDING THIS
UP. THE PROGRAM. THE FOURTEENTH
OF. FORTY FOUR- IT PROVIDES FOR
THE CREATION OF AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO OVERSEE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE REGULATIONS
SURE FRANK V. PARAMEDICINE
PROGRAM IN THE- IN THE-
EVALUATION BUT WILL- CRITERIA
WILL BE A- DEVELOPED BY THE
ACTED BY THREE COMMITTEE AND
IN- WHICH WILL BE SUPPORTING
THEM SO. IN THE PROPAGATION OF
THE OF THE REGULATIONS. CRYSTAL
CLEAR FIVE I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS THAT THE EVALUATION
WILL BE DONE IN HOUSE INSTEAD
OF BY UCSF WHICH DID THE
INITIAL EVALUATION CORRECT. IT
WILL BE BILL WILL CONTINUE TO
BE AN INDEPENDENT EVALUATION OF
THE PROGRAMS. AND THAT WILL BE
DONE BY UCSF WE HAD WE HAD IT
AT THIS POINT. OKAY A CONTRACT
WITH THEM TO CONTINUE THE
EVALUATION THEN. OKAY IS THAT
IS THAT ACTUALLY OUTLINED IN
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL I DIDN'T
SEE THAT. LOOTED AND A PIECE
THAT'S REFER TO. YES DOCTOR
DOCUMENTED THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL. OKAY IS
THAT THE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND ARE I MEAN I'M JUST
AND I'M BUT I'M LOOKING AT THE
HOUSES ON THE SHORTS COMING OUT
OF. OKAY LOVE YOU CAN THAT
PLEASE- CLARIFIED THAT- FOR ARE
WE YOU KNOW. AS WE LOOK AT THE
BUDGET MOVING FORWARD I DON'T I
KNOW THAT WE DON'T SPEND TOO
MUCH TIME. INTO THAT BUT- AT
THE TELEPHONE NO- VALUATION YOU
KNOW SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE GOING
TO USE USE YEP THAT'S FINE I
MEAN THEY DID THE PREVIOUS ONE
RIGHT EXACTLY HOW MUCH MONEY.
IT'S GOING TO BE DONE- YELPING
CONTRACTED FOR THE EVALUATION
TO HAVE KNOWN AT LEAST THE
RANGE MAYBE THE BIT HASN'T GONE
OUT YET. AND SO FORTH- I THINK
IT'S HELPFUL TO BE ABLE TO.
HAVE THAT INFORMATION THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY DOCTOR WE WILL ENSURE
THAT YOU. GET THAT INFORMATION.
OKAY THANK YOU. CENTER OF
HONEST QUESTIONS. OKAY SHALL WE
MOVE ON THEN. THIS IS RICHTER
ALSO BE SPEAKING ON ISSUE FIVE
OKAY WHICH IS REGARDING OUR
COVE IN NINETEEN FUNDING AND-
YOU- QUESTION NUMBER ONE IS TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF ACCOUNTING OF
ALLOCATIONS OF FUNDING. MS OUR
FOR PANDEMIC RELATED
EXPENDITURES AND FISCAL YEARS
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE UNDER SB EIGHTY NINE.
I AM SO RECEIVED TEN POINT SIX
FOUR SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
UNDER SB EIGHT EIGHTY NINE OR
SECTION THIRTY SIX ADJUSTMENT.
WE UTILIZE THAT FOR THE
PURCHASE OF NEW VENTILATORS THE
REFURBISHMENT OF EXISTING
VENTILATORS ALREADY POSSESSED
BY THE STATE. AND IN THE
VENTILATOR CERTIFICATION BY-
LICENSED BY MEDICAL
TECHNICIANS- THE FUNDING WAS
ALSO USED TO PROVIDE PATIENT
TRANSPORTATION MEDICAL STAFFING
AND STAND BY SERVICES AT
VARIOUS LOCALS MEDICAL SITES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR MOVE ON
QUESTION TO- I WOULD GUESS I
WOULD DISTINCT CARRY ALSO YOU
WHAT WE DO WITH ALL THE
TRADITIONAL RESPIRATORS THAT WE
PURCHASED GOING FORWARD. IF WE
DID A WHOLE BUNCH MORE FOR THE
PANDEMIC. THAT'S THAT'S
CERTAINLY A QUESTION FOR ME-
THESE HAVE ALL BEEN EVALUATED
REPACKAGED CHARGED AND READY TO
DEPLOY- WE'VE DEPLOYED ON THE-
CLOSE TO TWO THOUSAND WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A LOT MORE THAN
THAT I'M JUST DOUBLE CHECKING-
WE HAVE TWELVE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AVAILABLE- THE
PROJECTIONS. ALIGNED A WORST
CASE SCENARIO THAT WOULD
REQUIRE OVER TEN THOUSAND
VENTILATORS THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
THAT NUMBER IN PLACE. WELL
THAT'S SAID WHAT WILL WE DO
WITH ALL THESE WE WILL
CAREFULLY STORE THEM IN A
TEMPERATURE REGULATED
ENVIRONMENT BIOMED THEM AS
REQUIRED TO KEEP THE FUNCTIONAL
IN THE EVENT THAT THERE
REQUIRED AGAIN. ALL RIGHT. BUT
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THAT ACTUALLY I DID HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AFTER MAYBE AFTER THE
ANSWER ALL THE QUESTIONS OKAY
THAT'S IMPOSED. PLEASE PROCEED-
SO QUESTION NUMBER TWO WAS
PRODUCED PROVIDED REVIEW COUNTY
REVOCATIONS STEMS OF FOR
PANDEMIC RELATED EXPENDITURES
IN THE TWO FISCAL YEARS UNDER
THE JURY OR THE DISASTER
RECOVERY EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT. DURING THE LAST TWO
FISCAL YEARS MS OUR RE HAS
RECEIVED FROM THE JURY ACCOUNT
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY FOUR POINT
TWO SEVEN FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS FUNDING HAS BEEN USED IN
THE FOLLOWING CATEGORIES
AMBULANCE TRANSPORTS OF BIO
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT CALMAC
PERSONNEL SUPPORT. IT'S ME CAL
MASS HOURS AND BENEFITS
CHALAMET SUPPORT. MS OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS. MS OUR
OVERTIME HEALTH CORPS PERSONNEL
SALARIES AND BENEFITS HEALTH
COURSE SUPPORT- MEDICAL
SUPPLIES- PURCHASE OF PP.
TRAVEL EXPENSES FOR BOTH ENDS
AND CAL MAN STAFF AND AS WE
JUST DISCUSSED THE PURCHASE OF
VENTILATORS- SO ALL RIGHT AND
JUST FOR MY UNDERSTANDING YOU.
YOU ARE THE PURCHASER FOR THE
PP THAT THEN GOES TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND EACH INDIVIDUAL
COUNTY. NO WE ORIGINALLY AT THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC WE
ESSENTIALLY SPENT ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON PP. SINCE THEN- CDPH
AND DGS AND OTHER ENTITIES HAVE
BEEN PURCHASING HE P. E. AND WE
ARE- CORRECT- WHEN WE NEED P.
P. WE ARE REQUESTING THAT
THROUGH THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. IF THE CARD. A QUICK
QUESTION ON THE HEALTH CARE FOR
UP HEALTHCOR PERSONALE- LOOKS
LIKE WE SPENT THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION AND REAL FUNDING. HE I
KNOW WE DOES A STRAIGHT A HOW
MANY PEOPLE SIGNED UP BUT IN
TERMS OF ACTUALLY. SO HOW HOW
MANY HEALTH CORPS PERSONNEL WAS
THE THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
CAN GET A LITTLE BREAK DOWN IN
TERMS OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
DEPLOYED. AND SO FORTH THAT-
WE- EXPENDED THIS FUNDS FOR.
YOU'RE VERY WITH ME ONE SECOND-
WE LARA EIGHT APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
HEALTH CORPS MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO VARIOUS MISSIONS
SINCE THE PANDEMIC HAS BEGUN.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE SITES SUCH
AS SLEEP TRAIN ARENA SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES ELDER CARE
FACILITIES LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES. OKAY SO IN THE SUM
OF MONEY THE THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION- WHAT KIND AND WHAT
DOES THAT ACTUALLY COVERS A
WEEK CALL THAT DEPLOYMENT- BUT
IS THAT ALSO FOR EXAMPLE PAY
FOR THEM OR OTHER EXPENSES I
MEAN I THINK IT COMES OUT TO
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PER PERSON SO. DOES THAT IS
SALARIES AND BENEFITS OKAY IT'S
ALWAYS BENEFITS OKAY THANK YOU-
OKAY. QUESTION NUMBER THREE IS
A BRIEF ACCOUNTING OF THE
ALLOCATIONS OF FEDERAL FUNDING
TO MS- FOR PANDEMIC RELATED
EXPENDITURES IN THE TWO FISCAL
YEARS NOTED FROM FEMA I'M MS
OUR HAS RECEIVED MOST OF OUR
COVERT RESPONSE FUNDING VIA THE
JURY- AND S. B. EIGHTY NINE WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY FEMA
FUNDING DIRECTLY FOR RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES HOWEVER WE HAVE
STARTED THE FEMA REIMBURSEMENT
PROCESS AND WORKING WITH- YES
TO COMPLETE THE APPLICATIONS
THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR US TO
RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT FOR THOSE
ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD BE
COVERED BY FEMA. WELL SO- I
UNDERSTAND THE UNCERTAINTY IN
TERMS OF HOW MUCH MONEY WILL BE
REIMBURSED BY FEMA- AND MAYBE
IT'S MORE A QUESTION FOR
FINANCE THAN FOR YOU- SO IF WE
DO GET REIMBURSEMENTS FROM. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR SOME OF
THESE EXPENSES THAT WE
RECOUNTED FOR- HOW THIS IS THAT
FUND IS THAT MONEY COME BACK
TO- FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO READ DISPERSE
ARE. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT- THAT IT JUST DOESN'T GO
INTO A POT THAT SOMEONE ELSE
DISPENSES WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT SO I REALIZE YOU KNOW
WE SPENT THIS MONEY WE MAY OR
MAY NOT GET BACK. CERTAIN
AMOUNTS FROM FEMA- AND
FREESHEET THE REPORT BUT I JUST
WANT CLARITY ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE WHEN WE DO GET THE
REIMBURSEMENT WHENEVER THAT MAY
BE THAT- WE HAVE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT HEALTH OF ON. HOW
THAT FUNDING BECAUSE THAT
GRAYSON THAT RELEASES NEW
FUNDING THAT- WE HAVE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER HOW
THAT FUNDING WILL BE REGIS BE
DISPERSED. REFINANCE BY
HARDWARE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
WHEN WE RECEIVE THAT A FEMALE
IN THE FORMER REIMBURSEMENTS-
THE SHIP WILL GO WITH YOU TO
THE STATE- GENERAL FUND. OKAY
SO WE'LL GO INTO THE- GENERAL
FUND AND THEN WE WILL THROUGH
ARE. YOU THE BUDGET PROCESS
OTHER PROCESSES THEN DECIDE HOW
THOSE FUNDS WOULD BE USED THANK
YOU. TWENTY CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR. OKAY NEXT.
HELLO QUESTION NUMBER FOUR
PLEASE PROVIDE A BRIEF
ACCOUNTING OF ALLOCATIONS OF
FEDERAL FUNDING DAMS ARE FOR
PANDEMIC RELATED EXPENDITURES
IN THE TWO FISCAL YEARS FROM
THE CORONAVIRUS RELIEF UNDER
OTHER DIRECT FEDERAL FUNDING-
MS IS NOT AGAIN RECEIVE NO
DIRECTION AT ALL FUNDING FOR
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES. BUT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SINCE
DECEMBER AND WE HAVE PROVIDED
THEM APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND
THEN A LATER EXPENSES WHICH
ARE. A WHICH WILL BE REIMBURSED
THROUGH THE CORONA VIRUS RELIEF
FUND DIRECTLY BACK TO THE
STATE- WE ARE AND ACT SUPPLYING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FOR THE
REMAINING EXPENDITURES FOR THE
VENTILATOR PURCHASES AND UPKEEP
AND MAINTENANCE. THAT WILL BE
PROVIDING BY THE START OF MARCH
TO FINANCE SO THEY CAN ALSO
INCLUDE THOSE PART OF THE
CORONA VIRUS RELIEF FUND. THANK
AND THEN THERE'S THAT THAT TAKE
CARE OF A BAD NUMBER FIVE AS
WELL. YEAH WELL IS MY ANSWER IS
THE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING
TO BE RECEIVED DURING TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO WILL BE
DEPENDENT UPON THE LEVEL OF
EMERGENCY RESPONSE STATEWIDE
EFFORTS OF THE DEPARTMENT WILL
BE INVOLVED WITH- IS KIND OF
DIFFICULT RIGHT NOW. GETTING ON
THE WAY THIS PANDEMIC IS GOING.
TO DETERMINE EXACTLY WHAT
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT WILL
NEED TO COVER WHICH RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES IN THE UP COMING
FISCAL YEAR. OKAY OF BEFORE WE
MOVE ON ANY FINAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DR. AFFECT THANK YOU-
SO JUST TO CLARIFY YOU SAID YOU
DO YOU- IN TERMS OF SO WE JUST
THE HEALTHCARE GOVERNMENT JUST
PASSED THE STIMULUS PACKAGE-
SIGNED BY- THE PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT'S AT THE END OF THE
YEAR. WE MAY HAVE ANOTHER ONE
THAT'S WORKING THROUGH
CONGRESS- WHAT'S THE
NOTIFICATION PROCESS BY WHICH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THIS MAY
BE A QUESTION FOR FINANCE MORE
SO- TO THE LEGISLATURE AS TO
WIN IN NEW FUNDS MAY BE
ANTICIPATED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AS WE TRY TO MAKE
OUR BUDGET DECISIONS WE WILL I
THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE WHOLE PICTURE SO YOU KNOW
WE'RE FOLLOWING BUDGET STATE
FUNDS WE WOULD ALSO NEED TO
KNOW HOW MUCH FEDERAL FUNDING
IS COMING TO WEAR TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE SUPPORT.
ACROSS YOU KNOW FOR THE ENTIRE
YOUR RESPONSE OR SERVICE AND-
APOLOGIZE EMS YOU'RE THE FIRST
ONE UP ON THE AGENDA SO THIS IS
SOMETHING ON FRIDAY ASKING OVER
AND OVER AGAIN FOR OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL- BUT- I
JUST WANT TO GET CLARITY AS FAR
AS- HOW THIS NEW FEDERAL
FUNDING SOME MAY SHOW UP AND
VARIOUS- PACKAGES WAS THE LAST
TO MILES'S ARE JUST ANOTHER
PACKAGE GOING THROUGH. HOW'S
THE LEGISLATURE NOTIFIED IF
THERE ARE THINGS WE'VE
ALLOCATED FUNDING FOR WE'RE
BUDGETING FUNDING FOR THAT
THERE'S NOW FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MONEY THAT'S COMING IN FOR THE
SAME THING OR SOMETHING VERY
SIMILAR SO THAT WE CAN REVISIT
AND LOOK AT WHETHER DEBT TOTAL
ALLOCATION. AND THE ALLOCATION
STATE FUNDING STILL MAKES SENSE
IN PROPORTION TO THE OTHER.
DEMANDS THAT WE HAVE CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT PLEASE. GOOD FOR.
I CANNOT AND I'M GONNA HAVE TO
DO TO MY- TO FIND OUT THAT THIS
IS A QUESTION OF FINANCE THANK
YOU HI. THIS IS IT I PLEDGE AS
YOU YOU'RE OR THE FIRST AGENCY
JOB SO IT'S ONE THAT IS HAS
BEEN OF THE QUESTIONS NINETY
AND ASK QUESTIONS OF FINANCE
QUESTION. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THEN YOU'LL BE PREPARED.
EVERY TIME TO ADDRESSES AS IT
COMES UP I DON'T WANT TO BE.
FIRE ARE. WE HAVE A UNIT THAT
IS COORDINATING THE OVERALL-
ALLOCATION OF THE TRAIL OF
FINDING A AND- HOWEVER I DO
HAVE TO LIKE GET BACK TO YOU AS
FAR AS THE HOW THE LEGISLATURE
IS BEING NOTIFIED AND- ARE
THERE COURTNEY. OF DETECTS OKAY
SO I. GAVE YOU CAN I'M I'M SURE
THAT SOMETHING ARE BUDGET TEAR
CENTER SKINNER I'M SURE OF THE
VERY INTERESTED IN AS WELL BUT-
I THINK CLARITY AND ON THAT
BECAUSE A SAID. THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT WE HAVE A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS TRYING TO BE MORE
SPONSORED AND HELP US. AND OUR
RESPONSE THIS IS AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S A WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
OUR BUDGETING PROCESS. THAT WE
GET NOTIFICATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AS THESE
DIFFERENT- YOUKNOW FEDERAL
PACKAGES ARE PASSED AND WE GET
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT. THAT WE
HAVE TIMELY NOTIFICATION OF
WHAT WE EXPECT TO GET TO
VARIOUS OF OUR OWN RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES SO WE CAN MAKE. THE
OPTIMAL USE. OF OUR STATE
RESOURCES I'M SURE
DEMONSTRATION SHARES THETHING.
SAME THING BUT IT WITHOUT THAT
INFORMATION IT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR US. AS A CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT TO MAKE.
APPROPRIATE DECISIONS O. I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE VERY TIMELY
NOTIFICATION OF ANTICIPATED
FUNDS- THAT MAY COME AS A
RESULT OF FEDERAL ACTIONS. SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE TIMELY
DECISIONS ABOUT STATE
RESOURCES. AND IF YOU CAN GET
BACK TO US ON THAT- I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT ARE YOU CAN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHEN EVERY DOLLAR ACCOUNT OR
ANYTHING ELSE FROM THE PARDON
OF A FINANCE OR THE L. A. O.
ACTUALLY PERHAPS L. A- WE WANT
TO COMMENT ON HOW THEY THINK IT
SHOULD BE DONE. OR THEY CAN GET
BACK TO US IF IT'S UP TO ME. TO
LIVE AN ANSWER FOR RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR DAN
THIS IS SONYA PADDOCK FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND- YOU KNOW TRACKING TRACKING
INCOMING FEDERAL FUNDS TRACKING
OUTGOING STATE EXPENDITURES.
AND GETTING A BETTER GRASP ON
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION- IS
REQUESTING IN USING FUNDS IS
SOMETHING THAT OUR OFFICE IS
KEENLY INTERESTED IN AND- BUT
YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY HAVE
CONCERNS JUST ABOUT- YOU KNOW
WANTING TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
A TRANSPARENT PROCESS SO THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS- SO YES THIS
IS SOMETHING OUR OFFICE IS
INTERESTED IN AND WERE WERE
HAPPY TO- YOU KNOW FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU. WITH YOU IT AT ANY
POINT AND I'M SURE AS YOU SAID
THIS ISSUE OF ISSUE WILL COME
UP- AGAIN IT AT HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE THROUGHOUT THE
WINTER AND SPRING. THANK YOU
CHRIS THANK YOU FOR THE FOLLOW
UP THURMOND IS. OKAY SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU. BUT
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ELIZABETH PLANTS BURKE
THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. OUR STUDENTS IS
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO SAFE
QUALITY HEALTHCARE ENVIRONMENTS
BY FOCUSING ON THREE PRIMARY
AREAS WE WORK TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE THAT IT NEEDS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE SINCE. WE WORK TO
COLLECT AND REPORT ON
THE AREAS OF HEALTH CARE
CONSTRUCTION AND FINANCE FOR
THE BUDGET PROPOSES ADDING A
NEW OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND RECASTING
OPTION HEAD AS THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. H. C. A. I.
R. H. HI TO BETTER REFLECT OUR
EXPANDED MISSION AND INCREASED
PORTFOLIO. WE WILL SUBMIT A
PROPOSAL IN THE SPRING WITH
MORE DETAIL ON THE RECASTING OF
OPTION THAT IS A DEPARTMENT AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING MORE
ABOUT THE AFFORDABILITY OFFICE
WHEN WE GET TO THAT BCP. IT
JUST HAS A THOROUGH DESCRIPTION
OF OUR MANY PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO SOME OF
OUR COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
ACTIVITIES. LIKE ALL
DEPARTMENTS OF THE HHS FAMILY
ASHRAF HAS BEEN CONTRIBUTING TO
THE STATE'S PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
WE'VE ASSISTED FEMA THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS OUR STATE
PARTNERS WITH THE DESIGN AND
APPROVAL OF OUR ALTERNATE CARE
SITES AND SEARCH SPACE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE HAVE
CREATED A CODE NINETEEN WEBSITE
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR HEALTH
FACILITIES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL AS
ASSISTING WITH THE CREATION OF
A FIFTY EIGHT. COUNTY DASHBOARD
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO TRACK
VARIOUS MEASURES REGARDING
HEALTH FACILITIES SEARCH SPACE
AND EQUIPMENT. WE WERE PLEASED
TO DISTRIBUTE A PRIVATE GRANTED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THE STAFF
WORKING IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES THE SKILLED NURSING
HERO AWARDS WHICH GRANTED FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR HERO AWARDS TO
FIFTY THOUSAND LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSES AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS ALL ON THE FRONT
LINES. DURING THE RECENT
DANGEROUS HOSPITAL SURGEONS
ASHRIDGE FIELD STAFF AND
VISITED OVER A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THREE HOSPITALS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON SEARCHSPACE
BAXIAN STORAGE AN OXYGEN
SUPPLIES. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
HELPING LICENSE THOSE VERY COLD.
RESERVES WHICH HOUSE THE PFIZER
VACCINES AND THE OUTSIDE OF OUR-NORMAL SCUTTLED- WE EVEN HAVE
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS WHO'VE
BEEN ASSISTING WITH THE PLAN
FOR SCHOOL RE OPENING. WE
CONTINUE TO EXECUTE INVESTMENTS
IN THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE TO
ADDRESS WORKFORCE SHORTAGES IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND BEYOND SO THA IS
OUR OVERVIEW I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR WE CAN
PROCEED WITH PRESENTING OUR
PCPS. LET'S PROCEED CORRECT SO
FOR ISSUE NUMBER TWO WE HAVE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR MONICA ERICKSON.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN MONICA ERICKSON ADMITTED
MINISTRY TO DEPUTY DIRECTOR
THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS A NET
ZERO ADJUSTMENT TOSH HAD
SPECIAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES THIS
REQUEST WILL PROVIDE THE
FUNDING FOR RE DIRECTED
POSITIONS IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROGRAM AND ALLOW THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DIVISION THE ONGOING RESOURCES
TO MEET THE PROGRAMMATIC AND
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS AND
TIMELINES. TRANSITION OF THIS
CALENDAR TWENTY SEVENTEEN WITH
THE CURRENT WORK FORCE AND THE
INCREASE IN TIME NEEDED FOR
VARIOUS PROCESSES ACCOUNTING
PROCESSES HAVE BEEN DELAYED. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE RESOURCES
WERE REDIRECTED WITH AN ARCH
BUT OUR FISCAL OBLIGATIONS AND
MANDATED TIMEFRAME. ASHRAE HAS
MADE PROGRESS IN MEETING ITS
PROGRAMMATIC REQUIREMENTS AND
STATUTORY MANDATES AS A RESULT
OF THESE READ DIRECTIONS.
HOWEVER THERE IS STILL MORE
WORK TO DO WE STILL HAVE
PROCESSES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
COMPLETED IN OVERTIME FOR STAFF
IS VERY HIGH THIS PROPOSAL WILL
PROVIDETHE RESOURCES NEEDED
FOR US TO ACHIEVE FISCAL
COMPLIANCE. AND NOT INCREASE
ITS OVERALL BUDGET I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ON THIS PROPOSAL. I THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT I DO HAVE A BRIEF
QUESTION- ON THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH DATA AND PLANNING FUND.
I NOTE THAT- THAT THERE'S A
REDUCTION IN THE- EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF UP TO FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND FOR THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT DIVISION-
CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO THE
REASON FOR- WELL. I THINK I
WORKFORCE ISSUES HAVING GONE
AWAY SO BUT ON THE OTHER HAND
OF COURSE MAYBE YOU CAN SPEAK
TO THE SPECIFIC WORK THAT'S
GOING TO BE REDUCED WITH THAT
REDUCTION IN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY- AND I DO KNOW
THERE'S AN INCREASE IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DIVISION SO THAT SHIFT IN.
WORKLOAD OR WHAT HE'S SPEAK
PERHAPS A LITTLE BIT TOO WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THAT CALIFORNIA
HEALTH DATA PLANNING FUND. OKAY
LET ME TAKE A LOOK AT THAT HERE.
SO BASICALLY REDUCING HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DIVISIONBY TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND INCREASING THE MYSTERY
SERVICES DIVISION BY TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND WE
ARE STILL UP IF YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT THE PROPOSAL THERE ARE
CERTAIN FUNDS THAT GO THERE ARE
INCREASING AND DECREASING-
RIGHT. RIGHT SO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS WE ARE TAKING
POSITIONS THAT WERE FUNDED BY
THE- DATA FUND AND THOSE GET
MOVED OVER INTO THE PROGRAM
THIRTY EIGHT SIXTY ONCE THOSE
POSITIONS GET MOVED INTO THIRTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN THERE'S AN
ALLOCATION PROCESS THAT OCCURS.
OKAY SO JUST TO CLARIFY IT'S
JUST MONEY MOVING OUR POSITIONS
ALSO MOVING. THIS IS MONEY
MOVING OKAY SO ANOTHER WORDS
ESSENTIALLY THE POSITIONS ARE
STILL THE SAME JUST FUNDING
FROM A DIFFERENT SOURCE. THAT
IS CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU
THAT'S THE CLARIFICATION I
WANTED OKAY I WASN'T SURE OF
THOSE PEOPLE OF POSITIONS WERE
MOVING THEN THERE'S A RE
ORIENTATION IN TERMS OF. EFFORT
THAT I WANT TO CLARIFY BUT IF
THAT'S MAINLY IT'S WHERE THE
MONEY'S COMING FROM BUT THE
POSITIONS ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
STABLE THAN THAT. THAT'S FINE
OKAY THANK YOU DR GRANT I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THERE ARE
THERE ARE NO FUNDS BEING TAKEN
AWAY FROM ANY OF OUR
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS- OR
RESIDENCY SUPPORT PROGRAMS.
OKAY THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT. ALL RIGHT- WERE THERE ANY
OTHER SORRY I JUST HAVE TO LOOK
OF- SIR MELINDA'S CENTER I'M
NOT ACTUALLY AT THE COMPUTER
DID YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THEN I THINK- IF THERE
WEREN'T ANY OTHER QUESTIONS-
THEN LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN AND THAT WILL BE PRESENTED
BY DEPUTY DIRECTOR MIKE VALLEY.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MIKE VALLEY DEBBIE
DIRECTORS FOR INFORMATION
SERVICES AT THE DEPARTMENT-
WITH ISSUE NUMBER THREE OSCAR
REQUEST FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY TO THE
GENERAL FUND FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- AND FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN REVERSE.
ALREADY IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- THIS
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY WILL
ENABLE ASHRIDGE EIGHT YEARS
FEDERAL MEDICAID FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE HEALTHCARE PAYMENT
STATUS SYSTEM. THE END OF THE
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT THE LIFE
CYCLE PROCESS. MOSEL INFORMANTS
THAT PAYMENT DATA SYSTEMS
STATUTE WHICH REQUIRES ASHRIDGE
PURSUED THE MAXIMUM POSSIBLE
FEDERAL FINANCIAL FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION. IN THE MEDICAID
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT SYSTEM.
REIMBURSE MINORITIES REQUIRED
PROSTITUTES SPEND THE FEDERAL
FUNDING RECEIVED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FROM THE U. S. CENTERS
FOR MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
SERVICES. I'MHAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ON ON THIS
PROPOSAL. THE TRACK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ADDED TODAY HAVE A
QUESTION IN TERMS OF- WHAT'S
THE START TREATY THE FUNDING
PART WHICH IS THIS PROPOSAL BUT
CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO THE
TIMELINE ON. THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS
DATA- PROGRAMMER DATABASE- WENT
WHEN WHERE WE ON THAT AND WHEN
WE EXPECT TO HAVE A FULLY UP
AND RUNNING- ALL PAYER CLAIMS
DATABASE. SURE HAPPY TO HAVE A
TO DO THAT CENTER BEN AND
RESHAPE YOUR YOUR SUPPORT
OXFORD IS ON TRACKING IN MAKING
PROGRESS TO INTENTIONALLY
COMPLETE THE DATABASE BY JULY
ONE. TWENTY TWENTY THREE WE'VE
MADE SOME IMPORTANT JOB PORTENT
PROGRESS- RECENTLY WITH BEING
TO MEETINGS UPDATE IT NEEDS
STAKEHOLDER FIZER COMMITTEE-
AND ALSO COMPLETED THE FIRST
TWO STAGES OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY IDEA ALL.
LIFE CYCLE- WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES REQUIRE A
MEDIC CAL DEEPER SERVICE
MANAGED CARE DATA- AND- WERE
ALSO WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
TO DEVELOP THE REGULATIONS
WHICH MUST BE IN PLACE BY THE
END OF DECEMBER. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- THAT WILL OVERSEE THE
COLLECTION OF COMMERCIAL I DATA
FROM HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS
OKAY SO THAT'S EXCELLENT SO
WE'RE TALKING LIKE JULY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND I NEED TO
DEVELOPING THE VARIOUS PIECES-
JUST ONE OTHER QUESTION IS THAT
DO YOU ANTICIPATE OBVIOUSLY
DIAZ- YOU HAVE TO. I GUESS
ANONYMIZE THE DATA DE
IDENTIFIED THE DATA IS AS ANY.
IN IT IS EARLY WAYS IN WHICH
PART RELEASED PORTIONS OF THE
DATA WITH THE FOR PROPRIA
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IN PLACE-
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC OR TO RESEARCHERS- FOR
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS BEYOND-
THE STATE. MAYBE MORE MEDIA
STAKEHOLDERS. YEAH ABSOLUTE AND
THAT AGAIN A WHAT THAT YOU- FOR
THAT- THERE'S SEVERAL
COMPONENTS TO- DATA ACCESS AND
RELEASE THAT WILL BE PART OF
THE HEALTHCARE PAYMENTS DATA
PROGRAM ALL OF WHICH CAN BE
INFORMED BY MY STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGH OUR- OUR ADVISORY
COMMITTEE- WERE WERE PLANNING
TO. BEGIN PRODUCING A PUBLIC
REPORTS OF AGGREGATE-
INFORMATION AS YOU DESCRIBED.
AFTER THE DATABASE IS
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE TO HELP
INFORM OUR POLICY MAKERS- AND
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
HEALTHCARE. SYSTEM DELIVERY
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. WE WILL
ALSO BE DEVELOPING- PROCESS
SEEDS AND PROCEDURES FOR
PRIVILEGED ACCESS TO. NON
PUBLIC DATA SUCH AS
RESEARCHERS- WHILE PROTECTING
CONSUMER PRIVACY. PROVIDING
PUBLIC BENEFIT FOR CALIFORNIANS
I THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE UPDATE. OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH GOING TO
NUMBER FOR TWENTY. HEY WE HAVE
CHIEF COUNSEL RYAN BUT ON THIS
ITEM. IT IS NUMBER FOUR IN
ADDITION TO DEFEND OUR SPAS
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COST
TRANSPARENCY PROGRAMS ONGOING
SINCE DECEMBER OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN WAS
ORIGINALLY NAMED AS IT LEAD
DEFENDANT QUALIFY FOR DAVID
DIRECTOR BOUGHT FIVE TIMES
UNTIL RECENTLY NEARLY ALL
ATTORNEYS FEES LITIGATION
EXPENSES WERE PAID FROM THE
GENERAL FUND WITH THE DISMISSAL
OF THE GOVERNOR FROM CASE AND
REVIEWED EXPENSES WHEN ARMY
JUSTICE. COSTS OF LITIGATION
RECENTLY SHIFTED TO OUR- TO
PROVIDE FEES LITIGATION
EXPENSES THEPRESENT BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
INCREASE TRANSFER FROM MANAGED
CARE FUND AN INSURANCE FUND.
SHOULD BE PRESENT SOURCE ABBAS
PODS DRUG COST TRANSPARENCY
PROGRAM IS REQUIRED BY STATUTE.
WITHOUT HAVING TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. BUT IN JUST THE
PAUSE FOR SECOND CENTER MELINDA
STILL ON BOARD WE LOSE YOU
OKAY. CLOSE WE HOPE YOU'RE BACK
THEN YOU'RE OKAY. HI ISSUE
NUMBER. FIVE THANK YOU DOCTOR
SPEND EGGMAN- SO I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY AS THE
GOVERNOR HIGHLIGHTED IN THIS
BUDGET RELEASE YET MINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING TO ESTABLISH AN
OFFICE AND HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WHILE LAST YEAR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE HOUSE THE
OFFICE WITHIN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY THIS YEAR
PROPOSES TO HOUSE IT WITHIN
OPTION AS- WELL CALIFORNIA HAS
HAD GREAT SUCCESS IN EXPANDING
COVERAGE THE COST OF HEALTH
CARE IS A SIGNIFICANT STRAIN ON
INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIANS.
EMPLOYERS AND THE STATE. WE
NEED FULL ACCESS TO HEALTH
SERVICES IS SIMPLY NOT.
POSSIBLE WITHOUT AFFORDABILITY
SO BUILDING ASHRIDGE WORK
DEVELOPING THAT EACH TV THAT
THE HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS
DATABASE THAT WAS JUST
DISCUSSED THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY WILL COLLECT
DATA. ON THE TOTAL COST OF CARE
IN THE STATE AND SET COST
TARGETS FOR THE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY. THE OFFICE ENFORCE
COMPLIANCE OF THOSE TARGETS
THROUGH PROGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT
AND FILLING GAPS IN MARKET
ANALYSES OF MERGERS AND
ACQUISITIONS IT MAY ADVERSELY
IMPACTS YEAH PARDON THE IMPACT
MARKET COMPETITION. PRICES
QUALITY ACCESS AND THE TOTAL
COST OF CARE. NOTE THAT THE
MARKET ANALYSES WOULD FOCUS ON
THOSE HEALTHCARE TRANSACTIONS
THAT DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
PROCESS SO THE AGENDA RIGHTLY
NOTES THAT DMH CCDI AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE OVERSIGHT
OF MANY TRANSACTIONS AND WE
WHICH WE WOULD FILL IN THE GAPS
WHERE THERE'S NOT CURRENTLY
OVERSIGHT. WELL THE FOR ARCHING
GOAL IS TO LOWER COSTS THE
OFFICE WANTS TO ENSURE THAT
THAT IS NOT DONE AT THE EXPENSE
OF QUALITY. EQUITY OR WORK
FORCE ACCORDINGLY THE OFFICE
WILL PROMOTE HEALTH CARE WORK
FOR STABILITY AND TRAINING
THESE. REPORT QUALITY
PERFORMANCE AND EQUITY METRICS
ON THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
ADVANCE PAYMENT MODELS THAT
REWARD HIGH QUALITY COST
EFFICIENT CARE AND PROMOTE
INVESTMENTS IN PRIMARY CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT WILL BE CRITICAL TO
THE SUCCESS OF THE OFFENSE WE
DO HOPE TO RELEASE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE VERY SHORTLY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING INPUT FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS. BUT THERE ARE
SOME SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE OFFICE THAT I'LL GO AHEAD
AND ADDRESS UNLESS YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. YOUR
INITIAL TWELVE WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND DRESS THE CURRENT AND I DO
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
OF COURSE. IN TERMS OF HOW THE
OFFICE WOULD SET COST TARGETS-
WE WOULD COLLECT DATA- AND SET
AN OVERALL HEALTH CARE COSTS
TARGET GROWTH FOR PER CAPITA
SPENDING IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THEN HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
SET SECTOR AND REGION SPECIFIC
TARGETS. SO THE TARGETS WOULD
BE BASED ON- A PARTICULAR OR A
COMBINATION OF ECONOMIC
INDICATORS SUCH AS GROSS STATE
PRODUCT FOR THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX THE OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE IMPLEMENTED A SIMILAR COST
GROWTH TARGET HAS HAVE TO HAVE
TAKEN DIFFERENT CHOICES- OR
SOMETIMES HAVE GONE ABOVE OR
BELOW. A GIVEN ECONOMIC
INDICATOR. THE SENATE OF
DIFFERENT TARGETS WILL BE BY
HISTORICAL COST DATA AND OTHER
RELEVANT DATA WITH
CONSIDERATION AGAIN FOR A FOR
ACCESS QUALITY EQUITY AND WORK
FOR STABILITY. THE METHODOLOGY
AND PROCESS FOR REVIEWING AND
UPDATING THE COST GROWTH
TARGETS WILL BE INFORMED BY
STAKEHOLDERS AND EXPORT EXPERTS
THE REVISED REPORT. SO WE
WAITED TO BE OFFICE WILL BEGIN
SETTING THE BENCHMARK TARGET IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR CALENDAR
YEAR TWENTY THREE. AND THEN
BEGIN COLLECTING TOTAL
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURE DATA
FROM PAYERS AND WE WOULD HAVE
THEM BREAK IT DOWN BY SERVICE
CATEGORY SUCH AS HOSPITAL CARE
INPATIENT OUTPATIENT PHYSICIAN
SERVICES AND PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
THE COST TARGETS MAY BE
ADJUSTED FOR INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
CARE ENTITIES ONE WARRANTED TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE ENTITIES
BASELINE COSTS IN COMPARISON TO
OTHER HEALTHCARE ENTITIES THAT
OUR REGION OR HEALTH CARE
SECTORS. THE NEXT QUESTION ASKS
HOW THE COMPLIANCE AND PENALTY
PROCESSES WOULD BE ENFORCED
SPECIFICALLY AT THE PROVIDER
LEVEL- SO IN COMBINATION WITH
THE DATA REPORTED BY PAYERS THE
OFFICE WOULD ALSO BE GETTING
AUDITED FINANCIAL REPORTS FROM
PROVIDERS TO DETERMINE HOW
PROVIDERS ARE PERFORMING
AGAINST THAT COST TARGET. TO
THE EXTENT OF PROVIDER EXCEEDED
THE COST TARGET ENFORCEMENT
WOULD BE VERY MUCH PROGRESSIVE
SO IT WOULD BEGIN WITH
ASSISTANCE TO BRING THE
PROVIDER INTO COMPLIANCE-
LOOKING AT THE DATA. MAKING
SURE IT'S ALL CORRECT HAVING
THE PROVIDER SUBMIT A CORRECTED
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS- AND IF
THAT DOES NOT RESOLVE THE
ISSUES THEN. THERE IS THE
ABILITY TO ASSESS PENALTIES. IN
TERMS OF WHAT DATA WOULD BE.
USED TO DETERMINE COMPLIANCE
AND WHETHER THERE WOULD BE AN
APPEALS PROCESS THE OFFICE
WOULD DETERMINE OMPLIANCE
USING DATA COLLECTED BY THE
OFFICE- AGAIN. A LARGELY FROM
THAT FROM THE HEALTH CARE
ENTITY ITSELF. AND THEN THROUGH
THE PROGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS THE HEALTH CARE ENTITY
WOULD HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
REVIEW AND SEE CORRECTION- WITH
THE OFFICE. THERE CERTAINLY
WOULD BE AN APPEALS PROCESS SO
WE WOULD WE WOULD ASSESS THE
PENALTY AND THEN THERE WOULD BE
FORMAL DUE PROCESS
OPPORTUNITIES TO CHALLENGE AND
NON COMPLIANCE DETERMINATION
INCLUDING ADMINISTRATORS. AND
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS AND
RIGHTS FOR THE- SO THOSE ARE
THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE IN THE
AGENDA I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK
YOU- IT APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION I KNOW THAT THIS
WAS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- AT LEAST BECAUSE IT
WAS AN OFFICE OF AFFORDABILITY
I THINK THERE WASN'T AS MUCH
DETAIL- AND THE LAST. PROPOSAL
AND THEN OF COURSE CODE HERE. I
GUESS THE QUESTION I HAVE WELL
I HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS AND-
AND HOPE THAT WE CAN GET
CLARITY ON THIS IS- THE BUDGET
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD AND I
KNOW THAT- MY COMPATRIOT-
ASSEMBLY CHAIRS THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE IS ALSO
WORKING ON SOME OF LEGISLATION
AS WELL SO. I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THESE IN THE POLICY
CONTACTS AS WELL AS THE BUDGET
CONTEXT. BUT I'LL I WOULD MAKE
NOTES THAT- YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE STATUS IN CART COST TARGETS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. BUT AS I
JUST ASKED HER COLLEAGUES- FOR
THE ALL PAYER CLAIMS DATABASE
WE DON'T EXPECT THAT TO GET UP
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE. SO
THERE SEEMS TO BE A DISCONNECT
THERE AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
SAID THAT YOU GUYS COLLECTED
DATA FROM THE HEALTH CARE
ENTITIES THEMSELVES. BUT IT S.
FIND IT. INTERESTS ME I GUESS
I'LL FIND IT CHALLENGING TO
THINK THAT WE WERE ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE DATA ON THE OVERALL
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THAT NOW
THERE STILL BE SOME LIMITATIONS
ON ALL PAYER CLAIMS DATABASE.
THE LARGER PICTURE UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON BUILDING THIS
DATABASE OVER TIME AND THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST YEAR WE'RE
STARTING ON THAT SO IT DOES
TAKE TIME AND EFFORT TO DO
THAT. BUT YET WE'RE GONNA BE
SETTING COST TARGETS A YEAR
BEFORE WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATA.
TO DECIDE WHETHER THIS COST
TARGETS MAKES SENSE AND HOW
THEY FIT IN THE OVERALL
PICTURE. SO AND THEN WE'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA FORCE PEOPLE
BEFORE EVEN HAVE THE OVERALL
PICTURE- SO I WOULD ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT IN THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL- THAT- ACTUALLY WELL
AS THE SECOND LARGEST SECTION
YOU KNOW PART OF THE BUDGET OF
THE STAFFING REQUEST IS
ACTUALLY THE INVESTIGATION
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH I GUESS THE
FOLLOWS AFTER THE I. T.
BRANCHES WITH THE L. FOURTEEN
POSITIONS FOLLOWED BY FORTY
FOUR POSITIONS. THE FOLLOWING
FIVE EIGHT FIFTY TWO POSITIONS.
SO I GUESS CONCERN IS THAT AND
I. YOUR A PRESS- BUT MY CONCERN
IS THAT- WERE. GETTING A LITTLE
AHEAD OF OURSELVES NOT FOR OF
TERMS AFFORDABILITY IF NOT
OPPOSED TO THE IDEA IN OFFICE
AFFORDABILITY. BUT THAT OUR
APPROACH IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SET COST TARGETS IN THE ABSENCE
OF- GOOD DATA. AND I WILL TELL
YOU TO SOMEONE WHO STUDY
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT YOU KNOW
WHAT WE TRY TO DO IS WE TRY TO
MOVE FROM WHAT WE CALL EVIDENCE
BASED MEDICINE WHICH IS PEOPLE
LIKE- WE GOT. YOU KNOW EXPERTS
AND FAMOUS PEOPLE OF
PROCLAIMING WHAT SHOULD BE.
VERSUS EVIDENCE BASED MEDICINE
WHICH IS ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
THE DATA. SO I GUESS MY CONCERN
IS WE ACTUALLY COST TARGETS
BASED ON EVIDENCE. PEOPLE WHO.
ARE SELF PROCLAIMED EXPERTS AND
YEAH PRAYER DO HAVE ACTUALLY
SOME EXPERTISE. BUT IN THE
ABSENCE OF DATA IT'S HARD TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT THEY'RE
MAKING THEIR JUDGMENTS BASED ON
AND THEN ACTUALLY HAVING
PENALTIES ON PEOPLE FOR THAT.
SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO THIS
DISCONNECT. THIS LARGER DATA
AND HELL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND
ESTABLISHING COSTS WE'RE SORRY
YOUR CONFERENCES ENDING NOW
PLEASE HANG UP. THERE YOU GO. A
YES ANSWER. SO WE'LL TRY TO
PROCEED UNLESS WERE WERE KICKED
OUT YES. YEAH OKAY- RESEARCH
FOR ONE OF THIS MANUAL HOLDEN
RECESSED.
MANY HEARING BACK TO
ORDER HELLO GLITCH WE THINK BUT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD. ALL
RIGHT. THE ANSWER TO MY
QUESTION DOCTOR GEORGE AND
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR THE
ANSWER DOCTOR PENSION PRESSURES
YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO SEE YEAH
ARE WE GOING TO ENFORCE THINGS
BEFORE WE HAVE THE DATA WE'RE
GONNA WE ARE NOT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE QUESTION
DOCTOR PAN WE LOVE TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF DATA THAT THE ALL ARE
ALL PLAYERS CLAIMS DATABASE ARE
EACH P. PROGRAM WILL BE
COLLECTING AND THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY. SO
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WILL BE
COLLECTING AGGREGATE COST DATA
FROM PAYERS SO THAT WILL
INCLUDE- ALL OF THE COSTS IN
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM SO- NOT.
CLAIMS PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS-
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS PROFITS
COST SHARING PAID TO CONSUMERS
THAT AGGREGATE DATA THAT'S
COMING IN TO THE- OFFICE HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY STARTING IN
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE- ARE ALL
PAYS PAIRS CLAIMS DATABASE ARE
HEALTHCARE OUR HEALTH CARE-
PAYMENTS DATABASES YOU KNOW IS
VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON CLAIMS
DATA SO IT DOESN'T GO TO THE
TOTAL COST OF CARE PER SE THE
DATA COLLECTED BY THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY- IS
TRYING TO GET TO THE TOTAL COST
OF CARE- WE HOPE TO HAVE MORE
COMPLETE. SELF AND SHORT- DATA
AT THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WHERE IS THE H.
P. D. WE'RE HAVE TO SEE HOW
MUCH THE SELF INSURED PLANS
CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE- IT'LL BE
VOLUNTARY. SO H. P. D. WILL BE.
USED AS- CALL STRIVE THAT WERE.
BUILDING ON THAT DAY. BUT THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE. WILL
HAVE TO COLLECT- ITS OWN
AGGREGATE DATA TO DETERMINE
COST OF CARE SO WE'LL BE DOING
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
SETTING- ACROSS TARGETS. AND
HEN HAVING THAT THE SECTOR
BASED ON THE LINE SO IT IS A
VERY PROGRESSIVE PROCESS OKAY
SO- AND AGAIN IN. THE PERHAPS
SOME OF THIS WEEKEND- TAKE A
LITTLE- OFFLINE LATER BUT I
JUST. SO IF YEAH I GET IT THAT
THE ITS CLAIMS DATA YOU'RE
GETTING AND THE ALL PAYER
CLAIMS DATABASE BUT THE DATA
YOUGET FROM ANY HEALTH PLAN IS
ALSO CLAIMS DATA SO YOU- SO THE
DATA YOUR PLAN TO GET FOR YOU
YEAH YOU KNOW YOU MADE
REFERENCE TO HEALTH CARE
ENTITIES IS THIS NOW GOING TO
BE A REQUIREMENT THAT EVERY
PROVIDER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE TO PROVIDED
PROVIDE AUDITED FINANCIAL
REPORTS TO THIS ENTITY I MEAN
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A HUGE BURDEN.
AND ACTUALLY HUGE TASK EVEN
PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH STAFF YOU
HAVE YOUR EVEN FOR THE AYE EVEN
FOR THE HUNDRED THREE I. T.
PEOPLE YOU EVENTUALLY BE
BUDGING FOR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. THE HANDLED EVERYONE'S
HAVING TO SEND AUDITED
FINANCIAL DATA TO THIS OFFICE.
SO CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT SOURCE
OF SOURCES OF DATA. S. IT'S NOT
CLAIMS DATA THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE COLLECTING AND HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO COLLECTED I MEAN
ARE YOU GONNA MANDATE THAT
PEOPLE PROVIDE AUDITED
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS FOR EVERY
PRACTICE IN THE- STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AGAIN DR
PENSO YES MOVING FORWARD IN
ORDER TO- MEASURE WHETHER A
GIVEN TO HEALTH ENTITY IS
MEETING THE COST TARGET WE
WOULD EVENTUALLY HAVE TO GET
AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS. A
LITTLE CLINIC PRACTICE. NOW AS
WELL SO WE WILL BE DEVELOPING
REGULATIONS DEFINING-
HEALTHCARE ENTITIES AND
EXCLUDED HEALTH CARE ENTITIES
AND CERTAINLY WE WILL NOT BE.
IT IS NOT ENVISIONED THAT THE
OFFICE WILL GO DOWN TO TWO YOU
KNOW AND I'M A MOM AND POP
PROVIDE OKAY SO ALL RIGHT WELL
I THINK- MY CONCERN IS THAT IN
WHICH CASE YOU ALSO HAVE A
MISSING PIECE OF DATA THERE
RIGHT SO. WE GOT YOU KNOW YOU
ONLY WANT TO COLLECT THE DATA
FROM THE BIG ONES AND YOU KNOW
I'VE DONE BILLS AND I KNOW WE
WORK TOGETHER ON- I AND I AND
I'M TRYING TO YOU KNOW GET DATA
BUT I JUST. WANT TO. BE CAREFUL
ABOUT AND AGAIN I'M NOT OPPOSED
TO AN OFFICE OF AFFORDABILITY
AND I THINK THERE'S THINGS WE
NEED TO DO. I THINK WE NEED TO
BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT WHAT DEALS WE
HAVE DELIVERED ON ONE SIDE. ON
THE FLIP SIDE- KNOWN
RECOGNIZING TRYING TO MINIMIZE
DATA BURDEN. IS ALSO INCOMPLETE
DATA RIGHT SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
GAPS RIGHT SO. ARE THEY GONNA
HAVE SO YES THE LARGE ENTITIES
PROVIDE A MAJORITY OF THE
HEALTHCARE BUT NOW I'M GOING
CREEK COST TARGETS THAT ARE
BASED ON. JUST THE EXPERIENCE
OF THE LARGE IDENTITIES AND
WHAT'S GOING ON SMALLER
ENTITIES IN FACT OFTENTIMES IS
WEIRD EVEN DEALING WITH
VACCINATION DISTRIBUTION AND
OTHER THINGS ABOUT COVE IT IF
YOU GO LOOK AROUND AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WHERE I
PRACTICE. I SEE A LOT A LITTLE
MOM AND POP STUFF GOING ON
BECAUSE- THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY ARE LARGER WITH MORE
MONEY TEND TO GO TO MIDDLE
CLASS AREAS THERE'S MORE MONEY
THERE. SO AT SO I IT JUST. I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THOUGHT
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE TAKING A
LOT OF THOUGHT I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF THOUGHT. ABOUT HOW WE
GO ABOUT DOING THIS SO THAT.
AND AS WE'RE TRYING TO APPROACH
THIS IT THE ISSUE AFFORDABILITY
THAT WE DON'T MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON INCOMPLETE OR
DISTORTED DATA. ESPECIALLY IF
YOU'RE DOING COST TARGETS OF
PENALTIES AND I KNOW AND I
APPRECIATE THE STAGE THEN
YOU'RE NOT JUST HITTING PEOPLE
IN THE HAMMER WITH WITH THE
RIGHT AWAY. BUT IT CAN CAUSE-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE DISTORTIONS
AND DATA AND THEN THERE'S
CONSEQUENCES TO PEOPLE. THEN
YOU START GETTING- BEHAVIORS
THAT ARE- NOT NECESSARILY
OPTIMAL FOR CARE YOU GET
BEHAVIORS THAT ARE RESPONDING
TO THE SIGNALS THAT YOU'RE
SENDING THAT CLASS AND YOU CAN
HAVE THE FUNCTIONAL BEHAVIORS.
SO HI. YEAH IF I MADE AFTER PAN
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
QUESTION SO I THINK WE WANT TO
DRAW A DISTINCTION BETWEEN
SETTING THE TOTAL COST OF CARE.
AND THEN THE COMPLETE AND THEN
MONITORING COMPLIANCE- AT THE
SECTOR OR PROVIDER LEVEL SO IN
TERMS OF CALCULATING TOTAL COST
OF CARE THAT WILL BE DONE WITH
DATA FROM THE PAYERS NOT FROM
THE PROVIDERS. SO IN TERMS OF
ANY CONCERN ABOUT IF A GIVEN A
PROVIDER ISN'T SUBMITTING THEIR
AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS WE
WON'T BE USING THOSE AUDITED
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS TO
DETERMINE THE TOTAL COST OF
CARE AGAIN WILL BE USING
AGGREGATE DATA FROM THE PAYERS.
RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE WE NEED
TO SET A SECTOR TARGETS WE USED.
HOSPITAL OR LARGER MEDICAL
BROUGH- FINISH STATEMENTS TO
MONITOR. OF OUR WELL I'D- BY A
SECOND GET FOR THIS HEARING.
I'VE THE RESPONSE I LOOK FOR TO
FOR CONVERSE. I THINK THEM THE
DETAILS DO MATTER. AND I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW THAT TOO AND I
JUST- I THINK I WANT TO BE A
LITTLE CAUTIOUS ABOUT- HOW
WE'RE APPROACHING THIS SO THAT
WE DON'T CREATE PERVERSE
INCENTIVES I KNOW THAT I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE- YOU'RE AWARE OF
THAT AND THAT YOU DON'T WANT
THAT TO HAPPEN EITHER. BUT I
THINK WE DO NEED TO HAVE SOME
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE
YOU TALK ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU GETTING- PLAN DATA THAT'S
CLAIMS DATABASE THAT'S ALSO
THAT BACKS TO THE- PURPOSE OF
AN OFF FAIR CLAIMS DATABASE IS.
CAPTURING THOSE PLAN
REIMBURSEMENTS I MEAN THAT'S- A
THAT'S CLAIMS DATA SO YOU'RE
GETTING THAT'S CLAIMS DATA ON
THE FLIP SIDE YOU TRYING TO GET
COST ACTUAL COST DATA THEN
YOU'RE HAVING TO GET FROM THE
PROVIDERS UNLESS YOU THINK
CLAIMS REFLECT THOSE IN WHICH I
KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT YOU TOLD ME THAT.
WELL WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR
THAT SO WE DO NEED TO SORT
THESE KIND OF THINGS OUT. I
THINK EVENTUALLY WE DO WANT TO
GET THEIR FOR AFFORDABILITY AND
THERE'S SOME BROUGHT THINGS WE
CAN DO- BY LOOK FOR TO THIS
CONVERSATION AND- I THINK
THERE'S THERE ARE A LOT OF
DETAILS THAT. WE'D LIKE TO HAVE
SORTED OUT BEFORE. WE DO THIS
AND FOR EXAMPLE- JUST BECAUSE
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE THE
QUESTION IS FOR EXAMPLE. YOU
KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE DO WE NEED
INVESTIGATION ENFORCEMENT AND
WHEN I GIVEN THE TYPES OF DATA
THAT WERE AVAILABLE AVAILABLE
AT DIFFERENT POINTS IN TIME AT
WHAT POINT. YOU KNOW DO THEY-
DIG INTO WHAT ITEMS SELL AND
AGAIN THIS IS A SOMEONE WHO
ACTUALLY SUPPORTED LEGISLATION
FOR MORE OVERSIGHT OVER
CONSOLIDATION LAST YEAR
HERSELF. OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT
OPPOSED TO LOOKING. AT THESE
DRIVERS OF COST THANK YOU. CHU
COOLEY WILL A LOT MORE CONVERSE.
ON ON THIS FUND BUDGET ITEM I
AND I KNOW IT'S- WITH DARK WOOD
YESTERDAY HE'S GOT ALOT OF.
INTERESTING IDEAS AS WELL SO.
WE'LL DO A LOT OF COLLABORATION
AS WE GO FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
WE GET IT RIGHT. WE WELCOME
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
LAST ITEM- IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTED BY DEPUTY DIRECTOR
KAREN MYSELF THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON- RIGHT MY NAME IS
KAREN RIGHTS OUT AND I'M HERE
WITH TE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
FROM DIVISION I WILL ADDRESS
YOUR QUESTIONS REGARDING ISSUE
SIX. I'M FIRST QUESTIONS PLEASE
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THIS PROPOSAL. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES A THREE MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT TO
GROW AND DIVERSIFY THE PIPELINE
FOR THE GERIATRIC MEDICINE
WORKFORCE. INCREASING AND
DIVERSIFYING THE NUMBERS OF
OLDER ADULTS LIVING LONGER
LIVES REQUIRES DEVELOPING A
LARGER AND MORE DIVERSE POOL OF
HEALTH CARE WORKERS THE
EXPERIENCE IN GERIATRIC
MEDICINE AND CARE. THE
CALIFORNIA ALZHEIMER'S TASK
FORCE IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN ON
AGING. REPAIRED REPORTING
RECOMMENDED THAT CALIFORNIA
BESTING CAREER INCENTIVES FOR
THE ALZHEIMER'S HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. THE FUNDING ALLOWS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO PURSUE CAREERS IN
HEALTH FIELDS EXPAND THE
CAPACITY TO SERVE. OLDER ADULTS.
TO IMPLEMENT THE SPENDING
HOSPITAL USE EXISTING HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING PROGRAMS THAT ALREADY
PROVIDE AWARDS TO HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO SERVE
GERIATRIC POPULATION. WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS WE CAN MAKE
AWARDS MORE EASILY AND QUICKLY.
OUR PROGRAMS ALREADY FOCUS ON
EXPANDING PROVIDER DIVERSITY
AND INCREASING ACCESS TO CARE
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS. THIS
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL REQUEST
MULTI YEAR EXPENDITURE OF THEIR
OWN TO ALLOW OUR SPEND
SUFFICIENT TIME TO ADMINISTER
THE FUND- SECOND QUESTION HOW
WOULD ARCH VENTURE THESE FUNDS
SPECIFICALLY SUPPORT GERIATRIC
REMINDERS. AND WOULD THERE BE
SLOTS IN THE EXISTING WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS DEDICATED TO GERIATRIC
PROVIDERS. AS STATED PREVIOUSLY
WE WERE USING EXISTING PROGRAMS
TO IMPLEMENT THIS FUNDING. AND
WE ARE PROGRAMS THAT ALREADY
PROVIDE AWARDS TO GERIATRIC
PROVIDERS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM ALREADY CAN PROVIDE
TOWARDS THE POSITIONS THERE'S
PRACTITIONERS AND PHYSICIANS'
ASSISTANTS WITH A SPECIALTY IN
GERIATRICS AND GERONTOLOGY. THE
STEVEN M. THOMPSON PRECISION
CAR LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
AWARD PROVIDERS WHO AGREE TO
PRACTICE IN GERIATRIC CARE
SETTING. BUT PRIMARILY SERVES
ADULTS OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE FOR ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES. WE CAN ALSO USE
OUR OTHER MOMMY PAYMENT
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS FOCUS ON
NURSING ALLIED HEALTH AND
LICENSE MENTAL HEALTH. AWARD
PROVIDERS THAT SERVE OLDER
ADULTS BY MODIFYING OUR
APPLICATION TO INDICATE WHETHER
THEY ARE PROVIDING GERIATRIC
CARE. YOU ALSO GROW AND
DIVERSIFY THE GERIATRIC
HEALTHCARE PIPELINE WE HAVE THE
MANY GRANTS PROGRAM. A PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO INTRODUCE YOU AND
STUDENTS TO HEALTH CARE CAREERS
AND WE WILL MODIFY THIS PROGRAM
TO INCLUDE EXPERIENCES THE
GERIATRIC POPULATIONS IN
GERIATRIC CAREER. THE THIRD
QUESTION DOES ARE SPENDING TEN
TO ADDING NEW GERIATRIC
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS OR
CONDITIONS. THE SCHOLARSHIP OR
LOAN REPAYMENT AWARD SUPPORTED
BY THIS REQUESTED FUNDING. FOR
SOME PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
STEVEN THOMPSON LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM AWARDEES ALREADY
PROVIDERS PERIODIC
DOCUMENTATION TO SUPPORT THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING GERIATRIC
CARE NEED THEIR SERVICE
OBLIGATIONS. FOR OTHER PROGRAMS
WE WILL ADD A REQUIREMENT
AWARDEES PROVIDE PROOF OF
POPULATION SIR THE PHOTO THEIR
SERVICE OBLIGATIONS. I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. I
FOUND. I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION CERTAINLY
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
PROPOSAL- THE ONE I GUESS THE
ONE COMMENT I WOULD JUST MAKE
IS THAT- AND CERTAINLY THIS
PROPOSALS ABOUT TRYING TO BUILD
THE WORKFORCE- BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE CAN HELP
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO ENTER
TRAINING IN PARTICULAR
SPECIALTIES LIKE GERIATRICS WE
ALSO TO BE SURE THERE'S A
STRONG MARKET FOR THEM WHEN
THEY FINALLY FINISH YOUR
TRAINING INTO WORK SO. UNTIL
CERTAINLY THIS PROPOSAL ITSELF
IS EXCELLENT I DO THINK THAT WE
SHOULD ALSO EXAMINE FOR EXAMPLE
WHAT IS THE- PAY STRUCTURE AND
THE FINANCING OF SERVICES FOR
SENIORS I KNOW WE HAVE A MASTER
PLAN ON AGING THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE LOOKING AT BUT THAT GOES TO
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT MONEY WERE
PUT INTO THINGS LIKE I. HSS
INTO NURSING HOMES AND SO FORTH
LIKE ARE THEY GOING TO BE ABLE
TO HIRE GERIATRICIANS- TO
PROVIDE THE KIND OF CARE. OR OR
WEAKENED STRAINING THEIR
RESOURCES SO THAT THEY ARE NOT
AS MANY POSITIONS AVAILABLE- TO
HIRE PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING IN
THESE FIELDS SO APPRECIATE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO INCREASE THE
TRAINING AND THAT'S GREAT YOU
NEED TO BE SURE THAT WE ALSO
HAVE- IN OUR POLICIES IN OTHER
AREAS THAT WE CREE OPTING FOR
THEM TO BUILD CAREERS WANT. TO
COME OUT TRAINING IN THIS FIELD
AS WELL THANK YOU. ANY COMMENT
FROM A FINANCE OR HELLO. OKAY
WELL THAT COMPLETE THIS SECTION
AND WE THANK EVERYBODY FOR
THEIR PRESENTATION. AND NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON HOPEFULLY YOU CAN
HEAR ME OKAY CAN. THREE SO MY
NAME IS MERRY WATANABE AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE I HAVE
WITH ME ON THE LINE SERRA
REMARKS GENERAL COUNSEL WHO
WILL HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT COME UP. I'M FIRST I'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT AND DISCUSS TO
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS THAT
WILL HELP THE DEPARTMENT TO
ACHIEVE OUR MISSION WHICH IS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS HEALTHCARE
RIGHT INSURANCE STABLE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. THE
DEAL MAKES THE LICENSE REGULATE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN HEALTH PLANS THAT PROVIDE
HEALTH COVERAGE TO MORE THAN
TWENTY SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
WE REGULATE MORE THAN 96% OF
THE COMMERCIAL AND GOVERNMENT
HEALTH AND ROMAN IN THE STATE.
OUR PROPOSED FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET IS ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION AND FIVE
HUNDRED CHEN OPERATES
POSITIONS. THIS INCLUDES TO
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS MUCH AB
ONE POINT NINE MILLION AND FIVE
POSITION AND- THE DEPARTMENT
ESPECIALLY FUNDED BY ADULTS THE
SMUDGED ASSESSMENTS ON HEALTH
PLANS AND RECEIVES NO GENERAL
FUND. THE DEAL MAKES THE
PROGRAMS INCLUDE OUR HELP
CENTER WHICH IS A PROGRAM THAT
EDUCATES CONSUMERS ABOUT THEIR
HEALTHCARE RATES RESULTS.
THANKS MOST CONSUMERS NAVIGATE
AND UNDERSTAND OUR COVERAGE
INSURANCE ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. HELP
CENTER ALSO ADMINISTERS THE
DEPARTMENT'S INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL REVIEW PROGRAM TO
RESPOND TO CONSUMERS DISPUTES
WITH HEALTHCARE SERVICES ARE
DENIED OR DELAYED. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND GMAC HAS ASSISTED MORE
THAN TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
CONSUMERS CONSUMERS RESOLVE
COMPLAINTS AND PROBLEMS WITH
THEIR HEALTH PLANS SUCH AS
COVERAGE DISPUTES ACCESS TO
PROVIDERS AND BILLION WHICH-
NEXTER OPPOSITE PLAN LICENSING-
IS WHERE HEALTH PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO APPLY FOR A MEETING
A LICENSE. TO OPERATE AS A
HEALTH CLINIC CALIFORNIA THE
GMAC REVIEWS ALL ASPECTS OF THE
PLANT'S OPERATIONS INCLUDING
BENEFITS AND COVERAGE CONTRACTS
WITH DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS
PROVIDER NETWORKS YOU COMPLAIN
EVEN SYSTEMS TO ENSURE THEY
COMPLY WITH CALIFORNIA LAW.
AFTER Y. CENTER THE OFFICE OF
PLAN LICENSING CONTINUES TO
MONITOR THE HEALTH PLANS IF ANY
CHANGES THEY MAKE TO THEIR
OPERATIONS. OUR OFFICE THE PLAN
ON MONITORING IS THE OFFICE
THAT ASSESSES AND MONITORS
HEALTH PLAN CARE AND DELIVERY
SYSTEMS FOR COMPLIANCE WITH THE
KNOX KEEN ACT. THE DIGIT
DIVISION OF PLANNED SERVICE
PERFORMS ROUTINE AND NON
ROUTINE SURVEYS OF LICENSED
HEALTH PLANS TO ENSURE THEY
MEET THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER
THE LAW. AND THAT CONSUMERS GET
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
HEALTHCARE TO WHICH THEY'RE
ENTITLED. THE DIVISION OF
PROVIDER NETWORKS MONITORS
PROVIDER NETWORKS AND
ACCESSIBILITY OF SERVICES
REVIEWS YOU KNOW HEALTH PLAN
TIMELY ACCESS COMPLIANCE-REPORTS. CONDUCTS COMPLIANCE
REVIEWS OF LOCAL SERVICE TO BE
HERE NETWORK. OUR OFFICE THE
FINANCIAL REVIEW ACTIVELY
MONITORS THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF HEALTH PLANS AND
MEDICAL GROUPS THE REGULAR
REPORTING. FINANCIAL AUDITS AND
OTHER TOOLS DMH THE REVIEWS
ANNUAL MEDICAL LOSS RATIO
FILINGS TO ENSURE PLANS ARE
APPROPRIATELY INVESTING IN
RALEIGH HEALTH CARE SERVICES WE
ALSO REVIEW PER PRO PROPOSED
PREMIUM RATE INCREASES IN THE
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
MARKET TO MAKE SURE HEALTH
PLANS PROVIDING. DETAILED
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC TO
JUSTIFY THEIR RATES. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE GMAC HAS
SAVED CALIFORNIANS MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED NINETY SIX MILLION
IN HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS THROUGH
OUR RATE REVIEW PROGRAM. AND
FINALLY OUR OFFICE OF
ENFORCEMENT PROSECUTE
VIOLATIONS OF THE KNOX KEEN ACT
THE GMAC MAY USE A VARIETY OF
TOOLS TO ENFORCE THE LAW WHEN
VIOLATIONS AREN'T COVERED SUCH
AS CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN
SETTLEMENTS SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS. FINANCIAL PENALTIES
CEASE AND DESIST ORDERS A
FREEZE ON A ROMAN AND
INSTALLATION OF MONITORS ARE
CONSERVATORSHIP. THAT CONCLUDES
MY OVERVIEW OF OUR DEPARTMENT
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. I CAN MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. APPAM OF FOR
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENT. I DID
HAVE SOME- ON THE- SAYS IT
INVESTED UNDER THE OTHER TWO-
SO FIRST OF ALL- THE- IN TERMS
OF THE TIMELY ACCESS REPORTS SO
YOU KNOW WE HAD SOME PROBLEMS
SEVERAL YEARS AGO I KNOW
THERE'S A LAG- IN TERMS OF THE
QUALITY OF DATA. AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO ANALYSIS DALY SAID
SOME ERRORS REMAIN SO WHAT'S
BEING DONE TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF THE
REPORTS THAT YOU GET.FROM THE
HEALTH PLANS AND MINIMIZE THE
ERRORS FOR QUALITATIVE
SUBSEQUENT YEAR BECAUSE THAT'S
POINT OUT BACK IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AS DISK SUBCOMMITTEE
SHOCKINGLY GOT REPORTED NINETY
PERCENT. OF ALL THE INFORMATION
WE GOT WAS BAD- SO- I KNOW IT'S
MUCH BETTER NOW CAN YOU CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THE QUALITY OF DATA
THAT WAS AVAILABLE FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY REPORT AND HOW DO
YOU EXPECT THE QUALITY DATA
WILL BE. FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE REPORT- THAT IT NEXT YEAR
IN TERMS OF. THE BECAUSE THAT
DATA COLLECTIONS HAPPENING NOW.
NO NO GOOD QUESTION AND I WILL
SAY THAT TWENTY FIFTEEN
MEASUREMENT YEAR WHICH IS THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORTED SHE
MENTIONED- WE COULD NEVER
REPORT ANYTHING BECAUSE OF THE
QUALITY OF THE DATA SUPPORT- WE
HAVE SEEN SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE QUALITY OF
THE DATA THAT HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT. WE
CONTINUE TO REFINE AND WORK
WITH THE PLANS ON THE FINALLY
REQUIREMENTS IN THE TEMPLATES-
SO WE'VE COME A LONG WAY SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN- THE OTHER THING
THAT WE ARE WORKING ON AS WE
ARE- ACTUALLY INFORMAL
RULEMAKING RIGHT NOW IN OUR
TIMELY ACCESS REGULATION- AND
SO WE ARE CODIFIED IN OUR
METHODOLOGY AND OUR APPROACH TO
THE TIMELY ACCESS MEASUREMENT.
PROCESS WE ALSO HAVE A RATE OF
COMPLIANCE IN THEIR- AND WE
WILL BE ABLE TO HOLD CLIENTS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE RATE OF
COMPLIANCE- THERE'S A LOT THAT
WE WILL BE DOING IN TERMS OF
OUR REPORTING OUT I'M NOT. ONCE
NOT REGULATION- IS IT'S
APPROVED AND I BELIEVE WE JUST
CLOSE OUR SECOND COMMENT. ON
THAT SO. AGAIN WE COME A LONG
WAY ON THE DATA ERRORS AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK- THROUGH THAT.
AND JUST A REMINDER TO THAT
WHEN WE WHEN PLANS HAVE DATA
ISSUES WE ALSO DO MAKE
REFERRALS TO OUR OFFICE OF
ENFORCEMENT OKAY AND THEN I
GUESS THE FOLLOW UP AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU SAID YOUR- AND
SECOND COMMENTARY FOR YOU
REGULATIONS. FIVE MILLION THE
ROUTES. THE REPORT ITSELF- NO
THAT FOR FULL SERVICE HEALTH
PLAN- WE HAVE WAIT TIMES THE-
WILL. GOOD NEWS SUMMER 94% BAD
NEWS ONLY 52% AND FOR URGENT
APPOINTMENTS- THE WAIT TIME-
THE SURVEY PROVIDERS AGAIN GOOD
92% ALTHOUGH SOME WOULD ARGUE
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
MINIMUM STANDARD SHOULD ALWAYS
BE A HUNDRED PERCENT. AND THEN
TO A LOW OF FORTY FIVE PERCENT.
SO AND THESE ARE BECAUSE THE
MINIMUM STANDARDS. SO CAN YOU
SPEAK TO- AND I KNOW YOU'RE NO
HOPEFULLY WERE FINALIZING
REGULATIONS SOON MAYBE CAN
MATCH WHAT THE TIME LINE IS FOR
THAT. BUT SO WHAT ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES WHEN YOU HAVE.
CURRENTLY SOME PLANS REPORTING.
FOR APPROXIMATELY LESS THAN
HALF OR HALF OR STUDENTS EVEN
LESS THAN HALF A NIGHT POINT
OUT THE URGENT- THAT IN TERMS
OF NOT MEETING THE STATE TIMELY
ACCESS. STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE
IN PLACE. I REQUEST SO A COUPLE
OF THINGS- ONCE WE HAVE THE
REGULATION OF THIS FINAL WE
WILL WE WILL FINALLY HAVE A
RATE OF COMPLIANCE THAT IS A
LOT THAT WE CAN FOR IN FORCE
AGAINST- WHAT'S EMBARRASSING
RATE IN THE- IN THE
REGULATIONS. WHAT'S THE
PROPOSED RATE MINIMUM RATE OF
COMPLIANCE HE PERCENT SENATE
IT'S 0% MAYBE MAYBE MAYBE LET
ME RESPOND TO LITERATURE WHICH
SHOULD ALWAYS BE A HUNDRED
PERCENT- AGAIN THE TIME WE HAVE
TO SERVICE A POINT IN TIME
SURVEY THAT IS MEASURING THE
AVAILABILITY OF A SAMPLE OF
PROVIDERS AT THAT POINT IN
TIME- AT. ANY GIVEN POINT IN
TIME- THAT WE MAY HAVE
PROVIDERS THAT- ARE ON VACATION
AND- FOR OTHER REASONS. OUT
ALSO YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO GET
AN APPOINTMENT WITH THE EXACT
PROVIDER THAT YOU WANT AT ANY
GIVEN POINT IN TIME- THE
NETWORK NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT A TIMELY ACCESS
APPOINTMENTS AND SO WE'RE YOU
KNOW WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
ASSESS THE CAPACITY OF THE
NETWORK TO MEET. THE TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE
UP IN THE LAW- AGAIN THAT 70%
COMPLIANCE RATE WILL BE ALLOW
US TO MEASURE THE ABILITY OF
THE NETWORK TO MEET THOSE
STANDARDS- WE WILL ALSO THEN BE
ABLE TO TAKE. CORRECTIVE ACTION
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST THAT TIMELY
ACCESS COMPLIANCE STANDARDS. I
WILL ALSO JUST MENTION THE
TIMELY ACCESS IS JUST ONE
COMPONENT OF HOW WE MET
MEASURE- CONSUMER ACCESS TO
CARE- WE ALSO OBVIOUSLY HAVE
OUR HELP CENTER MONITOR
COMPLAINTS WE ALSO MONITOR. ON
THE NETWORK ADEQUACY STANDARDS
AGAINST THE GEOGRAPHIC- AND
PROVIDER RATIOS AS WELL SO IT'S
ONE COMPONENT BUT WE WILL BE
TAKING A HOLISTIC REVIEW. TO
THE- ACCESS ADEQUACY OF. OKAY
SO I A- I APPRECIATE THE WORD
HOLISTIC REVIEW BUT- IN SOME
WAYS THE TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARDS ARE WHERE THE RUBBER
MEETS THE ROLE ROAD- I THINK
IT'S- FOR US HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE PASS LAWS AND
WHEN THE TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARDS LAWS ARE PASSED I'M
NOT SURE OF THE AUTHORS. OF
THOUGHT THAT. THIS THE IN I
THOUGHT THE STATE STANDARDS
WERE SET PERCENT I MEAN I WHAT
YOU'RE- AND I KNOW PACKED
ISSUES. THAT FOR TO CHEAT A
HUNDRED PER IS MAY NOT. TOTALLY
REALIST BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION I HAVE THE IS THAT.
OKAY YOU SAID THAT SANDERS THAT
WE PUT INTO LAW THAT YOU'RE NOW
IMPLEMENTING TO REGULATION YOU
ONLY HAVE TO HIT IT 70% IS
THERE SOME MINIMUM STANDARD.
LIKE SO WHAT'S THE TAIL OF THAT
SO YOU KNOW WE GOT- WHAT'S A
TALE OF THAT CURVE- THAT SAYS
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT THIS PLAN
REALLY IS- ELSE OKAY THEY GOT
70% BUT YOU HAVE A CERTAIN
PORTION. OF THAT 30% THAT'S
REALLY DRAGGING OUT OR
SOMETHING. IS AND AGAIN I KNOW
YOU SAID HOLISTIC SO MAYBE LOOK
SOME OTHER FACTORS BUT- I
GUESS- I JUST. WANTED ONE BE
CAREFUL THAT- WHAT. SHOULD
PEOPLE REALLY EXPECT AND IS
THAT REALLY GOOD ENOUGH. AND SO
YOU KNOW WHEN WE PASS A LAW
HERE- AND I DON'T I'M NOT SURE
THE AUTHORS ARE THINKING LIKE-
WHAT IS THE STANDARD 470% OF
PEOPLE. AND I GET THE PRACTICAL
REALITIES OF THIS SO I IT
INTERESTING WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
BUT I JUST WANNA BE REALLY.
CAUTIOUS WITH THAT WHEN WE SAY
70% AND ALSO EXACTLY HOW DOES A
SKILL OR THE PARTICULAR
SPECIALTIES OR SOMETHING
BECAUSE SOMETHING ELSE
SOMEWHERE MAYBE A LITTLE
CHALLENGING TO GET BUT THEN.
STRATEGICALLY ALLOWS. A PLAN
NOT TO CONTRACT AS WELL FOR
CERTAIN MORE EXPENSIVE
SPECIALTIES OR OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS THAT. MAY BE MORE
CHALLENGING. AND THAT'S WHERE
THEY'RE SKEWING SO I THINK WE
NEED TO. SO CERTAINLY THE
OVERALL PERCENTAGE IS IMPORTANT
BUT ALSO LOOKING AT A
PARTICULAR AREAS WHERE ACCESS
IS. A PERHAPS LESSENED- IN THAT
30% THAT'S BEING DELAYED THAT
MAY BE MORE CONCERNING. THAN
WHEN WE LUMP EVERYTHING
TOGETHER. RESP THAT REALLY
QUICKLY I THINK WOULD WORSEN
THE RATE OF COMPLIANCE AND 70%
WHAT WE'RE SAYING THAT IS THAT
AT ANY GIVEN POINT IN TIME WHEN
WE MAKE THESE CALLS TO ASSESS
THE AVAILABILITY OF AN- THAT
SEVENTY. PERCENT COMPLIANCE
INDICATE THAT IN MOST CASES OF
A CONSUMER CALL THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET AN APPOINTMENT.
WITHIN THE TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARDS. IT'S NOT SAYING 30%
OF THE NETWORK NUMBER HAS AN
APPOINTMENT AND TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARDS AND AGAIN. CONSUMERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO GET A TIMELY
APPOINTMENT WITHIN TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS EVERY SINGLE
TIME AND IF THEY CAN'T- THE
HEALTH PLAN IS OBLIGATED TO
ALLOW THEM TO GO OUT OF NETWORK
AT THE END NETWORK KASHIRI RATE
SO I THINK. WE STILL HAVE THAT
CONSUMER PROTECTION. THE 70% OF
THE WAY TO WAS SAYS YEAH. IF
THE- THE ABILITY OF THE NETWORK
TO SUPPORT THE TIMELY ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS IT MAY MEAN THAT
IF YOU CALL THAT INDIVIDUAL
PROVIDER IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE AN
APPOINTMENT YOU COULD CALL. IT
A ONE OR TWO OTHER PROVIDERS
WITHIN THE NETWORK AND BE ABLE
TO GET IN A TIMELY. WELL THAT
OKAY FAA APPRECIATES THAT- I
THINK ULTIMATELY. IT'S GOING TO
COME DOWN TO THIS YEAR A
REGULATORY AGENCY IS HOW YOU GO
ABOUT ENFORCING AND AS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THESE THIS DATA AND
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT THAT DATA
IS VASTLY IMPROVED NOW. THAT
YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU GO ABOUT
ENFORCING IN A WAY THAT SENDS A
STRONG ENOUGH SIGNAL. AND I
KNOW MOST PLANS ARE TRYING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING BUT- THE
SENATE APPROPRIATE SIGNALS TO
THE PLANS THAT- ARE. BEING MADE
SEE. IS LOOKING CAREFULLY AT
ACCESS AND I KNOW YOU ARE. BUT
REALLY AND BEING SURE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE VARIOUS
NUANCES. OF HOUSE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING. AND THAT- THAT THERE
ARE CONSEQUENCES IF PEOPLE
AREN'T IT IF THERE IS CAN IT'S
YOU KNOW PEOPLE THERE ARE A
GROUP OF PEOPLE CONSISTENTLY
HAVING CHALLENGES GETTING
ACCESS THAT THE- AGENCY- AS THE
REGULATOR WILL ACT. AND HOLD
PLANS ACCOUNTABLE IT'S NOT
ENOUGH JUST TO TAKE COMPLAINTS
A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE DON'T
COMPLAIN NOT BECAUSE- DATE AND
THERE ISN'T A PROBLEM BUT- BUT
OFTENTIMES YOU PEOPLE. MEAN
FEEL LIKE ANYTHING WHAT. OR IS
TO CALM. TO GO AND YEAH USUALLY
TOLD THE CULT FOR AND THEN. THE
END OF. LIKE YOU YOU SOMETHING
AND- IT OUT FOR AWHILE THEN YOU
CALL THE INMATES SEE ITS
ADDRESS AND SET ITSELF. SO I
THINK INTHE END WE WANT TO
SEE. AND MY CONCERN BEFORE WHEN
WE HAD THE BAD DATA WAS WELL
HOUSE THE- HOUSE REGULAR GOING
TO ENFORCE THE LAW. RIGHT AND
SO- SO I THINK THE ULTIMATE
RESULT IS THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE. DATA ON. EXACTLY YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE THE CONSEQUENCES FOR
PEOPLE FOR PLANS THAT TO DATE
AT LEAST SEEMS OF. PEER TO
SHOW. THAT ARE NOT MEETING THE
STANDARDS AND- WHAT. WHAT
STEPS. THAT THE- US REGULATORY
AGENCY ARE TAKING TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PAYING PREMIUMS ARE GETTING.
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE GETTING.
FOR THE- FOR WHAT THEY ARE
PAYING. FOR AND THAT THEY GET
THE CARE THEY NEED. NINE AND
ARE REGULATIONS BE A GOOD. TO
HELP HELP US TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT OKAY THANK YOU OKAY. OKAY
THE MOVE ON. ISSUE NUMBER TO
THEM TOO OKAY THE DIMINISH THE
CURRENTLY UTILIZES A VARIETY OF
REGULATORY TOOLS TO ASSESS
WHETHER ENROLLEES ARE ABLE TO
OBTAIN TIMELY ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE SERVICES USE REGULATORY
TOOLS INCLUDE ROUTINE MEDICAL
SERVICES ANNUAL REVIEW OF
HEALTH PLAN PROVIDER NETWORKS
REVIEWING HEALTH PLAN ANNUAL
TIMELY ACCESS COMPLIANCE
REPORTS AND TRACKING AND
TRENDING IN REALLY COMPLACENT.
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW
APPLICATIONS. S. EIGHT FIVE
AMENDED. MENTAL HEALTH STATUTE
REQUIRING FULL SERVICE HEALTH
PLANS IN GROUP AND INDIVIDUAL
MARKETS TO COVER TREATMENT FOR
ALL MEDICALLY NECESSARY MENTAL
HEALTH. AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS LISTED IN THE MOST
RECENT RECENT VERSION OF THE
DIAGNOSTIC AND STATISTICAL
MANUAL OF MENTAL DISORDERS
KNOWN AS THE GSM. THIS INCLUDES
EXPANDING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER COVERAGE REQUIREMENTS
TO HEALTH PLANS IN THE LARGE
GROUP MARKET. THIS BILL ALSO
DEFINES MEDICALLY NECESSARY
TREATMENT OF A MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND
REVISES UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
AND SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT
REQUIRED HEALTH PLANS TO USE
REALIZATION REVIEW CRITERIA AND
GUIDELINES DEVELOPED BY NON
PROFIT PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION.
THE BILL EXPANDS THE HEALTH
PLANS RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP
ENROLLEES OBTAIN OUT OF NETWORK
HERE WHEN SERVICES ARE NOT
AVAILABLE THAT WORK. WITHIN
GEOGRAPHIC UNTIMELY DOCSIS
STANDARD. SB EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
REQUIRES A GMAC TO ANNUALLY
REVIEW HEALTHCARE SERVICE PLAN
DOCUMENTS FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT
REQUIREMENTS. THE ANNUAL
REVIEWS INCLUDE PRINCE EVIDENCE
OF COVERAGE DOCUMENT PROVIDER
CONTRACTS PLAN TO PLAN
CONTRACTS UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT GROUP INCLUDING THE
UTILIZATION REVIEW CRITERIA
DOCUMENTS AND NETWORK ACCESS
FOR SERVICE. IN THE EVENT THERE
IDENTIFIED DEFICIENCIES THE
GMAC MAGIC ENFORCEMENT ACTION
BY INVESTIGATING AN EXERCISE
MINUTES MINISTRY OF ACTION TO
PROSECUTE VIOLATIONS. INCLUDING
ASSESSING FINANCIAL PENALTIES
AND REQUIRING CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS. TO BRING DEFICIENT
HEALTH PLANS INTO COMPLIANCE.
THE DAMAGE THE REQUEST FIVE
POSITIONS AND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY IN AMOUNT OF ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION FOR FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. FIVE AND HALF THE SESSIONS
AND ONE MILLION 300-405-0004
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND I'M GOING FROM
THE MANAGED CARE FUND TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
SB FIFTY FIVE. THIS REQUEST
INCLUDED LIMITED TURN RESOURCES
OF TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO TO CONDUCT LEGAL
RESEARCH AND COMPILE AND
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS.
EMPLOYMENT SB THIRTY FIVE. THE
REQUEST ALL AND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND ANNUALLY
FOR CLINICAL CONSULTING
SERVICES. TO ASSIST WITH THE
CLINICAL REVIEW AND ANALYSIS OF
HEALTH PLAN DOCUMENTS INCLUDING
THE RADIO THE UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT. AND UTILIZATION
REVIEW CRITERIA DOCUMENTS. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REVIEW OF ISSUE
NUMBER CHOI THE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. OKAY RIGHT AWAY OPEN
THE- OVER THE DECADES AT THIS
BEEN FULL PARITY WE HOPE THAT
WITH SB SIX EIGHT THERE WERE
ACTUALLY GONNA GET THERE I
SUSPECT. OKAY A LOT OF
IMPROVEMENTS. FOR OUR REGION
ABOUT ISSUE NUMBER THREE. OKAY
UNDER EXISTING LAW DAMAGE THE
MONITOR THE FINAL SOBRE A PRESS
VERY OR- BUT DOES NOT LICENSE
THEM IN OUR VIEW IS A PROVIDER
GROUP THAT IN ITS CONTRACTS
WITH THE HEALTH PLAN PAYS
CLAIMS AND ASSUMES FINANCIAL
RISK FOR THE COST OF
PROFESSIONAL HEALTHCARE
SERVICES INCLUDE SUFFICIENT.
ANCILLARY AND OUR PHARMACY
SERVICES BY ACCEPTING A FIXED
MONTHLY PAYMENT FOR EACH IN
RALEIGH SIGN TO THE RPO. THE
DEAL MAKES THE FINANCE
STABILITY RPOS ANALYZING
MONTHLY QUARTERLY AND ANNUAL
FINANCIAL FILINGS CONDUCTING
FINANCIAL EXAMINATIONS.
REVIEWING CLAIMS PAYMENT
PRACTICES IN DEVELOPING AND
MONITORING CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLANS. AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRES THE GMAC TO CREATE AN
AUTHORIZED TWO PILOT PROGRAMS
IN CALIFORNIA. ONE IN NORTHERN
I WANTED SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BY
MAY FIRST OF THIS YEAR. UNDER
EACH PILOT PROGRAM INVOLUNTARY
EMPLOYEES BENEFICIARY
ASSOCIATION OR A VISA. OR A
TRUST FUND WOULD BE PERMITTED
TO UNDERTAKE WRIST. RANGELANDS
WITH THE PROOF PROVIDERS
WITHOUT BEING SUBJECT TO
LICENSURE UNDER THE KNOX KEEN
HEALTHCARE. SERVICE PLAN ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. THE
PURPOSE OF THE PILOT PROGRAM IS
TO DEMONSTRATE WHETHER THAT'S
CONTRACTING ARRANGEMENT LEADS
TO BETTER CONTROL HEALTHCARE
COSTS. AND IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND QUALITY OF SERVICE
WHEN COMPARED AGAINST A FEE FOR
SERVICE PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT.
THE PILOT PROGRAMS WILL BEGIN
INDEPENDENTLY AND OPERATE FROM
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE FEVER
OR TRUST FUND MUST CONTRACT
WITH A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER WHO
IS A RBO LIMITED LICENSEE OR
RESTRICTED LICENSE HE WAS
LICENSED AND REGISTERED WITH
THE GMAC- FEVER OR TRUST FUND
IS REQUIRED TO REPORT ANY IN
RALEIGH COMPLAINTS INCLUDING
THE RESPONSE AND RESOLUTION TO
THE GMAC ON A QUARTERLY BASIS
DURING THE TERM OF THE PROGRAM.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR REQUIRES
THAT YOU MAKE SPEECH REVIEW
ANNUAL COST SAVINGS CLINICAL
PATIENT OUTCOMES IN RALEIGH
SATISFACTION REWARDS IN
QUARTERLY REPORTING OF ANY
COMPLAINTS LODGED BY IN ROWLEY
DURING THE PILOT PROGRAM. WE
WILL ALSO REVIEW QUARTERLY
FINANCIAL REPORTS SUBMITTED BY
THE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
PARTICIPATING IN THE PILOT
PROGRAMS AND FINALLY WE WILL
PREPARE A REPORT. WITH THE PARK
PILOT PROGRAM FINDINGS WERE THE
LEGISLATURE BY JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. THE REPORT
MUST INCLUDE THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY THE B. BY OR TRUST
FUND ON COST SAVINGS. POLITICAL
PATIENT OUTCOMES ENROLLEE
SATISFACTION. FRIEDMAN AND
APPEALS AN INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEWS. AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRES THE PILOT PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS TO REIMBURSE THE
DNA TEST THE RIVER REASONABLE
REGULATORY COSTS UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. EAST
BOSTON CLOSE BIG CLUE THOSE
ASSOCIATED WITH DEVELOPING AN
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR THE
PILOT PROGRAMS MONITORING
COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS AND COMMISSIONING
THE REPORT THE LEGISLATURE. THE
DEAL MAKES THE REQUEST LIMITED
TERM EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTEEN THOUSAND
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. FOUR HUNDRED ONE
THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY
TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
THREE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
AND THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND AND FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX AND
THREE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SEVEN FROM THE
MANAGED CARE FUND IMPLEMENT AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. THIS
INCLUDES CLINICAL CONSULTANT
SERVICES TO REVIEW CLINICAL
PATIENT OUTCOMES REPORTED BY
PILOT PARTICIPANTS AND ASSIST
WITH PREPARING A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THIS AMOUNT WILL
BE A WERE REIMBURSED BY THE
PILOT PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS UP
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AS
REQUIRED BY ELEVEN AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. CONCLUDES MY
OVERVIEW I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. RICHARD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION
AND- I APPRECIATE I THINK WHEN
THE BILL WENT THROUGH FOR THIS
PARTICULAR- PILOT- I KNOW THAT
THE ME SEE DID HAVE SOME
CONCERNS- BUT NOBODY WANTED
WHEN THE POTENTIAL CHALLENGES
THAT WE NEED TO MONITOR IS- IS
ESSENTIALLY WE HAVE A LIMIT
WELL THE LEMONADE BUT WE
CERTAINLY DECREASE THE S. OR
THE FINANCIAL RESERVE PART OF
THINGS- BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
SAID WELL THE TRUST FUND- IS-
SO IT IS THE THIS PART OF THE
VALUATION I KNOW THERE'S
CERTAIN THINGS REQUIRED IN THE
LAW. I THINK BUT CAN BE MOST
IMPORTANT FOR THE LESSONS THAT
WE LEARNED IS ALSO WHAT QUE EL
IN WHICH WAYS THE BENEFIT
DESIGN PERHAPS VERY FROM THE
CURRENT STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE
AND ALSO THE- IS THERE ANY
POINT IN TIME IN WHICH THE- AND
MAY OR MAY NOT HAPPEN- DURING
THE EVALUATION PERIOD THAT IS
IN THE PILOT WHERE DEER MIGHT
HAVE BEEN EXCESSIVE FINANCIAL
RISK- AND HOW AND HOW OLD THE
ENTITIES RESPONDED TO THAT IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT YEAH AND I
KNOW THE PROVIDE FINANCIAL
REPORTS IS THAT SOMETHING. TEAM
MEETS HE'S GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT. NOT WHAT WE WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT ALL OF THAT NOT EASILY
WHAT THE FIGHT. RISK WE- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE WE HAVE AN RBO OR
A LIMITED OR RESTRICTED LICENSE
PLAN THAT'S INVOLVED SO WE HAVE
OUR ON GOING REPORTING OF THOSE
ENTITIES. IN ADDITION TO THE
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE
REPORTED BY THE BEEP AND TRUST
FUND- WE'VE ALSO DONE A LOT OF
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT MANY OF
THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE IN THE BOXYOU KNOW ACTOR
ALSO PART OF THOSE SO. THAT
WILL ALL BE PART OF WHAT WE
REVIEW AND REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. OKAY WELL THANK
YOU I THINK STEPS- A VERY. VERY
IMPORTANT AND I ALSO KNOW THAT
AND IF THEY DON'T IF MANAGER IF
YOU DON'T HOUSES- ARE. NOT
PARTICULARLY RELEVANT TO ISSUE
THREE BUT I DO WANT TO JUST-
APPRECIATE THE WORKERS TEAMMATE
CS WE'RE DEALING WITH A COLD
AND I KNOW IT'S NOT A BUDGET
ITEM IMMEDIATELY BUT- IN TRYING
TO- DO REGULATIONS TO ENSURE
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THINGS
LIKE TESTING AND VACCINATIONS.
I GUESS MY BUDGET QUESTION TO
THAT IS THAT- AT LEAST THERE'S
AT LEAST I HAVEN'T SEEN A
BUDGET REQUEST SO IN TERMS OF
DAEMI T.'S RESOURCES AND
CAPACITY AND DOING ESSENTIALLY
ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS THE
DRESS CODE- IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE ANY ADDITIONAL BUDGETARY
REQUESTS IS THAT IS THE V. AS-
WELL. SO THAT. I JUST WANNA BE
SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
BANDWIDTH NECESSARY TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON ON. THESE
REGULATIONS ENFORCEMENT- AS
WE'RE TRYING RESPOND CODED. NO
NO DO AND A GOOD. WE'VE YOUR-
REGULATION AND I THINK WE UP TO
A THIRTY ALL PLAN WATERS THAT
WE'VE ISSUE. AND YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY COVERED RESPONSE HAS
BEEN OUR PRIORITY FOR THE LAST
TEN MONTHS NOW- AND WHO KNOWS
TO AN AMAZING TEAM THAT WE HAVE
THAT IS. HAS PRIORITIZE THAT
WORK IN THE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE USING ARE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY. TO DO SO
TO CONTINUE TO ENFORCE ABOUT
THE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS ON
pABSORBING THOSE COSTS WITHIN
OUR WITHIN OUR EXISTING STAFF
AT THIS POINT. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR KNOWLEDGE IN THE WORK ABOUT
THE L. K. WELL I JUST WANNA BE
SURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING. AND
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER ANY
FEDERAL MONEY WILL EVER WILL
TRICKLE YOUR WAY FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING BUT I ALSO
CERTAINLY IS THE LEGISLATORS
WERE DOING THE BUDGET WANT TO
BE SURE THAT OUR REGULATORY
AGENCIES LIKE THE MEET SEE. DO
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
CARRY OUT- THESE POLICIES
APPRECIATE THAT'S BEING QUOTE
ABSORBS UP LASSEN KNOW YOU'RE
READY PRETTYBUSY WE DON'T
USUALLY STAFF YOU WITH A LOT OF
EXCESS CAPACITY SO- I JUST WANT
TO RAISE THAT ISSUE TO BE SURE
THAT- WE ADDRESS THAT. IF
NECESSARY IN THIS BUDGET
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN A-
COMMENTS FROM- DEPART FINANCE.
OKAY THEN I THINK WE'LL MOVE ON
TO THE MENTAL HEALTH. SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS TO BE DOING THE CANNELLA
SERVICES OVER SECOND KIND OF
THE COMMISSION. AND I'M JOINED
BY OUR DEPUTY NORMAN EIGHT.
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE
ANY- FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE CHANCE TO BE HERE TODAY
AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
PROTOCOLS THAT YOU'RE TAKING TO
KEEP EVERYBODY SAFE- AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO. TALK
TO A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE P. C.
P. THAT'S IN THE PACKAGE. FIRST
IN TERMS OF THAT. BROAD
OVERVIEW OF THE COMMISSION'S
WORK. WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT AGENCY THAT WE WORK
WITH OUR STATE COUNTY COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. TO PROMOTE AND
REALIZE TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE
IN OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. WE
HAVE I WOULD SAY FOR VERY BROAD
ASPECTS OF OUR WORK THAT
INVOLVED DATA. FUNDING
INCENTIVES CAPACITY BUILDING
AND WORKING TO INFORM POLICY%
DECISIONS. ARE DATA WORK SOME
SOME OF THE WORK WE'VE DONE
DATA MAY BE FAMILIAR WE ARE
WORKING TO MAKE IT VERY EASY
FOR THE PUBLIC AND POLICY
MAKERS. TO UNDERSTAND HOW OUR
SYSTEM IS FINANCED. THE KINDS
OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE SUPPORTED
IN THE OUTCOMES THAT ARE
ACHIEVED. OUTCOMES REPORTING IS
THE MOST DIFFICULT AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE. BASED ON SOME OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE THIS MORNING AROUND.
MONITORING THINGS LIKE- OUR
PLANE HEALTHCARE CLAIMS
DATABASES. GETTING DATA TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN TERMS OF OUTCOMES
VERY DIFFICULT. WE'VE HAD SOME
SUCCESS PARTICULARLY. IN IN
TERMS OF REDUCTIONS IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT THROUGH THE
RIGHT. TYPE OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT WE CAN DELIVER TO
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS. WE
PROVIDE. WHAT WE REFER TO AS
FUNDING INCENTIVES THROUGH
THINGS LIKE OUR SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH. GRANTS THAT ARE THE
SUBJECT OF THE B. C. P. THAT'S
ON THE AGENDA. WERE WORKING TO
BUILD OUT A STRONGER RESPONSE
EARLY PSYCHOSIS IN CALIFORNIA
RICE'S SERVICES AND SERVICES
FOR YOU. WE DO A RANGE OF WORK
THAT IS REALLY ABOUT CAPACITY
BUILDING HOW CAN WE SUPPORT
EFFORTS YOU ARE COUNTING
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO REDUCE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT.
TO STRENGTHEN OUR FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS TO PREVENT PEOPLE
LOOK TURNING TOWARDS CRISIS
ORIENTED SERVICES BECAUSE
THEY'VE GOTTEN EARLY
INTERVENTION KINDS OF SUPPORTS
FROM THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND
WE'RE WORKING TO BUILD AND
ESTABLISH LEARNING NETWORKS AND
COLLABORATIVE SO THAT OUR
SYSTEM IS IMPROVING CONSTANTLY
OVER TIME. WE ALSO INFORM
POLICY AND PRACTICE THE
COMMISSION. LAST YEAR ADOPTED
THE SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN
WE'RE WORKING TO IMPLEMENT THAT
NOW WE ARE STRENGTHENING CRISIS
RESPONSE STRATEGIES WE'VE GOT
THREE PROJECTS UNDER WAY. ON
MENTAL HEALTH IN THE WORKPLACE
WHICH IS AN AN EFFORT TO REDUCE
STIGMA STRENGTHEN PREVENTION
AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO CARE WE
HAVE A PROJECT THAT'S REALLY
EXPLORING. THE BOUNDARIES OF
PREVENTION WHAT THAT MEANS AND
HOW THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WITH A STRENGTH IN OUR MENTAL
HEALTH PREVENTION EFFORTS AND
THEN OF COURSE EVERY STATE
OPERA REPORT ON SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH. AS PART OF THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS RELEASED NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN N. IN
FUNDING FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH%
STUDENT SERVICES ACT AND AS
PART OF THE B. C. P. WE'RE
ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD
THAT OUT AS MENTIONED IN THE B.
C. P. THE COMMISSION LAST YEAR
RECEIVED JUST OVER EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN APPLICATIONS
FOR GRANTS TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING. AND IT
TO BE HONEST IT WOULD ACTUALLY
TAKE MORE THAN DOUBLE OF WHAT
WE HAVE ALREADY PROVIDED TO
BEGIN TO MAKE PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AROUND THE STATE THE
FUNDING THE EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS THAT WOULD
COVER THE UNFUNDED APPLICATIONS
WOULD ACTUALLY ALLOW US TO MAKE
SOME DOWN PAYMENTS AND ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF THE COUNTIES SO
WE REALLY THINK THIS IS PART OF
A LONGER CONVERSATION IN A
BROADER STRATEGY TO STRENGTHEN
HOW WE DELIVER CARE TO YOUNG
PEOPLE IN PARTNERSHIPS THROUGH
OUR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND OUR SCHOOLS SO
IT'S A PLACE TO START. AT WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS WORK
WE'VE HAD TREMENDOUS RESPONSE
FROM OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. IN
BUILDING OUT THESE
COLLABORATIVES IT WE'RE WORKING
WITH THEM TO BUILD A LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE SO THAT THEY CAN
COLLECTIVELY SHARE INFORMATION.
IDEALLY WITH SUPPORT FROM THE
COMMISSION AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AROUND FINANCING
PROGRAMMING STAFFING CARE
DELIVERY AND THE CONNECTION OF
SCHOOL BASED CARE WITH
COMMUNITY BASED CARE. WE'RE
ALSO WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN LINK
MENTAL HEALTH DATA AND
EDUCATION DATA SO WE CAN TRACK
THE IMPACT THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE HAVING. ON
OUTCOMES ASSOCIATE WAS STUDENTS
BOTH EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OUTCOMES.
THIS EFFORT AGAIN AS PART OF
THIS BROAD PORTFOLIO OF WORK
THE COMMISSION HAS IT REALLY
DOES LOOK AT DATA. INCENTIVES
CAPACITY BUILDING AND STRATEGY
AND THAT'S VERY QUICK I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN HERE MOST OF THE
AFTERNOON SO I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ABOUT EITHER A SPECIFIC
WORK OR THE ROLE THAT THE
MEDICAL STUDENT SERVICES ACT
PLAYS. IN A BROAD PORTFOLIO
EFFORTS AT THE COMMISSION HAS
UNDERWAY. THANK YOU AND I LOOK
FORTY SPEAKING TO A TO WITH YOU
A LOT MORE AND- BUT I AM ALSO
AWARE OF OUR TIME AND I KNOW
OUR CALLS. ARE RECALL CAPACITY
IS GOING TO STOP BY FIVE SO
WE'RE GONNA. GET THROUGH THIS
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE WOULD
COME BACK AND SPEND A LOT MORE
TIME WITH MENTAL HEALTH BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S A- HUGE AREA OF
CONCERN FOR ALL OF US RIGHT NOW
AND CERTAINLY A- SPECIAL AREA
OF CONCERN FOR ME- THE BATTLE
JUST OVERALL WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVER EUROPE
YOUR COMMISSION. ARE YOU ARE
YOU JUST LOOKING. AB AT THE
MONEY TAT COMES IN FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT OR
DO YOU ALSO LOOK AT THAT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH ALL OTHER WHEN
YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE MEASURING
OUTCOMES AND SEEING HOW A
PERSON IS A- TREATED IN THE
SYSTEM. ARE YOU ABLE TO TRACK
ALL THE INPUTS THAT COME IN TO
THE SYSTEM. IN ORDER TO SEE
WHAT KIND OF CARE IS REALLY
BEING PROVIDED. NOT YET I THINK
THAT THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT OUR
WORK IS IT SO. NOW SERVICES ACT
ACTUALLY INCLUDES A PROVISION
THAT SAYS THE PUBLIC THE
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE PART OF THE
DESIGN OF COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS. AND THAT
LANGUAGE IN OUR MINDS REALLY
APPLIES TO THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
RIGHT INCLUDING. ACCESS TO CARE
THROUGH COMMERCIAL INSURANCE
PLANS HOW ARE WE MAKING SURE.
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO CARE IN WAYS THAT IS
TIMELY. CULTURALLY
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE AND
EFFECTIVE. IN THE TOOLS THAT
THE STATE HAVE EXTEND BEYOND
THE DOLLARS THAT ARE ASSOCIATE
WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT. THAT THE POLICY IN THE ACT
REALLY ENVISIONS THAT THAT
BROUGHT EFFORT TO. ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
CURRENTLY HOWEVER BECAUSE OF
LIMITATIONS IN OUR ACCESS TO
DATA. ACCESS TO INFORMATION
ABOUT BOTH REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES WE'RE REALLY ONLY
ABLE TO TELL A LIMITED STORY.
THAT IS FOCUSED ON THE IMPACT
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
DOLLARS. AND EVEN THAT STORY IS
VERY LIMITED BECAUSE OF. VERY
SIGNIFICANT DATA CHALLENGES.
BUT IN MANY CASES THE STATE
ACTUALLY HAS THE DATA. BUT WHAT
WE HAVEN'T DONE IS PUT IN PLACE
THE SYSTEMS AND STRATEGIES TO
USE THE DATA SO I MENTIONED.
WAYS TO LINK MENTAL HEALTH DATA
AND EDUCATION DATA. OUR TEAM
HAS DONE AN EFFECTIVE JOB OF
LINKING MENTAL HEALTH DATA IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE DATA AND CAN
DEMONSTRATE IN SOME INSTANCES.
IF THE RIGHT KIND OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES CAN HAVE AS
MUCH AS A SIXTY NINE PERCENT.
REDUCTION IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT BECAUSE WE DELIVER
CARE IN A TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE FASHION. SO OUR
GOAL OUR INTENT IS TO ANSWER
THE BIGGER STORY THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR SENATOR BUT RIGHT
NOW WE'RE LIMITED BY CAPACITY
AND SOME OF THE CHALLENGES. AND
MOSTLY FOCUSED ON IMAGES SAY.
OKAY SO YOU'RE INTERACTION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE DO YOU HAVE MUCH
INTERACTION WITH THEM AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MANAGING COST
AND- IN TREATMENT. WHAT HAVE WE
HAVE WE HAVE MET WITH SAID THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE WE DO INTERACT WITH THEM-
WE ARE INCREASINGLY TALKING
WITH THEM VERTICALLY THROUGH
THIS EFFORT THAT WE HAVE UNDER
WAY. WITH THE DEPART WITH THE
THIS FOCUS ON MENTAL HEALTH IN
THE WORKPLACE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
EMPLOYERS TO KEEP PARTNERS IN
ENSURING ACCESS TO CARE AND
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO MEET
THESE BROAD STATEWIDE GOALS OF
ENSURING THAT EVERYBODY HAS
ACCESS TO CARE YOU CAN'T SIMPLY
BE THROUGH MEDICARE. OR AM I
JUST SAY AND SO THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE IS A IS A
KEY PARTNER WE'RE STILL
LEARNING ABOUT EACH OTHER'S
WORK WE'RE VERY INTERESTED IN
THE PARITY LEGISLATION HOW
THAT'S IMPLEMENTED. AND WE'RE
ALSO TALKING FOR EXAMPLE WITH
CALPERS AS A LARGE PURCHASER OF
HEALTH CARE ABOUT WAYS IN WHICH
WE CAN LEVERAGE THE STATE'S
PURCHASING POWER OR THE
PURCHASING POWER OF THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. REALLY SHAPE THE WAY
THE MARKET IS DESIGNED AROUND
CREATING AFFORDABLE ACCESSIBLE.
AND APPROPRIATE CARE ACROSS THE
STATE. SO IF IT JUST AND AGAIN
I AM NEW AT THIS I DON'T HAVE
THE HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE OF-
OF DOCTOR PAN BUT- IN IN
ESSENCE YOU SERVE AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE FOR. PROP SIXTY
THREE NINE. WELL THEY SAW THAT
THE ORIGINS OF THE COMMISSION
ARE ACTUALLY DESIGNED TO ENSURE
FIRST THATTHE MSA REVENUES
THAT ARE GENERATED- YOU TO
CREATE THAT PUBLIC TRUST THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY IN PUBLIC TRUST
THESE DOLLARS ARE WELL SPENT I
WOULD SAY MORE BROADLY IT'S
ALSO TO CREATE THE POLITICAL
CAPITAL THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDING AND SUPPORT THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY WHO NEEDS CARE GETS
CARE. IT'S SO. MET QUITE OFTEN
THE PERSPECTIVE IS THAT THE
COMMISSION REALLY OVERSEAS
DAMAGES A DOLLARS BUT THE LAW
IS VERY CLEAR THAT THE
COMMISSION IS AN OVERSIGHT
AGENCY OVER THE OUR SYSTEMS OF
CARE CHILDREN'S SYSTEM OF CARE
ADULT SYSTEM IF YOU'RE AN OLDER
ADULT SYSTEM A CARE BUT THAT
THE COMMITTEE BUT BECAUSE OF
THE LANGUAGE OF PREVENTION. IN
THE ACT WHICH IS VERY EXPLICIT
BUT THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT
RESPONDING TO PEOPLE AFTER THEY
HAVE NEEDS IT'S REALLY ABOUT
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY PREVENT THE ONSET OF
OR THE ESCALATION OF. FOR
SYSTEM L. L. AND BECAUSE OF
THAT PREVENTION LANGUAGE WE
REALLY SEE THAT AS A WAY IN
WHICH WE NEED TO APPROACH THESE
CHALLENGES TO A PUBLIC HEALTH
MODEL. OF REALLY THINKING ABOUT
POPULATION BASED STRATEGIES SO
IT'S VERY BROAD- OUR PRIMARY
ROLE ACTUALLY IS ADVISORY TO
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE ALTHOUGH IN RECENT
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR HAVE GIVEN THE
COMMISSION MORE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE ALREADY. AROUND THINGS
LIKE LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS.
WE ISSUE REGULATIONS FOR
PREVENTION AND INNOVATION OUR
WORK TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
PREVENTION CAN MEAN AND SHOULD
MEAN IN THE MIDDLE HOLE SPACE
REALLY COMES OUT OF SOME
LEGISLATION FROM A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO. THAT ASK THIS
QUESTION OF HOW CAN WE BETTER
UNDERSTAND OUR PREVENTION
EFFORTS ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE
IN PART OF THAT IS REALLY
TRYING TO START WITH WHAT WE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
WITH PREVENTION. AND WE DON'T
HAVE BROAD BASED AGREEMENT ON
THAT AT THE MOMENT NOT JUST NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIABUT IT BUT
YOU KNOW CROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT'S AN AREA WHERE- WE REALLY
HAVE TO. BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES LOOK LIKE
THAT WE CAN SHAPE HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN PURSUE THEM. AND
IF YOU'RE AN ADVISORY BUT IN
SOME RESPECTS OF A REGULATORY
WITHOUT ANY KIND OF REGULATORY
POWER CORRECT IF I'M WE
REGULATIONS FOR P. E. I. N. FOR
INNOVATION AND THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM IS SUCH THAT IF WE
IDENTIFY A CHALLENGE WE ARE
DIRECTED TO REPORT THAT REPORT
THAT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR- FOR
FOLLOW UP THROUGH THEIR
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES. I THINK
YOU HAVE WHAT WE HAVE WORK TO
DO OKAY THANK YOU TO WORK TO
GET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
IT'S- IT'S GOOD TO THE- PARTY
AND I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY JUST
A TOUCH ON TALK ABOUT
HISTORICAL IS THAT- AND AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AT THE
INTEREST IN HEARING MORE ABOUT
HOW THESE DIFFERENT DIESEL.
AND- GREAT- I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD AND SO I MEAN WE CAN TAKE
TO DO THAT- OFFLINE- JUST THE-
THE ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE'VE
HAD WITH AN HSA FUNDING BEFORE
AT HAS BEEN IS THAT SOMETIMES
SOME OF THE LOCALS THAT SAT ON
THE MONEY IN FACT- SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WE FOUND OUT THAT- WE
DON'T EVEN COLLECT DATA ON HOW.
QUICKLY TO MOVING THE MONEY
OUT. DESPITE THE DEMAND YOU'LL
THINK ABOUT HOMELESSNESS THINGS
OUTSIDE SCHOOLS ETCETERA- IS
THAT IS THAT PROBLEM BEEN
RESOLVED ARE WE GETTING- GOOD
DATA FROM COUNTIES ON HOW
THEY'RE SPENDING THE MONEY ON A
SPENDING THE MONEY THAT THEY'RE
GETTING IN A TIMELY MANNER. AND
SO I GUESS THAT'S A QUESTION
FOR BOTH- DAY OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION AND ALSO L. A. L-
THANK YOU CENTER PAN- YEAH I
APPRECIATE THE HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE I THINK WE HAVE
COME A LONG WAY- BUT YOU KNOW
BASED ON THE COMMENTS THAT YOU
AND THE BUDGET COMMITTEE HAVE
RAISED IN THE PAST WE HAVE SOME
SIGNIFICANT WAYS TO GO. OKAY
YEAH. IN THE IN A RECENT BSA
AUDIT I THINK IT WAS ISSUED IN
OCTOBER THE AUDITOR RAISED SOME
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ADEQUACY OF RECORDING- IT
REALLY REPORTING OVER THE
BROADER SYSTEM SO NOT JUST THE
MHSAA BUT THE OTHER REVENUE
STREAMS THAT ARE USED TO
SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA ON THE PUBLIC
SIDE IMAGES SAYS ABOUT 25% OF
THOSE DOLLARS I'M I DO THINK
THAT WE HAVE GOTTEN A STRONGER
SET OF RULES AND TOOLS IN PLACE
BUT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES- WE ARE ACTUALLY
DEMO OWING A AN UPDATED. THIS
CALL TRANSPARENCY TOOL THAT
WILL ALLOW POLICY MAKERS IN THE
PUBLIC TO. SEARCH AND SORT BY
COUNTY BY FISCAL YEAR
INFORMATION ON REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES AND IT IS SOME
COMPARISONS. BUT IN GENERATING
THAT TOOL. I GET FULLY
UNDERSTAND AND ARE WORKING WITH
THE H. YES AND COUNTIES TO
FERRET OUT WHERE THAT
pINFORMATION IS COMING FROM. SO
I WOULD SAY. WE'RE HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT WE
STILL HAVE SOME WAYS TO GO TO
CREATE A LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE
THAT YOU HAVE LOOK FOR IN THE
PAST AND- IN THAT WE THINK THE
PUBLIC DESERVES. AND JUST A
FOLLOW UP AND THEN ALSO BE
INTERESTED ALEJO'S COMMENT- YOU
MENTION AN AUDIT REPORT UNDER
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
RECOGNIZED CAME OUT THE OTHER
REPORT THAT YOU THINK WE SHOULD
BE PURSUING AND THIS BUDGET
CYCLE WHETHER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE OTHERS- THAT WE HAVE
NOT DONE SO YET. THE AUDITOR
THE AUDITOR HAS RECOMMENDED
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE EXPLORE STRATEGIES
TO STRENGTHEN. THE FISCAL AND
PROGRAMMATIC IN OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY. OF THE STATE
CONSISTENT WITH THE
COMMISSION'S WORK. AND THAT.
THAT AUDIT WAS RELEASED.
TOWARDS THE END OF THE LAST
CALENDAR YEAR THE GUY I BELIEVE
OCTOBER- AND I DO NOT KNOW IF
IT HAS YET BEEN EXPLORED. BY
THE BY A LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
OKAY WELL CERTAINLY I THINK WE
WILL SINCE YOU MENTIONED THAT
WE SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
AND SEE THAT WE CAN COOPERATE
IT INTO THIS YEAR'S- BUDGET. IF
NECESSARY SO AN ALLEY- ANY
COMMENTS ON THAT. NONE OF YOU
LOOK AT THE AUDIT REPORT ILIO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DR PAN
COREY HAS SHE DOES FROM HE L.
A. AS THE HOLY SEE MENTIONED
EARLIER THERE WERE- A NUMBER OF
ACTIONS LARGELY- DIRECTED
THROUGH THE H. C. S. IN
RESPONSE TO THAT STATE AUDITORS
REPORT- WEEK WE ARE CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU AND TO
FOLLOW UP ON SORT OF- WHAT
THOSE SPECIFIC ACTIONS WERE IN.
MEETINGS CAN SORT OF FOLLOW UP
AND PUT TOGETHER A PACKAGE OF-
WHAT WHAT HAS TAKEN PLACE SINCE
THE OTTERS REPORT IS CANNELLA
OKAY I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE I THINK WE SHOULD
INCORPORATE SOME OF THAT INTO
THIS COMING BUDGET IF THERE'S
THOSE GAPS- AND REPORTING AND
DATA TRANSPARENCY AGAIN AS A
TO. BUILD CONFIDENCE IN THE USE
OF THESE FUNDS AND PROVIDE MORE
TRANSPARENCY THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY SO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT PARTNERSHIP
GRANT PROGRAM. FIFTY SO MADAM
CHAIR I HAD I'D READ MY
COMMENTS IN ORDER TO SAVE SOME
TIME IF YOU KNOW INSURANCE THE
TECHNICIAN HAD ISSUED NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS.
THE APPLICATIONS INCLUDE.
EXTENDED PEOPLE ASKED THAT TO
THE LEVEL OF SLIGHTLY OVER
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS- THE
NEED IS ACTUALLY FAR GREATER
THAN THAT- THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU IS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS IN MEETING THE STUDENT
HEALTH NEEDS INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WHY NOT JUST AS
RATING. WELL WE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PHYSICAL LIMITATIONS
IN THIS ISSUE BACK WE WOULD BE
MORE THAN HPPY TO TALK WITH
YOU ABOUT EXPANDING THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXTEND THOSE
SERVICES BEYOND THE M. TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S IN
THE BASICALLY. OKAY THANK YOU
ANYTHING ELSE INSTEAD. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE LOOK FOR
TO TALKING WITH YOU MARTIN WE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE COVERED CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON AS SENATOR
EGGMAN CONSIDER PAN KATIE RAVEL
AND THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
ELIGIBILITY IN RESEARCH FOR
COVER CALIFORNIA VERY HAPPY TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY AND TO SHARE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR MISSION
AND RESPOND TO YOUR QUESTIONS
ABOUT ENROLLMENT IN SOME
POTENTIAL FEDERAL ACTION THAT
MIGHT IMPACT OUR PROGRAM.
EVERYONE CAN HEAR ME RIGHT YES.
THANK YOU I'LL GO ON AND AS YOU
KNOW THE FEDERAL AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT DRAMATICALLY CHANGED
IN THE INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKET WHICH IS WELL
SUMMARIZED IN THE COMMITTEE
MATERIALS AND AGENDA TODAY A
KEY COMPONENT OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT WAS THE CREATION OF
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE'S
THROUGH WHICH ELIGIBLE
AMERICANS CAN ACCESS. FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES TO REDUCE THEIR
INSURANCE PREMIUMS AND LOWER
THEIR OUT OF POCKET COSTS. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
BASED ON THEIR INCOME COVER
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE WITH
THE LARGEST STATE RUN EXCHANGE
IN THE COUNTRY WITH OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION ENROLLEES.
OUR MISSION IS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF INSURED CALIFORNIANS
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE QUALITY
LOWER COSTS AND REDUCE REDUCE
HEALTH DISPARITIES THROUGH AN
INNOVATIVE COMPETITIVE MARKET
THAT EMPOWERS CONSUMERS TO
CHOOSE THE HEALTH PLAN IN
PROVIDERS. YOU I WENT EVERY
EVERY. TO ARAMBULA DOC ON
EIGHTY FOUR AND- BUT INDICATED
TO DECREASE. OKAY THANK. OKAY
AHEAD THANK YOU OKAY. WE CAL IN
NEIGHBORING VILLAGES WHERE'S
LAYS OUT A CLEAR VISION FOR AN
ORGANIZED MARKET PLACE
CALIFORNIANS TO A QUALITY
COVERAGE ARE ENABLING
LEGISLATION INCLUDED SEVERAL
INNOVATIVE TOOLS THAT ALLOW US
THE ABILITY TO ACTIVELY
NEGOTIATE WITH HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND SEPARATIST A
PATIENT REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF OUR
CONSUMERS HAVE REVIEWS THOSE
WHO WILL SO MANY. YEARS IT. I
AND- PORTABILITY THE FIRST. IT
SHOWED. IT'S CAN. PORTABILITY.
FIFTY AND STATE EIGHT
INDIVIDUAL IF YOU COULD HOLD ON
ONE SECOND I'M KATLEHONG OF
CONNECTIVITY PROBLEMS ON OUR
SIDE WE'RE NOT JEALOUS PEOPLE
FOR FEDERAL SUBSIDIES FOR ALL.
EXCUSE ME THE PROGRAM ALSO
PROVIDED ASK FOR INCREASED
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR AN
INDIVIDUALS WITH INCOME BELOW
4100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
SECOND YEAR IF YOU'RE READY FOR
ME TO MOVE TO QUESTION TO OUR
REGION WE LOST YOU FOR MOST OF
THAT AND YOUR WE ARE CURRENTLY
FROZEN ON OUR SCREEN AND YOU'RE
HAVING SOME PROBLEMS WITH YOUR
CONNECTION. WELL. I THINK YOU
BY I THINK I'M BACK. OKAY I
I'LL REPEAT MYSELF A LITTLE BIT
AND TELL ME IF YOU'RE IF YOU
HEARD BECOME PARTS. WITHIN AN
HOUR OKAY. ALL RIGHT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. CALIFORNIA ENACTED
THE FIRST STATE A SUBSIDY
PROGRAM FOR INDIVIDUALS OVER
4100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. WHO ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES TODAY. AND
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE SECOND
YEAR OF THAT THREE YEAR PROGRAM
AND I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE AN
ENROLLMENT UPDATE IF YOU'RE
READY FOR ME O MOVE DOWN TO
YOUR SECOND QUESTION ON THE
AGENDA. I AM DOCTOR OKAY. GREAT
WILL HAVE FINAL NUMBERS TO
SHARE IN THE COMING WEEKS BUT
THE QUESTION WAS ABOUT OUR MOST
RECENT OPEN ENROLLMENT PERIOD
WHICH CLOSE JUST ON SUNDAY ON
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST. HAND
THREE JANUARY TWELFTH OF THIS
YER. WE HAD NEARLY ONE POINT
SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS I TO
RENEW THEIR COVERAGE OR SIGN UP
FOR NEW COVERAGE WITH US- THIS
NUMBER REPRESENTS AN INCREASE
OF ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PLAN SELECTIONS OVER THE SAME
TIME PERIOD LAST YEAR. ABOUT
90% OF OUR ENROLLEES RECEIVE.
FEDERAL AND STATE FINANCIAL
HELP. SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND RECEIVE THE STATE'S
SUBSIDIES THAT I MENTIONED AND
OF THOSE ABOUT- FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND. MIDDLE INCOME
CONSUMERS WITH INCOME BETWEEN
41006100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL STEEP STATE
SUBSIDIES. AN ODD THAT THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE RECEIVED UNDER
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM. THAT
QUESTION TO A QUESTION THREE-
ALSO TALK ABOUT OUR RECENT
FEDERAL ACTIONS IN THE FEDERAL
A SPECIAL ENROLLMENT EVENT SO
I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT NOW UNLESS
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS- SO ON
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH PRESIDENT
BIDEN SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT ESTABLISHED A FEDERAL
SPECIAL ENROLLMENT PERIOD FOR
ALL THE STATES THAT ARE ON THE
FEDERALLY FACILITATED
MARKETPLACE NOT SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT PERIOD. I READ.
BONZI. TWO FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH
THE CALIFORNIA IN COORDINATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT MANAGED
HEALTHCARE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FOLLOWED THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WE ANNOUNCED
OUR OWN SPECIAL ENROLLMENT
PERIOD FOR ALL CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET I PUTTING THOSE WHO
PURCHASED INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
COVERAGE OFF EXCHANGE. SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT PERIOD IT'S GOING
NOW IT RUNS FROM FEBRUARY FIRST
THROUGH MAY FIFTEENTH OUT WE IN
ADDITION COVER CALIFORNIA WILL
BE INVESTING AT LEAST SIX
MILLION OVER THE COMING MONTHS
TO RAISE PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT
THE SPECIAL ENROLLMENT EVENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT CONSUMERS.
ANYONE WHO NEEDS COVERAGE IS
ABLE TO SIGN UP. I WOULD JUST
MENTION THAT THIS IS SIMILAR TO
THE SPECIAL ENROLLMENT PERIOD
THAT WE. OFFERED IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
IMPACTED BY THE CODE NINETEEN.
INTERNET WE ACTED QUICKLY IN
MARCH TO IMPLEMENT THAT RAN
THROUGH AUGUST- WE INVESTED
ABOUT NINE MILLION IN PUBLIC
AWARENESS- TO MAKE SURE THAT.
CONSUMERS CAN SIGN UP FOR THAT
EVENT AND ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE TO SIGN UP INTO
THAT SPECIAL ENROLLMENT EVENT.
I THINK THAT WAS A RESPONSE TO
QUESTIONS WHO AND THREE ARE
THERE ANY ANY FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS FOR ME THERE. THANK
YOU. OKAY I QUESTION FOR TALKS
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT PROPOSED
CHANGES TO BE S. FEDERAL
PREMIUM TAX CREDIT PROGRAM-
THOSE ARE UNDER DEBATE NOW.
UNDER THE FEDERAL PROGRAM A
FEDERAL PREMIUM SUPPORT WOULD
BE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED AT
BOTH FOR INDIVIDUALS FOR L.
PEOPLE TODAY WITH INCOME UNDER
4100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL IT WOULD ALSO ELIMINATE
THE CURRENT FEDERAL CUT OFF FOR
SUBSIDIES AT FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT. SO ANYONE OVER 4100%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
COULD RECEIVE SUBSIDIES. IN
EXCHANGE SO THAT PREMIUMS
WOULDN'T HAVE TO COST THEM ANY
MORE THAN EIGHT AND A HALF
PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME- WE ARE
STILL LOOKING AT THIS PROPOSAL
DETAILS ARE EMERGING- BUT IT
DOES APPEAR THAT. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD PROVIDE A SUBSIDY
STRUCTURE THAT WOULD BE MORE
GENEROUS. THAN THE STATE
PROGRAM THAT OUR STATE PREMIUM
SUBSIDY PROGRAM. AND WE ARE
ANALYZING THAT LIFE IS BAD. AND
WEBER HELLO WORK WITH THE MANY
STRICT ADDITIONAL. ME BE EIGHT
EIGHT SUBSIDY CORRUPTION PER US.
LESTAT AND TO ANY YOU HAVE. DR
PLAN HAS SOME QUESTIONS AND-
AND YOU CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME
CONNECTIVITY ISSUES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT PRESENTATION
AND QUESTIONS. YES YES A DOCTOR
AND RICHARD PAN- SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT PRESENTATION
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE THE- THE AMAZING WORK
BEING DONE AT COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND- BY HERE AT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE FACT
IS THAT- IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE'VE HAD AN AVERAGE PREMIUM
INCREASES UNDER 1% THINK ABOUT
THAT IN THE EXCHANGE UNDER ONE
PERCENT- USUALLY WE CELEBRATE
ANY TIME THE PREMIUM INCREASES
LESSEN THE G. P. INCREASE CELL
BUT IT'S AGAIN GREAT JOB. I
GUESS MIKE- AND MAYBE HAVEN'T
HAD TIME TO LOOK AT IT SO MAYBE
YOU CAN FOLLOW UP ON THIS IS
THAT. SOME OF THE CHANGES BEING
PROPOSED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL-
WHICH D EXCEED WHAT WE WERE
ABLE TO DO HERE IN STATE BUT
YET WE DID TAKE THE FIRST STEP
THE STATE AT OUR OWN RISK TO
PROVIDE THOSE SUBSIDIES. WOULD
PART OF THE REASON WE WERE ABLE
TO GET THOSE- COSTS. DOWN SO I
DID SO AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT BE
VERY INTERESTED AND WHAT THE
ANTICIPATED ACTUARIAL IMPACT OF
THESE ADDITIONAL SUBSIDIES.
WILL BRING IN BECAUSE AS WE
BROADEN THE BASE OF PEOPLE IN
THE EXCHANGE- WE- THAT ALSO CAN
HELP BRING PUT DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON- DEEP ON PREMIUMS
AS WELL- SO- YOU MAY NOT HAVE
THE ANSWER RIGHT NOW BUT I HOPE
THAT WE CAN- FOLLOW UP ON. IF
THESE THINGS COME TO PASS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL- THE IMPACT
IT WILL HAVE ON THE- RATES
EXPECTED FOR THE FOLLOWING YEAR
AND HOW THAT WILL AFFECT
NEGOTIATIONS COVER CALIFORNIA.
HAS AS AN ACTIVE PURCHASER.
IT'S A GREAT POINT SENATOR CAN
WE WILL BE LOOKING AT THAT AND
LIKE YOU MENTIONED IT WILL
DEPEND ON THE LENGTH OF THAT
THAT AT. A TIME PERIOD OF THE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU OKAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE ILLEGAL OR
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. OKAY I THINK. SO
JUST- SO WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING
THE CURRENT SUBSIDIES SO
ESSENTIALLY ISRAEL GOVERNMENT
CARRIES THROUGH THAT AND WE
WOULD. NEED TO DO THAT. CORRECT.
THAT IS OUR INITIAL TAKE A DIET
APPEARS THAT THEY WOULD BE
WOULD BE MORE GENEROUS THAN THE
PROGRAMS WE HAVE IN PLACE TODAY
OKAY SO I GUESS I DON'T KNOW
WHEN WE'LL HEAR WORD WHETHER WE
CORPORATE THAT INTO OUR NEXT
DOOR BUDGET FOR THE FOLLOWING
YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WELL THAT CONCLUDES THE
BUDGET ITEMS. I THINK WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. AND AS
A REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX OH NINE- I THINK
WE'LL- WE BEGIN WITH. ARE THERE
ANY PEOPLE TO TESTIFY IN PERSON
NO THERE ARE NOT TODAY. AGAIN
AND DICK THE CONSTRAINT IN THE
TECHNOLOGY WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
ASK PEOPLE TO KEEP THEIR
REMARKS TO ONE MINUTE- SO IF WE
COULD ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO
WRITE COM PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY
OF THE BUDGET. THAT THE ITEM SO
FAR. I DO NOT SEE ANYBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SO NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE ANY WITNESSES ON
THE- TELECONFERENCE MONITOR.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD BEGIN TO
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
ASK A QUESTION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. REMOVE YOURSELF FROM
QUEUE AT ANY TIME BY PRESSING
ONE ZERO AGAIN. IF USING A
SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. BUT AGAIN IF YOU HAVE
A QUESTION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BEFORE WE
START MODERATE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GIVE ME THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE WAITING
ROOM. AT THE TIME HAVE EIGHTEEN
OKAY. THEN IF WE COULD OPEN THE
LINES AND CALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC INDIVIDUALLY. OKAY A
COMMENT FROM. ONE NUMBER EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND MAN AND J. D. ACT
HERE ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE AND THERE ARE SPENT
ON THE CREATION OF THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
FOR DAY FOR DECADES NOW
ADDRESSING UNSUSTAINABLE
HEALTHCARE COSTS HAS BEEN A TOP
PRIORITY FOR FTI YOU. AS YOU
ALL KNOW HEALTHCARE COSTS
CONTRIBUTE TO HEALTHCARE
INEQUALITY AND WORKERS FORGO
WAGE INCREASES TO PAY FOR
INCREASING COST OF CARE. WE
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND ALSO DIRECTOR
LEAN FOR RECOGNITION OF THE
OFFICES ROLE IN MONITORING COST
CONTAINMENT EFFORTS ON
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE STABILITY
AND THE TRAINING NEEDS OF
WORKERS. THIS IS TO ENSURE THAT
HOSPITALS AND OTHER HEALTHCARE
EMPLOYERS DO NOT CONTROL COSTS
SIMPLY BY CUTTING WORKER WE DID
OR LAYING OFF WORK WORKERS
ESPECIALLY NOW DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
RECTOR LANDSBERG COMMENTS
REGARDING REQUIRED PROVIDERS TO
REPORT AUDITED FINANCIAL
REPORTS AND WE HOPE THERE WILL
BE A PUBLIC REVIEW PROCESS
ATTACHED DOCUMENT DENTURE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OVERVIEWTHE ENTITIES. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE OFFICE AS
TBL COMES OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SILICON FROM LINE
NUMBER TWO FOUR ONE IS A PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
MEMBERS I THINK HE KNOW WHAT HE
THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY FAMILY
PHYSICIANS SPEAKING ON THE
OSCARS ITEMS ESPECIALLY THE
OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY. WE ARE GLAD TO
SEE DISCUSSION CONTINUE ON A
PUBLISHING OFFICE CULTURE
PORTABILITY WILL BE SUBMITTING
A LETTER LATER THIS MONTH OUR
OUR WHOLE COMMENTED TO AFFORD.
TO LANGUAGE BEING RELEASED IN
THE SPRING. DISCUSSION ONE OF
FOUR. NEED TO START SPOKE ON
AND SUPPORTING PRIMARY. WHICH
MULTIPLE SHOWED WHAT BETTER
HEALTH. PROMOTE EQUITY INCREASE
THE SUPPLY OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS AND LOWER COSTS.
INSTEAD OF THE CLEAR CONNECTION
BETWEEN ROBUST PRIMARY CARE
SYSTEMS INCREASED HEALTH
OUTCOME LOWER COST. KARAKUM
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED THESE
TRENDS WERE AMPLIFIED DURING
THE PANDEMIC FOR MANY OF OUR
PRIMARY CARE PRACTICES
STRUGGLED MIGHTILY JUSTIFIED IN
TWENTY TWENTY. EVEN REFORM WILL
NEED TO BE A PARENT
CONSTRUCTING ITS OFFICE BECAUSE
THE CURRENT PREDOMINANT PAYMENT
SCHEME OF PEOPLE SERVICE IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE ARE FORWARD
LOOKING. ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
MODELS MUST BE DELIBERATED AND
BUILDING NOR SHOULD AND SHOULD
REWARD VALUE OVER VOLUME GF HE
WORKS FOR THE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ASSHETON THIS
COMMITTEE TO THAT THOSE CONTACT.
JAPANOLOGIST DOESN'T EXCELLENT
LAYING THE AFTER OR AND RHODE
ISLAND THE PHYSICALLY WHICH
PRIORITY PRIMARY CARE AND THEIR
EFFORTS. WE HOPE YOU'LL TAKE
THESE CASE STUDIES ON THE
ACCOUNT ME POSITIVE OUTCOMES
THAT RESULTED FROM THOSE
INITIATED. ESPECIALLY IN
REDUCING COSTS. WE APPLAUD THE
MAINTENANCE AND SONG BRO. HONG
BROWN PROGRAM ENSURED THE
BURGEONING PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRAIN THING HOW. WHERE WE
HAVE A MAJOR DURING THE PREP
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS THANK
YOU HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM Y.
NUMBER. THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON YES MEAN
COVERED WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON ITEM
FIVE FROM ASHFORD. PART OF THE
OVERALL CONCEPT AND THE NEED
FOR AN OFFICE AND HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY DESPITE THE
GLOBAL PANDEMIC HEALTHCARE
COSTS CONTINUE TO RISE AND
CONSUMERS EAT RELEASE WITH YOU
THE OFFICE AS AN ESSENTIAL TOOL
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF HIGH
HEALTH CARE PRICES. ENFORCEABLE
COST TARGETS ACROSS THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY THIS TYPE
OF PROPOSAL WILL HELP SIX NOT
JUST SPECIFIC HEALTHCARE MARKET
FAILURES AND IT USES A PROVIDE
A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
CONTAIN HEALTH CARE COSTS AND
YOU'LL SAVINGS FOR CONSUMERS
AND OTHER PURCHASERS OF HEALTH
CARE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND MINISTRATION ON
THE PROPOSAL. ON COVER
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT STATE COVERED
CALIFORNIA PREMIUMS BUT STEVE
ALMOST ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ARE BENEFITING FROM. WHAT WE
ARE HOPEFUL THE BITE IN THE
MINISTRATION MAY OFFER
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE FOR COVER
CALIFORNIA OUR EXISTING
SUBSIDIES ARE SET TO EXPIRE AT
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE
MUST TAKE ACTION TO EXTEND THEM
FOR ANOTHER THREE YEARS A
PORTABILITY OF THE PREMIUMS AND
COST SHARING IN SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER TO COVERAGE WE HOPE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES SUCH AS
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE REVENUE.
WILL BE USED TO FURTHER
AFFORDABILITY HELP IN
CALIFORNIA FINALLY HELD BACK
WITH SUPPORT DEPARTMENTAL WORK
EMPLOYMENT BILLS WE SUPPORTED
INCLUDING S. U. SEVENTEEN S. B.
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE AND SB EIGHT
FIVE TWO THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. HOW FOR
ONE THIRTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEFF HANSON
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS REPRESENTING FORTY
FIVE PUBLIC NOT FOR PROFIT AND
FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
COLLECTIVELY DELIVER HEALTH
COVERAGE- PROXIMITY TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON HEARING IF WE WANT TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE FIVE IN THERE
ARE ON THE OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY. AND PART OF OUR
ON EFFORTS TO IMPROVE HEALTH-CARE AFFORDABILITY. LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE DETAILS
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE
OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY PROPOSAL. WE HOPE
IS THAT WE WILL CERTAINLY BUILD
UPON AFFORDABILITY MEASURES
THAT WERE SUPPORTED BY HEALTH
PLANS THE PREVIOUS BUDGET
BUDGET EXPANDING COVERAGE BUT
MANY. MORE LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. IN
EXTENDING. MEDIC OUT ONE
DOCUMENT INDIVIDUAL. THE
COMPANY. NOW AND PRIORITIZE OUR
CALL FIRST TO CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE HOPE THAT THAT THAT
WOULD REDUCE. THE IMPORTANCE OF
AFFORDABLE KIND OF REFERRAL.
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEES MOVING
FORWARD. I WOULD FORWARD TO
BEING A PART OF THE QUESTION
DROWNED OUT CHARACTER
PORTABILITY I JUST PROPOSAL
MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WITH THE COMMENT FROM
LINE NUMBER THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ADRIAN
SHELTON WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE A CHILD FAMILY
SERVICES WHICH REPRESENT THE
HUNDRED FIFTY NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
SERVING CHILDREN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES AND HUMAN SERVICES PUT
THEM WE ARE COM COMMENTING ON
THE ITEMS OF THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AT
THE PUBLICLY WANTED TO WEIGH IN
AT THE CORPORATE LEVEL HOPE YOU
GET THE PERFECT PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM I DID THAT WITH YOU. IN
THE PRESSURE OF THE NINETEEN ON
STUDENT THEY STRUGGLE WITH I
PLEDGE ISOLATION OF THE RAPID
CHANGE TO THEIR WORLD WE
BELIEVE ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE
NEEDED FOR THE PARTNERSHIP.
GIVEN THE NEEDS AND THE OVER
PRESCRIPTION APPLICATION THAT
COULD. NOT BE FOUND. I'M WE
BELIEVE ARE QUITE TO ENSURE
THAT HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH
SERVICES. WE WITH THE PORT
INCREASE BY THE PROGRAM EIGHTY
POINT MILLION WHICH IS THE OUT
THERE TECHNICIAN BUT- WOULD BE
REQUIRED FIND ALL OF THE SCHOOL.
HEALTH PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE MINUTE
DOES GREAT. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BITCOMET ONE NUMBER FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME OF THE
SONG AS AND I LOOK BACK NOW
THANKS SO MUCH RIGHT YEAH
COMMENTS LIKE BLACK COLOR I.
OFTEN LOOK AT. AND ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. KNOW WHERE WE- FOR. IF YOU.
FOR FORTY. HOW DO WE GET A WITH
OF THE FACT. WE WILL DO HOPE
THAT YOU. WE ARE HERE FROM
FORTY FIVE MILLION EIGHTY FIVE.
BOB THAT WILL WORK TARGETED ALL
OF THE OTHERS WILL COME EXACTLY
ARE. BUDGET WILL BE A REAL.
PUSHING HERE UNDERSTAND THAT
SCHOOL FROM PARTNERSHIP ARE
REALLY UNLIKE SOME OF THE OTHER
INVESTMENT IS MAKING A LITTLE
WHILE. YOU THE ROLE OUT WE'RE
GOING AFTER ALLEGE THE HERE IS
THERE WILL BE SUPPORTING EITHER
THE PARTNERSHIPS. FOLLOWING
TALK ABOUT- ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHERE I COME FROM ONE
THE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS A IT. I AM
A THE K. LINES FOR YOU THE
COMMUNITY JUSTICE. WE ARE
CALLED OF EACH AS AND STRIP
EIGHTY COUNTIES AND OVER.
THIRTY FIVE ORGANISED. AND PART
OF OUR OUR HELLO NEED ONE COME
BACK TWO DAYS IS ON A- NUMBERS.
OF THE- OFFICES YOU YOU
RESTORATION. ON THE HEALTHY
HUMAN AGENCY. IT IS JUST OUR-
WE JUST WANT TO KIND THAT-
WE'RE ABOUT STAFFING IN THE
BUDGET ALLOCATE- YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF THE POINT SOMETHING
MILLION FOR NINETEEN POSITIONS
YOU KNOW IN COMPARISON THE
HORSE RACING BOARD IS FORTY
EIGHT. AT FORTY POSITIONS ON A
BUDGET OF SIXTEEN MILLION. AND
A MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION HAS THIRTY SIX
POSITIONS. AND IN THE BUDGET
AND THEN THEY HAVE SEVENTY
MILLION. AND SO WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS NEW OFFICE WILL
FOCUS ITS ROLE AND FUNCTION
THAT IT'S FUNDED AND STAFFED
ADEQUATELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE COMING FROM ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THERE ARE FLOCKS I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK THE TEN AS A COMMENT ON
EQUITY CENTERED PROGRAM WHICH
IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE UNDER HHS.
FIRST ON THE POST CODE BUT
EQUITY ANALYSIS IT IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUT
INSUFFICIENT WE'RE GLAD TO HEAR
THE AGENCY IS CONSIDERING
CONVENING STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THE FINDINGS OF THE
ANALYSIS. AND WE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT PLAN OF ACTION-
BE INCLUDED AS PART OF THE
PROPOSAL AND THE PLAN SHOULD
COVER ALL THE RELEVANT
DEPARTMENT AND BE CONCRETE
ABOUT THE TIME LINE AND
PROPERTIES. AND TO IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ANALYSIS.
ON LANGUAGE ACCESS POLICY WE
WOULD REQUEST THAT THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY REVIEWS THE
TRANSLATION. ON THE EQUITY DASH.
WE DO HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF
WHERE AND WHY YOU'RE MISSING
HEALTHEQUITY DATA BUT WHAT WE
REALLY NEED OUR INVESTMENT FIX
THE PROBLEM- AND TO BEYOND THE
DATA GAP ISSUE WE WOULD ALSO
WANT TO FEED THE DASHBOARD
INCLUDE INFORMATION ARE AT A
LEVEL THATIS ACTIONABLE. AND
ALSO REQUIRE A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO ESTABLISH THE
DASHBOARD AND COMPONENT. FIND
WHAT TRAINING WE DO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL ANTI RACISM IN
EQUITY TRAINING FOR STATE
DEPARTMENT STAFF. BUT HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THAT THE EXISTING CARE PROGRAM
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO HAVE DATA
AND OUTCOMES FROM THAT PROGRAM
BEFORE THE DECISION IS MADE TO
EXPAND- THIS PARTICULAR
TRAINING PROGRAM. AND OVERALL
WE RECOMMEND THAT HHS DEVELOP
AN OVER ARCHING STRATEGY TO
ADVANCE EQUITY- WITHIN ALL OF
THEIR DEPARTMENT ONE THAT TIES
TOGETHER- ALL OF THESE ASPECTS
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY. BODY WITH
CLEAR STOPPING AND WE DO
APPRECIATE AND THE INCLUSION
AND EMPHASIS ON EQUITY IN THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE FOR THE
PORTABILITY AND CONTINUED
EXPANSION OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE- FOR CONSUMERS IN
COPPER CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SEEN OUR THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
COMES FROM NUMBER FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'RE BACK IN
POLITICS FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER- WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY ESPECIALLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC SO THEREFORE WE
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WHICH WE BELIEVE
IS NECESSARY CAN FORCE ****
FORGET TO PREVENT INFLATED
HEALTHCARE PRICES- WE OPTED FOR
AFFORDABILITY AND PORTABILITY
ASSISTANCE AND ARE COVERED
CALIFORNIA. AND IS THAT THERE'S
HAVE STATED WEARE HOPEFUL THE
BY THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
EXPAND FEDERAL ASSISTANCE BUT
WE NEED TO EXPAND STATE
SUBSIDIES THAT WILL EXPIRE AT
THE END OF THE YEAR- LASTLY
WERE ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE AS SB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE AND FUNDING TO
ENFORCE THE BAD MENTAL HEALTH.
PARITY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TIME
IT COMES FREE ONE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOME AND
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. SHE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY FOCUSED
ON EQUITY AND RECOMMEND EFFORTS
BE EXTENDED BEYOND FRAMEWORK
DEVELOPMENT TO QUICKLY
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS. WHERE CLEAR
GAP SUGGESTS FOR EXAMPLE
WESTERN CENTER IN ALIGNMENT
WITH DEFENDER CLASS THAT THAT
THE GROUP UP BY ONLY FILL
TESTING PER KEATING MEDIC HOW
TRANSLATION IN ADDITION. ARE
RELATED TOSH SAID WE SUPPORT
THE OFFICE THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
LOW WAGE WORKERS BUT STILL
EXPECT ADDITIONAL EXPECTED. TO
CONTRIBUTE MORE OF THEIR WAGES
TO HEALTH COVERAGE WE CANNOT
GET TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE IF WE
DO NOT RAIN AND THE COST OF
pCALIFORNIA WE ECHO HEALTH ACT
OF HIS COLLEAGUES TO ENSURE
CONTINUITY SO THAT CALIFORNIANS
WHO RELY ON SUBSIDIES FOR
HEALTH COVERAGE DO NOT HAVE TO
GIVE UP COVERAGE DUE TO THE
LOSS OF THE SUBSIDIES. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT FROM LONDON
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR CAN PARKER GLAZER WITH
A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. WE WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS ON THE
PROPOSED TOPIC THAT HEALTHCARE
PORTABILITY HOSPITALS RECOGNIZE
AND EMBRACE THE OPPORTUNITY
GOAL TO MAKE HEALTH CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE. THIS IS NOT EASY
AND IT HAS BEEN A LUCIFER
POLICYMAKERS FOR DECADES IN
PART BECAUSE UNDERSTANDING THE
DRIVERS OF HEALTHCARE COSTS IS
EXTREMELY COMPLEX. ON
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY WE
MARKET RISE OF THE STRATEGY WE
PROCEED TOGETHER WILL BE
SUSTAINABLE AND ENSURE THERE
ARE NO DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON
QUALITY AN ACCENT. IMPLEMENTING
SUCH AN INITIATIVE IN
CALIFORNIA WILL BE NO EASY TASK
OUR STATE IS HOME TO FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE IN MANY MANY
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS. WHEN IT'S
ROCK RIGHT WILL REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT UPFRONT WORK TO
ENSURE COMPLETE RELIABLE
CONSISTENT AND UNDERSTANDABLE
DATA THAT WILL DRIVE ACTION IN
RESPONSE. CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
ARE ALREADY HIGHLY EFFICIENT
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITAL SPENDING
WITH THREE POINT 6% LOWER IN
THE NATION. CALIFORNIA
ENCOURAGES THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER ESTABLISHING AN
INDEPENDENT NONPARTISAN ENTITY
A CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF THE
FEDERAL MACTAC FOR MEDICAID TO
PROVIDE EXPERT ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WILL PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL DATA AND PERSPECTIVE
TO INFORM DECISION MAKING ABOUT
HEALTHCARE COSTS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THIS PROPOSAL
IS CONSIDERED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TIME IT COMES FROM THE LINE
NUMBER TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME MR
JERKER REPRESENTING THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION I'M
SPEAKING OF THE COURT OF ISSUE
SIX UNDER OSTAD RELATED TO
ALZHEIMER'S HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. THERE'S
A HUGE NEED IN THE GERIATRIC
WORKFORCE BASE AN INDIVIDUAL
LIVING WITH DEMENTIA ARE
UNIQUELY IMPACTED BY THIS LESS
THAN HALF OF INDIVIDUALS LIVING
WITH ALZHEIMERS OR DEMENTIA
HAVE BEEN GIVEN A DIAGNOSIS AND
ONE OF THE MANY REASONS FOR
THIS CHALLENGE. IS CAPACITY IN
THE RELEVANT FIELD THIS BUDGET
ITEM HELP ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
IT- THE BAR BY THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING AND ITS FOCUS ON
EQUITY A PRIORITY FOR OUR
ASSOCIATION. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THE FIGHT ON AS WELL AS THE
ADDITIONAL ALZHEIMER'S FOCUS
ITEMS. AS WEL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- COUNTY MORE
CALLS ON THE LINE. WE HAVE
FIFTEEN REMAINING OKAY THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. COME FROM MY
NUMBER THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MD HILLARY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND I'D
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THE OFFICE
OF HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY
PROPOSAL. YOU MAY SUPPORT
MAKING HEALTHCARE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA BUT WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE APPROACH
OUTLINED BY THE- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
TRAILER BILL WHEN IT BECOMES
AVAILABLE. AND WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR INTEREST IN
ENGAGING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSAL MOVES THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS EITHER HERE
IN THE BUDGET. PROCESS OR ON
THE POLICY SIDE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. YES COME
IT COMES FROM ONE NUMBER
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I THINK MIGUEL
GARCIA AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND A FORMER U. AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE. I'M CALLING REGARDING
ISSUE NUMBER SIX THE OFFICE OF
THE COMMUNITY RESTORATION OR
WHAT YOU ARE BOB BARGAIN
ADDITION ISN'T THE PORTABLE
LIKE THE OUR ORGANIZATION HARD
CONCERNED THAT THE CURRENT
RESOURCES. ARE INSUFFICIENT OR
LIKE THE ART THE BILL WE
EXECUTED TO BE AT THE LEVEL
REQUIRED GIVEN THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF THE AGENCY ROLE
ENSURING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE CLOSER AND NOT
HARM CALIFORNIA AND WAS BORED
WITH THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATORS LAST YEAR. OKAY
EIGHT TWO THREE SOME OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM TOWARD TO
HELP A FAMILY APPOINT AND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT APROACH THANK YOU
HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT
FROM. MY NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN AND MEMBERS
SUBCOMMITTEE I'M BILL KRAMER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH
POLICY AT THE PURCHASER BRINGS
GROUP ON HEALTH FORMALLY KNOWN
AS THE PACIFIC BUSINESS GROUP
ON HEALTH. A. B. H. IS A NON
PROFIT COALITION REPRESENTING
NEARLY FORTY LARGE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYERS. OUR
MISSION IS TO IMPROVE QUALITY
AFFORDABILITY AND ACTUALLY OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. ORDING
ITEMS UNDER NUMBER FIVE PBJ
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE PROPOSED
OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY. IS A CRITICAL
STEP FORWARD IN ADDRESSING THE
PROBLEM THAT COSTS ARE MUCH TOO
HIGH MAKING ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE ON AFFORDABLE FOR MANY
PEOPLE. CROWDING OUT WORKERS
WAGES AND CROWDING OUT PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
PROPOSED OFFICE INCLUDES A KEY
FUNCTIONS WHICH- OF BUILDING ON
THE EVIDENCE BASED INSURANCE
ENSURING TRANSPARENCY SETTING
COST TARGETS. PROVIDING
INCENTIVE TO BEAT THOSE TARGETS
WE BELIEVE ALL THOSE ARE
NECESSARY. WHEN FULLY
FUNCTIONAL THE ACTIVITIES OF
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WILL BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS AND
CONSUMERS AS WELL AS SMALL AND
LARGE BUSINESSES. I THINK THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AND HELPING TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
CAN GET HIGH QUALITY AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
COME IT COMES FROM THE LINE
NUMBER FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THEIR BRIDGE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
COMMENTING ON THE ITEM UNDER
THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT WE
WOULD LIKE TO AKNOWLEDGE AND
APPLAUD THAT NO CUTS TO BE MADE
TO THE LAW MARTINEZ GARCIA
PROGRAM. AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE REQUESTED FUNDING TO
SUPPORT ON GOING AND YOU
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
THAT CREATE A MORE JUST ROBUST
YEAR AFTER WORK FOR. OUR NUMBER
YOU HAVE CONCERNS ON ISSUES
FIVE REGARDING OFFICE
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY WHILE
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT
OF THE OFFICE AND RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO ADDRESS AFFORDABILITY
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD STRESS THE
NEED FOR THOUGHTFUL AND
THOROUGH PLANNING DURING THIS
PROCESS AND ECHO THE COMMENTS.
MADE BY THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTICIPATING IN THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS AND DIFFICULT
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
COMMENT FROM NUMBER TWO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS KELLY MAC MILLAN AND
BMB OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION AND NEARLY THE
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
DENNIS AND THEIR TEAMS
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY TO
HELP US FORGE COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIPS PROVIDERS LOCALLY
TO HELP MORE EFFICIENTLY
DISTRIBUTE STATE STOCKPILE
SUPPLIES THE PRICE AND
AVAILABILITY OF PP ANOTHER
INFECTION CONTROL SUPPLIES.
CONTINUES TO BE A MAJOR BURDEN
FOR DENTAL PRACTICES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE GENERALLY SPEAKING
PROVIDERS ARE PAYING AS MUCH AS
TEN FOLD MORE THAN PRE COLD IT
FOR NEW MANDATORY INFECTION
CONTROL SUPPLIES. IN ONE
EXAMPLE THE PRICE OF OUR CLUBS
FOR A REACHED A WIDELY WEEK TO
WEEK AND SOMETIMES AS MUCH AS
FIFTY DOLLARS A BOX. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE EMSA IS TO
COORDINATE WITH THE STATE
STOCKPILE IN THEIR COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS TO ENSURE THAT
SUPPLIES ARE APPROPRIATELY
DISTRIBUTED AND EMPHASIS SHOULD
BE PLACED ON PROVIDERS OUTSIDE
OF FORMAL HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS
LIKE DENNIS AND PRIVATE
PRACTICE PHYSICIANS THAT ARE
UNABLE TO PURCHASE SUPPLIES AS
EASILY AS HOSPITAL SYSTEMS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
LOCALLY MSAS ON FUTURE STARS
STATE STOCKPILE DISBURSEMENT
STRATEGIES. THANK YOU AND HAVE
A GREAT EVENING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN COMMON PLEAS. COMMENT
LINE TWO TWO GO AHEAD. BUT I'M
TERM MEMBER THIS IS BOB EURO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE CAL
JULY US FOR. WOULD LIKE ALIGN
OUR ARE SO WITH THE AND CAN.
RAISED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATIONIN REGARDS
TO THE PROPOSED THE PROPOSAL TO
CREATE AN OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WELL IT'S STILL
VERY EARLY IN THE PROCESS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BCP SETS FORTH
A VERY AGGRESSIVE POLICY
PROPOSAL IN AN AGGRESSIVE TIME
FRAME. AT A TIME WHEN EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS AT OUR HOSPITALS
ARE STILL DOWN BY FIFTY
PERCENT. INPATIENT DAYS ARE
DOWN BY 15% AND OVERALL REVENUE
WAS DOWN BY TWENTY PERCENT.
COMPARED TO TWENTY NINETEEN IF
WE GET THIS KIND OF POLICY
CHANGE A WRONG THE IMPACT ON
CHILDREN'S HEALTH COULD BE
SEVERE AND THE ACCESS. TO LIFE
SAVING TREATMENTS SUBSTANTIALLY
DELAYED WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER CJ'S MORE RICK
MEASURED APPROACH IN WOULD
ALLOW THIS BODY TO BE A REGULAR
PART. OF THE DECISION MAKING
BASED ON THOROUGH AND
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS. IN A
MACTAC LAKE MICHIGAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU. COMING FROM MY
NUMBER FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND DR PAN CONNIE DELGADO
ON BEHALF TO DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY FOUR
DISTRICT AND MUNICIPAL HOSPITAL
HERE TODAY VOICING OUR CONCERNS
FOR THE PROPOSAL ON THE
OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY. MEMBERS TO
HOSPITAL SHARE THE GOAL OF
MAKING HEALTH CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR CONSUMERS
EMPLOYERS TAX PAYER BUT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT CONSTRAINING
THE COCKPIT CARE WITHOUT
BENEFITING PATIENTS. HEALTHCARE
COSTS TARGETED COMPOSED IT MUST
BE DONE CAREFULLY TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE NO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WHICH COULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE ALREADY
FRAGILE DISTRICT POLITICAL
HOSPITAL THE HOSPITAL ARE VERY
DIVERSE BY THEN SERVICES
OFFERED ALL PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
LEVELS OF CARE TO THE UNINSURED
AND MEDICAID POPULATION. TWO
THIRDS OUR WORLD AND HALF HAVE
CRITICAL ACCESS DESIGNATION AND
THE HOSPITALS ARE STANDALONE
FACILITY WITHOUT THE RESOURCES.
OF THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC NEED TO
HOSPITAL OPERATE ON THIN. DID
AT THE MARIANNA BREED WILL
CREATING. WILL CALL YOU IN
LOOKING. WANT TO KNOW THAT ARE
MEMBERS. ARE REMEMBER THERE CAN
WORK BILL TO BECAUSE BUT
FACTORS THAT CAN WITH POTENTIAL
TO HOP CLOSER NOT ONLY EASILY
CONTROL. AND BECAUSE IT HAD
EXACTLY THE- ISSUE. VIDAK
DRIVERS WILL NOT BE EASILY
ATTAINED UNDER HIGHLY HIGHLY
INTEGRATED MODELS OF CARE WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO CUT THIS
QUESTION WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO CARRY
MUCH MAKES COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT
COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR AND DR PAN-
AWARENESS INTERFERE ITH
SECTION POLICY HOPING TO SPEAK
ON THE ISSUE OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE PORTABILITY AND
ECHO. THE COMMENTS FROM WITHIN
FEDERAL POVERTY AND SEE PAN ON
HEALTH EQUITY- EITHER RELATE TO
THE OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY CALIFORNIANS FACE
THE HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS. AND THE COST OF
HEALTHCARE SIGNIFICANTLY
OUTPACES INFLATION AND WAGE
GROWTH AND CONSUMERS ARE HURT
IN THE END. BECAUSE OF THE
MARKET FAILURES THAT HAVE LED
TO HIGH HEALTHCARE COSTS THE
STATE HAS A BIG ROLE IN PUTTING
FORTH WILL COST TARGET TO
PREVENT INFLATED HEALTHCARE
PRICES. THE OFFICE WILL HAVE
THE ABILITY TO THAT REGION BY
REGION AND SECTOR BY SECTOR
GOLDMAN COSTS AS WELL AS
QUALITY IN EQUITY GIVEN THE
INDUSTRY TOOL COMMUNITIES GOALS
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IF THEY
DON'T. AN OFFICER HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY WITH A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE WHOLE
HEALTH SYSTEM OULD HAVE THE
BEST POTENTIAL TO ENSURE THAT
THE BENEFITS OF REFORMS
ACTUALLY REACH CONSUMERS
EMPLOYERS WORKERS AND TAXPAYERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT COMMENT
FROM NUMBER SEVEN PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR DR
MAKE IS BIANCA LONG THE IN YOUR
POLICY ADVISER SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IN MARIN. RESEARCH AND
EDUCATIONAL. DEDICATED COULD
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND THEN
THEIR ROBUST PARTICIPATION IN
OUR ECONOMY. ALL BUSINESS
OWNERS A ROUGHLY HALF OF
AMERICANS PRIVATE SECTOR
WORKFORCE AND OUR THIRD PARTY
INDEPENDENT POLLING AND
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT 67%
OF SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WERE
ON WHO ARE ABLE TO OFFER HEALTH
COVERAGE TO THEIR WORKFORCE.
YOUR WILL TO AFFORD IT AND THIS
WOULD BE FOR THE PANDEMIC
OCCURRED IN NINETEEN BE
ALTERNATE ACROSS THE HEALTH
CARE SIGNIFICANTLY OUTPACES
INFLATION AND EVEN WAY TO GROW.
THE OFFICE OF AFFORDABILITY
WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO THAT
REGION BY REGION AND THAT
STANDARD PLAN CALLS ON COSTS AS
WELL AS QUALITY AND EQUITY. WE
ALSO FULLY SUPPORT EXPENDITURES
TOWARD COVERED CALIFORNIA
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES FROM THE
BUDGET WHICHIN FACT EXPIRE AT
THE END OF NEXT YEAR AND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS RELY ON THE
SUBSIDIES TAX PREP PROGRAMS.
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES OFTEN RELY
ON THE SUBSIDIES WE APPRECIATE
THE CONTINUED COMMITMENT FROM
THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP THE
COVER CALIFORNIA MARKETPLACE
AFFORDABLE AND AFFORDS THE
BIDEN MINISTRATIONS WORKED FOR
THEIR FEDERAL PORTABLE
AFFORDABILITY AT THE TENT.
CALIFORNIA FIRST OF ITS KIND
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES ARE
POLITICIAN THAT WE HOPE TO
BUILD UPON BY LOWERING PREMIUMS
AND FURTHERING COST SHARING
ASSISTANCE THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
COMMENT PLEASE. WE HAVE A CALL
FROM ONE NUMBER. ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING I'VE NEVER
CHAIR PAN FELIX WITH LUCIA CAL.
YOUR COMMENT ON THE ISSUE FIVE
UNDER ACOSTA THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY. WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE CONCEPT
IN THE VISION OF HIS OFFICE AND
WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE
PROPOSAL REVIVED IN. ITS FIRST
BIJECTION UNDERSTAND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT LED TO IT
BEING TABLED LAST YEAR. OUR
VISION OF THE NONPROFIT HEALTH
PLAN IS TO ENSURE EVERY
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AT AFFORDABLE PRICE.
WE BELIEVE THAT AN OFFICE ARMED
WITH BOTH GOOD DATA AND
OVERSIGHT FROM COSTCO TARGET
YOU CAN HELP ACCOMPLISH THAT
MISSION. SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE RELEASE OF THE TRAILER BILL
AND WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. COMMENT
FROM NUMBERS THREE PLEASE AHEAD.
HI THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND DR
PAN ALLEY OKAY ARE DO WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM AT THE ORTIZ
AND COUNTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES ACT
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM UNDER THE
L. A. C. AND ALSO WANTED TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO DR PAM'S QUESTION.
ABOUT HOW COUNTY THEY'RE DOING
IN EXTENDING THEIR IMAGE THAT
THEY FUND MISTER EWING
MENTIONED THE ONLY HE'S WORKING
ON A PHYSICAL DEATH PASSWORD
WHICH WE ACTUALLY WERE ABLE TO
PREVIEW YESTERDAY ACCORDING TO
THIS DASHBOARD AND PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE DAC ASK. INFORMATION
COUNTIES ARE EXPANDING THE
BATHROOM JORDY OF THEIR IMAGE
THAT THEY FIND WITHIN TWO YEARS
WELL BEFORE THE THREE TO FIVE
YEARS OF CURRENTLY ALLOWED BY
STATE LAW IT IS CLEAR FROM THIS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DHS DATA AND
THE SOON TO BE AVAILABLE OAC
FISCAL DASHBOARD EMERGENCY
CONSERVING SPENT. NEEDED ONE
CRITICAL SERVICES FOR THOSE
MOST IN NEED OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES INCLUDING
CHILDREN OLDER ADULTS THE
HOMELESS JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH.
AND OTHERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY.
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT HELLO
NUMBER NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
AND I ATE AND JENNIFER O'MALLEY
AND I'M CALLING- REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
AND I AM STATISTICALLY SPEAKING
TOWARDS ISSUE NUMBER FIVE UNDER
OSP ED IN THE OFFICES HEALTH
WORK HERE FOR THE BILITY. SAID
IF THE CREATION OF THAT OFFICE
CAME OUT. MANY YEARS OF WORK BY
COALITION OF CONSUMER LABOR
BUSINESS HEALTH PROVIDERS AND
HEALTH CARE PLAN TO ADDRESS THE
SOARING COST. OF HEALTHCARE FOR
WORKERS AND CONSUMERS IN THE
STATE AND FOR YEARS ARE UNION
MEMBERS HAVE FORGONE WAGE
INCREASES IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING TO MAINTAIN
AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY HEALTH
COVERAGE WITH MAJOR. FINANCIAL
CONSEQUENCES. ANY OF OUR
BARGAINING WITH EMPLOYER ARE
TIGHTER TO. EMPLOYERS TO SHIFT
RISING OF HEALTHCARE ON TO
WORKERS IN THE FORM OF HIGHER
SHARE OPINIONS. THE IMPOSITION
OF THE DOCTOR BILLS AND HIGHER
DEDUCTIBLES AND CO PAYS. AND WE-
ABSOLUTELY SHARE IN SUPPORT OF
THEIR OFFICE AND WE ARE EAGER
TO. SEE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OUR
COALITION MEMBERS. AND WORKING
TOWARDS CREATING A SYSTEM TO
IMPROVE ACCESS AFFORDABILITY.
AND QUALITY OF HEALTHCARE IN
THE STATE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS COLIN
PLEASE. CONNECT COMMENT FROM
LINE NUMBER FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THE QUALITY
CONTROL KIRK THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE CREATION OF AN
OFFICE THAT HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY AND FOR
INCREASING AND EXTENDING
COVERAGE CALIFORNIA PORTABILITY.
NO DECREASE THAT CALIFORNIANS
ARE FACING A HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
EXACERBATING IT EXACERBATED BY
THE PANDEMIC AND IT SHOWS THE
NEED FOR US TO HAVE A LOT OVER
THE OF THE HAPPY TO SPEAKING
ABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY OUR
HOPE THAT- AND OFTEN HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY BUT A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE WHOLE
SYSTEM WHAT HAPPENS THAT'S THE
TENSION BETWEEN SURE THAT THE
BENEFITS ARE PERFORMED.
ACTUALLY REACH CONSUMERS
EMPLOYERS WORKERS AND TAXPAYERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
THANKS CON PLEASE. AND THE LAST
COMMENT ONE OF FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE
NANTWICH TO FUND. CALLING TO
SPEAK ON ISSUES UNDER
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND YOU
SERVICES AGENCIES REGARDING THE
NEW OFFICE AND USING COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. I'M CALLING HE
EXPRESSED WRONG. THAT THE
RESOURCE WILL CRACK WILL CLOSE.
TO DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF STAFF
AND EXPERTISE ARE INSUFFICIENT
FOR THE NEW OFFICE THE FULLY
EXECUTED STUDENTS AT THE LEVEL
REQUIRED GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS AGENCIES ROLE ENSURING
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND CLOSURE COULD NOT
HARM ARE YOU. AND MOVE TOWARD
THE INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE
LAST YEAR BUT SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY THREE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN TOWARD THE HEALTH BASED IN
TRAUMA INFORMED YOU DEVELOPMENT
APPROACH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THAT. WAS THE
LAST CALL YOU SAID RIGHT
CORRECT ERIC. YES ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE MEMBERS OF.
TO DOCTOR AND YOU HAVE ANY THE
DISH COMMENTS OKAY. THEN THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. I THINK
EVERYBODY WHO PREPARED FOR
TODAY AND ATTENDED TODAY. WE
HAVEA LOT OF WORK IN FRONT OF
US AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO IT-
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION AND THIS HAS
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA ITEMS FOR
TWO DAYS. BUDGET AND FISCAL
FINANCE SUB COMMITTEE THREE IS
A DIFFERENT.